[Music]
oh
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
welcome back to the best business show
this is the show that my brothers and i
wish
that we had when we were learning about
business investing in finance
it's the best business show because we
simply said it's the best that's how
this works on the internet i am here
with two of our brothers joe and john
we are in for a big treat how do you
know the names of joe and john real
simple names are on the back of their
chairs there we go
joe's earpiece hanging over his shoulder
hanging down real low
i got my oat milk i'm ready to go we are
ready today all right here's the deal
ready we got a whole bunch of stuff for
you let's break it down from the top i
need you to go
get some coffee get some water maybe get
some food you're just going to want to
sit down it's going to be a long long
show but we're going to be here with you
the entire time
we are going to start streaming now
obviously we're live it's amazing and
we're going to go until we get tired we
have lined up murderers row of guests we
will clemente we have miami mayor
francis suarez we have jack mahlers we
have dylan leclair natalie brunell
danny boy hustle hard will be coming on
the show
give us a little street knowledge of
what's going on with inflation we p uh
press and pitch we have anil from delphi
digital
and pj kev will be coming live in studio
as well to break down the private jet
business
we've got a ton of other special guests
lined up throughout this show
so we are just going to sit here and we
are just going to stream and we are
going to talk about bitcoin we're going
to talk about economics we're going to
talk about finance talk about inflation
how we're getting gaslit by politicians
everything that you possibly could want
us to talk about we're going to talk
about but of course this wouldn't be the
best business show if it was only
learning or laughing there's obviously
got to be earning opportunities as well
so to start with number one
number one
every 15 minutes we're giving out 100
worth of bitcoin all day long until we
finish i don't know what time we're
gonna finish we already have food orders
in we've got coffee orders we've got
bathroom breaks whatever happens for the
next couple of hours you'll be with us
and we're just going to stream and
stream and stream and stream
learn laugh and earn every 15 minutes
we're gonna give out a hundred dollars
for the bitcoin all we ask of you is
just press the like button free content
for hours i'm sitting down i never sit
down i'm sitting down i'm buckled in i'm
in my battle station the boys are in
their battle station
we are just going to sit here and stream
for hours and hours
i'm not asking anymore press the like
button
we're just going to do this all day long
we're going to answer every question you
got or do our best that we can anastasia
said the whole family's watching day 15
people pomp let's go let's get it i
appreciate it guys
we're gonna we're gonna do a little
orange pilling if you if you're watching
with your family by the way tweet us a
picture tweet us a picture and we'll
pull it up on the show we're just gonna
sit here and we're gonna orange pull as
many people as we can go get your mom
your dad grandma we're watching your
sister get your grandma get your dog
it's your neighbor get your cousin get
your wife's boyfriend just go get
everyone you know tell him to come watch
the best business show cause today we're
not playing around sitting in the room
watching
with your wife and her boyfriend might
be difficult but hey listen i don't make
the rules if you got to do that that's
what you got to do i mean
that is a picture people got weird lives
out there whatever send us a picture yes
that's a picture of you and your wife's
boyfriend maybe a video
get some reactions going or something
all right
the next thing
is
it's black friday and on black friday i
get in a real good mood because i know
that people are buying gifts for
christmas holidays i'm a big holidays
guy i like it i don't think that you
should be allowed to put up your
christmas gifts before thanksgiving that
should be illegal my wife's already
learned that lesson but
i do think that it's holiday cheer
and so here's how we are going to do
today today is your opportunity to be
interactive with the show
if you go into the store the
bestbusiness show.com if you go into
that store
we have every single item there is 21
off 21 off
why 21 because 21 is important for
bitcoin the best business show.com 21
off you can go get all of your holiday
gifts you can get everything from this
ugly christmas sweater you can get the
one joe's wearing we got all kinds of
gear in the store but if you go in there
here is what we are going to do
if you buy 100
of gear in the best business show uh
store we will give you a live shout out
on the show we'll say what your first
name is the first initial of your last
name and where you live so you'll get a
shout out if you spend 100 in the store
today
if you spend 500 in the store today then
we are going to go ahead and we are
going to make a personalized video me
and my brothers will sit down you spend
500 or more in the store and we will
make you a video and we'll send it you
can tell us what you wanted to say in
the video it could be a shout out to
somebody you know it could just be us
telling you that bitcoin's going to the
moon whatever you want
if you spend a thousand dollars today in
the store we will send you a link and
you can join us on today's live stream
for three minutes you can talk about
whatever you want no [ __ ] bitcoins
no shilling altcoins but if you spend a
thousand dollars in the store today we
can see on the back end when you do it
and we will send you a zoom link you can
join the live stream for three minutes
and you will get to talk about whatever
you want
lastly
lastly
whoever spends the most money in the
store this weekend
we will fly them to miami and you can
come hang out with us for a day
you will come on the show and be a guest
host for a whole day i don't know how
much money it will take to win
the most this weekend but whoever spends
the most money in the store this weekend
we will bring you to miami we'll fly you
here and when we fly you here we will go
ahead and have you join us as a guest
host so 100 bucks you get a shout out
500 bucks you get a personalized video a
thousand dollars you'll join the live
stream and if you're the person the
lucky lucky person that spends the most
money this entire weekend then you will
get flown to miami and we will go ahead
and have you join us for
as a guest host
this to me feels like probably one of
the nicer bigger things that we've done
i don't know how this is gonna go
but i do know that we're gonna do a lot
of shouting out we already got some
people that we gotta give shout outs to
the personalized video john is gonna be
in charge of as always
and then a thousand dollars or more
joining the live stream this is the one
i'm the most nervous about because i
have no clue people are gonna come on
what they're gonna talk about what
they're gonna do but if you spend a
thousand dollars or more in the store
then we'll go ahead we'll bring you on
you can knock yourself out you can talk
about whatever you want we'll go ahead
and give you the floor for three minutes
no shilling all coins or we'll kick you
off immediately but other than that
then anything goes you got a small
business you want to promote it knock
yourself out go buy a thousand dollars
in the store you got some cars you want
to talk about that's fine you want to
ask us a question have us answer it
that's fine too whatever you want
thousand bucks in the store you'll get
to come on and then we'll finally end up
picking biggest the biggest is flying
someone here because that's open-ended
we have no idea where you're coming from
what what it's going to take to get you
here i don't care someone said if could
i just if i spend 100 could i get a
twitter follower from all three of you
yeah sure dm mail follow you if you dm
me the receipt though
that's fine if you spend a hundred
dollars then we get a little twitter
follow too i already dmd my receipt can
i get a shout out uh no but i do not
i do got one thing to say cause we're
not putting up with any of this nonsense
anymore daniel rack you need to chill
out buddy all right
he's in the comments he's been coming at
john for weeks here we got a lot of
giveaways to go through all right buddy
hey daniel all i'll say is i'm not the
one holding it up well i just sent him
his money so he's good you're done now
stop complaining all right
it's in your bitcoin wallet now be quiet
all right
all right joe's chose violence this
morning
he keeps coming in he's spamming
i hear people talking about will you fly
me from australia yes will i fly you
from south africa yes anywhere you are
in the world if you're the person who
spends the most money in the store this
weekend and we'll keep you updated as we
go and monday we'll tell everyone okay
here's what the top spender is so far
but anyone in
the
entire audience i don't care where you
are in the world i will fly you to miami
and you can come hang out with us for a
day
lastly
is remember sofi
has this is probably the most incredible
thing advertiser's done with us uh so
far
is
sofi is going to allow anybody you can
go to sofi.com you can sign up for the
credit card that they have when you sign
up for the credit card you immediately
add it to your digital wallet on your
phone you can go in the store and buy
something with the sofi credit card if
you buy something up to 50 they are
going to give you 50 in rewards so that
it negates the purchase of what you're
buying you basically get the item for
free for getting the sofi car pretty
cool how they're doing this so you can
go to sofi.com pomp and you can go ahead
and get that credit card go into the
store and buy anything you want with
that and you'll be ready to rock and
roll
okay are we ready to go hold on john
wants to show you all the stuff in the
store real quick and then we're gonna
get some information by the way if this
is the first time watching the show
buckle up go get some coffee go get some
food you're in for a treat today go
ahead check this out so drone pal just
got reappointed as the fed chairman
if you want to get paid in bitcoin
that's what that says right there in the
corner pay me in bitcoin black and white
available who's satoshi we don't know we
are all satoshi
[Laughter]
miami vibes obviously show's being
streamed from miami the miami collection
and i'm tired of people calling everyone
supercoders so we're going to make it
cool to be a supercoder got that one too
and then obviously the ugly christmas
sweater we rocking those all day 100k
hats the ugly christmas sweaters are by
far the best you've ever created only
bitcoiners no phew you know what there
may be a i'm not going to get into it i
guess
you said
hey listen if you're in lockdown in
australia we'll break it out no problem
bring me in bitcoin
john's still going all right john you
got any more over there no i'm done okay
there's more stuff in the store there go
check second thing we just we just hit
600 likes so to get started just to show
everyone if you're new here if you if
somebody told you go watch this show
right now let us show you how this works
we're going to give out 100 with a
bitcoin right now ready one two three
everyone go ahead and press the like
button when you press the like button
we're gonna pick one person if you're
not new to the show you know how the
game gets played go into the chat and
just leave your twitter or your
instagram handle we're gonna pick one
person john's gonna pick who it is and
we're gonna send you a hundred dollars
worth of bitcoin
while we are waiting for you to hit the
like button and go ahead and drop your
twitter or instagram handle into the
chat
you know what time it is it's friday yes
it's black friday yes it's a special
show yes it's a long stream
but it's still friday and there's only
one
way
to start off
friday
[Music]
what
[Applause]
there's just something about mufasa that
just gets your blood going
all right do we have who the 100 winner
in six million yeah i got someone for a
hundred dollars yeah who's
the first hundred dollars of bitcoin
going out the door who is it it is jim
whipple jim whipple shout out jim shout
out jim
i need love in the chat i need some love
in the chat every time somebody wins
every 15 minutes a hundred dollars where
the bitcoins going out the door
hopefully i don't go broke by the end of
the show and that was only 13 minutes i
was told somebody just messaged me and
told me to hold this up actually it was
johnny pointed at me told me to hold it
up but this is the bitcoin wrapping
paper if you don't have bitcoin wrapping
paper then it's not a real gift you
don't care about your loved ones unless
you have bitcoin wrapping paper everyone
knows that right that's facts that's
facts if you don't use this wrapping
paper it's not a real gift but you
didn't care enough to get a real well
let's put it this way you go under the
tree you see a present here present
there you see one with bitcoin that's
the first gift i'm opening
that's true that is true okay now
we are going to
get into first let's start with john
how was thanksgiving thanksgiving was
great for me i enjoyed some nice food
spend some quality time with some family
and friends and yeah i had turkey
stuffing mac and cheese what about you
guys
i i saw you yeah i mean we we hung out
on thanksgiving uh but it was good you
know food football chilling oh football
couple drinks double drinks couple
drinks how many drinks
uh not too many you know not too many
all right all right we got a bunch of
stuff bitcoin's price is down we know we
know we see the the comments in the chat
we got it so here's how we're gonna get
started today bitcoin's price is down
but that doesn't mean that all of the
underlying metrics show a bearish story
we went this morning the best business
show research team and we went ahead and
we looked at a couple of metrics that
say what exactly is going on the price
is going down but does that mean
everyone's selling their bitcoin of
course not the very first metric i saw
is that we hit an all-time record world
record in the number of bitcoin
addresses that have at least .01 bitcoin
or more of a balance so at least 0.01
bitcoin as the balance in the number of
bitcoin addresses so over 9 million 297
000 addresses globally have at least .01
bitcoin in their wallet address now that
means that bitcoiners are using the
price drawdown as an opportunity to
stack sats if the price goes down and
you have long-term conviction of the
asset people are going to dollar cost
average they're going to accelerate it
is at an all-time high we've never had
more bitcoin addresses in the entire
world on the bitcoin network with at
least .01 bitcoin in them or more then
the second statistic that i went and i
looked at was that more than 89
of all bitcoin in circulation is in
profit what does that mean that means
that 89
of all bitcoin that is in the
circulating supply the last time that
somebody bought that bitcoin was at a
lower price than it is today so if they
were to sell it today they would capture
a profit rather than a loss which is
pretty impressive that's a very very
different story than what you are seeing
in the media or with that price drawdown
most people majority of people are still
in profit which is important joe john
what do we think when we see that the
bitcoin addresses are continuing to grow
and that most people still 90 of people
are still in profit
yeah i don't think it's really that
surprising right i mean we were at our
near all-time highs a few weeks ago
we're still uh tremendously much higher
than we were much much much much higher
than we were a year ago and i saw uh
there was a tweet earlier i think uh it
was what were we at 13k last year during
black friday right so like we've
appreciated a lot obviously if you look
back 10 years the history of bitcoin's
price has appreciated a lot so the
address is uh being in profit is not
really that big of a surprise i think a
lot of the people that have gotten in
over the past 12 to 24 months are still
massively in a profit so that's not
really surprising but the number of
addresses
and wallets is is a good sign i think
we're just continuing to see adoption
day every day and we we talk about this
all the time but the the main thing is
right when you have that fixed supply
all people are worried about now is just
continuing to see adoption globally and
i think what we're going to find over
time is not only is that going to happen
on a retail level but the big flows are
going to come from institutions and as
more institutions get comfortable with
this stuff as not only a store of value
but hopefully eventually a medium of
exchange we're going to see that price
continue to appreciate and i think when
you when you look at the price that's
happened uh over the last we'll call it
10 or 15 days it's really not that
concerning because sure yeah one you can
just zoom out and look what has happened
over the last year and see how many
addresses
are still in profit but ultimately when
you think about the global adoption of
this asset like we're still in the very
early innings of it uh and that
ultimately is what's gonna drive the
price higher and if we're in the early
innings of adoption you you would assume
at some point uh from a monetary
standpoint of kind of what we can see
from an inflow perspective that we're
still in the early innings from a price
standpoint also which i think is uh
exciting to watch for sure john what do
you think over nine million
addresses i'm sure some people have two
different addresses but nine million is
a small number i think in the grand
scheme of things of where we'll see it
go
bitcoin price has drawn down a little
bit i treat it as a black friday sale
it's nothing new it's volatile
volatility works both ways and i look at
the technology part of it right so you
see more and more companies kind of
building on the technology we have jack
mars coming on later on the show who is
the founder of strike
and look it will i think people will
continue to use this technology and what
fascinates me is every time i see
someone send those large large large
transactions over the bitcoin lightning
network for small amounts of money it's
baffling me because that's never been
seen before you see people literally
spend bill send billions of dollars
for two to two dollars banks can't do
that banks charge you thirty dollars to
send a hundred sometimes right so i
think the technology aspect is
underrated in my opinion and people
generally focus on the price and i'm
more looking at the entire grand scheme
of things more adoption more technology
and infrastructure built around it and
the price is just something that
will if all everything else goes up will
also go up over time somebody just spent
a thousand dollars in the store we have
the very first we're the first person
that's gonna be joining the show live on
the live stream we're gonna get you a
link some i don't wanna say what the
name is yet but we'll get you a link we
somebody just spent a thousand dollars
in the store which means that they're
gonna be coming on the live stream
that's how this game is gonna work start
it off day long people if you go in the
store and you spend 100 bucks you get a
shout out 500 you get a personalized
video thousand bucks you get to come on
the show biggest spender you're gonna
get a trip to miami go ahead joe where
are you gonna say what i was just gonna
say what was your tweet yesterday banks
are closed bitcoins always open
facts fast
listen the fact that is 2021
and you literally cannot access your own
money because humans decided there was
hours of operations is absurd we live in
a digital automated world except for
everything with money somehow the
bankers the people who put on the suits
and ties they put on their clone they
slick back their hair they got a little
gold chain around their wrist and they
hit you up and they say hey i need you
to go ahead and deposit your money at my
institution how about instead of feeding
your face with turkey overnight instead
open up your bank so if i want to send
money to somebody or maybe i just want
to access it i want to have the peace of
mind to know that i can always get to my
money
that is not what happens in legacy
system bitcoin's always open doesn't
matter you it's completely
permissionless you can send it to anyone
you can receive it from anyone you can
do it at any time 24 7 365 it's always
running it's always up it's always on
and there is no hours of operations and
so when you start to think about how
antiquated it is the u.s stock market is
closed more hours a week than it is open
it's closed more hours in a week than it
is open why because humans are lazy and
we hadn't come up with hours of
operation instead bitcoin the
cryptocurrency markets open 24 7 365. so
obviously markets can open and operate
all the time why doesn't the stock
market do that because it's antiquated
because it is outdated but that will
change eventually i do believe the stock
market will be 24 7 365 it's just going
to take some time to get there we'll see
more volatility if it's 24 7 365 right
and the fact that it's not open
the entire time is ridiculous and also
it kind of irks me a little bit that
some people have the ability to trade
after hours and others do not um because
obviously companies report earnings
right when the closing bell happens and
then in turn you don't get to kind of
take advantage of the knowledge that is
open to the public right it's not
insider trading everyone has that
information once they report it but yeah
i think uh it shocks me that it's not
open i tweeted something out the other
week that was basically like it was a
friday night or something like that and
i was like someone just transferred a
billion dollars in bitcoin and paid like
a 150 a dollar 50 cent fee while
everyone else is the people are that are
screaming that bitcoin is uh a ponzi
scheme and all this stuff are gonna wait
for their bank to open on monday so
they're gonna wait all weekend for their
bank to open they're gonna go wait in
line for an hour and pay 35 to transfer
five thousand dollars right so and when
you and
like it's just like when you think about
in the context of the world we live in
now versus that system like i don't
understand how it's apparent how it's
not apparent to everyone that that's
gonna change right and you can argue
what the end solution is but the idea
that you have to wait the entire weekend
you have to go into a physical location
to transfer money and pay a fee to do
that at your bank like that's a joke and
that's not the place all over the world
i get that here in the united states it
certainly is at a lot of these banks uh
my bank you literally it's the worst
experience in the world going in there
sometimes it's just terrible and granted
the people that are there are trying to
do their best they're not trying to make
it more difficult than it is but
ultimately that's just the
infrastructure that's set up so when you
see those things of people transferring
a billion dollars and paying a dollar
fifty cent fee like it's absurd to not
uh ultimately see that that's going to
be the end solution uh for the
infrastructure of banking and money
thanks our banks are an awful experience
to deal with customer service going in
no matter how you deal with them there
is a fee associated with almost
everything and there's a wait time
associated with almost everything
thanksgiving statistics are coming out
now around purchases and according to
adobe analytics the online spending
during november and december is on track
to hit over 200 billion dollars that's a
10 year-over-year increase and would be
an all-time high they estimate that
consumers will spend about 5.1 billion
to 5.4 billion online just yesterday on
thursday on thanksgiving
and they believed that the uh top end of
the range is coming down so they
actually was gonna be 5.9 now they
believe it's gonna be 5.4 billion
dollars or so spent yesterday uh and
what ends up being really interesting is
that shoppers have spent at a pace of at
least 3.5 million dollars per minute on
thanksgiving
3.5 million dollars a minute spent
online yesterday during thanksgiving to
buy stuff so we've got this quote here
from taylor shriner the director of
adobe digital insights says in the midst
of a holiday shopping season
characterized by inflation weaker
discounts and widespread product
shortages is noteworthy that u.s online
spending has already racked up over 75
billion dollars to date in november i
don't think people care about inflation
when it comes to buying holiday uh goods
they're gonna continue to buy it for
christmas et cetera it actually because
the inflation may make them buy more so
they don't sit in the cash whether they
realize they're doing that or not and on
top of that i think that companies have
gotten really really really good they're
better today than they've ever been at
remarketing at targeting at advertising
at conversion funnels at sign ups
landing pages uh all the language etc
and so to see more people interested in
buying stuff and then also getting more
sales this is like the least surprising
thing you could tell me
it's interesting to see what approach
companies are taking right so walmart
and target were i know target was closed
yesterday right on thanksgiving day and
what a lot of these companies are doing
is they're using these social media
platforms like instagram twitter
facebook to try to basically get you to
live shop and instantly shop and as a
young consumer i've been marketed to my
entire life digitally pretty much and
i've kind of almost been uh now immune
to it in the sense of i understand what
they're doing and how they do it but a
lot of people don't they just see a
product and they they basically it's
like buy now or miss the opportunity
amazon with the one-click buy all these
things they basically want it to make it
as easy as possible for you to buy the
product and that's what we're seeing
well i was uh i was talking earlier uh
yesterday about the velocity of money
and there's just so much money
in this in circulation right now and the
velocity of money is ridiculous and what
i mean by that is like the one of the
examples and and these are very uh small
examples but they just amount because
you hear about these every single day
and i saw the other day uh for the super
bowl here in the united states the
biggest sporting event uh in the u.s and
at sofi stadium in la this year the the
previous record for a super bowl suite
so like a private area for 15 or 20
people the previous record had been 750
000 that one had sold for sofi stadium
has already sold multiple suites for
over a million dollars including one for
1.25 already right and the game still is
months away that's a 66 increase over
the previous record despite so far
stadium having 90 more suites than the
previous uh stadium that held the record
so extra supply the demand is so crazy
that people are paying that much money
so from a a context of like wealthy
people getting even wealthier people
spending more money in the economy the
velocity of money is at an all-time high
right now and these numbers shouldn't
surprise anyone with kind of inflation
narrative and supply chain narrative and
all these things going around i think
we're going to see some absurd numbers
not only on black friday but this
christmas season here in the united
states also which is crazy when you
think about a supply chain added into
that
yeah well that's part of the problem
too if you're watching at home right now
and your family's over go get your crazy
uncle you know the one who gets drunk
and starts talking about a bunch of
crazy stuff go get him because guess
what he's going to like this next
segment
politicians are gaslighting americans
that's what's happening right now we
have two tweets over the weekend from a
politician who absolutely is saying
there's no way she believes this stuff
zero chance that she believes this stuff
the first tweet we have is that we
elizabeth warren tweeted and said
americans are paying record high prices
for their thanksgiving turkey well big
poultry companies are paying billions in
dividends giving ceos raises and earning
huge profits these companies are abusing
their market power i'm asking the
department of justice to investigate i
want to frame this for a second here
we live in a country that has 6.2
percent official inflation number
there's over four and a half percent
unemployment there's 11 million open
jobs last year in 2020 was the single
highest one-year record jump in
homicides in the united states and we
have a supply chain that couldn't move a
dime
five feet without incurring more cost
the whole system's broken
unemployment too high inflation too high
open rolls too high homicides up
significantly and the supply chains are
broken
add in that it's getting worse and worse
inflation is accelerating and you can
quickly see how bad the situation is but
while all that's going on the people
that have been elected to leadership
positions on both sides of the aisle
are absolutely losing their minds we
have a politician who wants to use the
department of justice
the department of justice
to investigate big poultry what the hell
is big culture i've never heard a big
poultry i don't think there's some big
evil corporation that is trying to stuff
chicken and turkey at overpriced uh
terms down your throat for thanksgiving
what is big poultry this is complete
nonsense
but
even worse than that is the department
of justice really
we're gonna have the department of
justice go investigate the turkey
companies to see if they're selling the
turkeys for too much
well that would ask the question
why didn't they do it last year why did
they price gouge last year or the year
before that or the year before that why
is it that randomly the chicken poultry
and turkey companies randomly decided in
2021 this is a year we're gonna get em
this year they're not gonna expect it
we're gonna price gouge them
this is insane but these people don't
actually believe this they know that the
undisciplined monetary and fiscal policy
that we have in this country has
completely destroyed the middle class it
has ruined the purchasing power of 45 of
americans that have no investable assets
and it has driven prices through the
roof go to a gas pump and try to buy gas
and you tell me that something's not
wrong go and try and buy a turkey like
you did for yesterday and tell me
something's not wrong it's not price
gouging it's literally they simply are
having increased labor cost and they're
having increased fixed cost
and they're having increased cost of
goods so they have to increase their
prices they have to pass it on to their
consumer
now the second tweet she had was
wondering why your thanksgiving
groceries cost more this year it's
because greedy corporations are charging
americans extra just to keep their stock
prices high this is outrageous
no what's outrageous is that actually in
many cases these businesses have given
their employees raises we've seen
everyone from chipotle down to tyson
foods all the way across they've all
given their employees races they've
increased their own cost because they
have to because that's how a free market
works is that if your competitors
increase their labor cost you have to as
well or your employees will leave and so
we have seen every corporation continue
to pay their employees more and more and
more eighty percent eighty percent of
americans get paid more than fifteen
dollars an hour there is no need for
politicians to pass a higher minimum
wage the free market has already
determined that the minimum wage in
america for eighty percent of american
workers is over fifteen dollars an hour
mcdonald's is paying twenty dollars is
mcdonald's price gouging as well they're
paying their employees twenty dollars in
some cases we have seen people literally
say i'll give you thousands of dollars
of a signing bonus to get a signing
bonus you used to either have to be a
professional athlete or go work on wall
street now we're giving it to fast food
workers something is wrong and it's not
because there's some greedy corporation
the corporations are doing exactly what
economics would require them to do if my
expenses go up the only way for me to
protect my profits
is for me to raise my prices so that i
keep the same margin and in many cases
i'm actually willing to bet that most of
them are making less on a percentage
basis it just so happens that at the
same time that they're increasing their
prices the government went and gave a
bunch of liquidity to the market they
gave out stimulus checks they gave out
boost to unemployment they pushed
liquidity into every single exotic
financial corner of the market and so
there's all this free cash flowing
around and so what do people do they
either hold it and lose purchasing power
or they spend it so they're rushing out
and they're spending it and they're
spending it and they're spending it you
could go sector by sector industry by
industry and everyone is experiencing
higher profits higher revenue and stock
prices going up
are they all greedy is every single
person who runs a company greedy is the
small business owner who had to increase
their prices are they greedy as well
is a small business on main street that
owns literally one location has five
employees and they've had to increase
their prices 10 percent this year
because they can't source their goods
for the same prices or their labor needs
to get paid more in order to keep up
with inflation are they greedy
if our politicians want to attack our
corporations then they should be
intellectually honest because whether
you're a small business or you're a
corporation you're forced to do the
exact same thing has nothing to do with
price gouging has nothing to do with
greed and it's everything to do with
undisciplined monetary and fiscal policy
and the part that nobody wants to talk
about is they did this
the companies are just merely reaction
they're reacting to the undisciplined
monetary and fiscal policy they're not
the ones who did this and anyone who's
saying that they did has lost their
minds what do you think joe
i do not even think that she believes
what she is saying zero chance zero
chance i don't even think she wrote i
think this is classic just
throwing [ __ ] out there to cater to
her her fan base and gaslighting yeah
that's exactly what it is because she
knows everyone knows everyone that has
some simple understanding of economics
and how businesses work know that when
all these costs are increasing you have
to also they have shareholders some of
these corporations public com companies
have shareholders individual
institutional et cetera retail traders
that own parts of these companies that
demand you to keep your margins good
demand you to continue to make to make
more money when you're paying employers
more when the supply chain is messed up
when you're introducing all this
liquidity into the into the economy 30
to i think it's like 35 or 40 percent of
the money that is currently in
circulation was printed in the last 12
to 18 months they know what they did
they know what the end result of this
was and again part of this is they were
put in a really difficult situation
right i don't think anyone had the
perfect solution when you're hit with a
uh a virus like covid and the economy
has shut down you have to tell people to
do all these different things there's a
million different arguments about what
they should have done there is no one
clear-cut solution that says hey this
would have been the perfect response
they're put in a really difficult
situation but to sit there and now say
that corporations are being greedy and
trying to price gouge and do all these
things it's [ __ ] they know it's
[ __ ] and i don't even believe she
believes half of what she's saying i
think it is literally she's just
pandering to her base and trying to put
out this information to save her own
seat and say hey look they're they're
being greedy they're doing all these
things and putting the blame on other
people she as a politician knows exactly
what happened from a fundamental
understanding of business she knows
exactly what happened i think this is
all [ __ ] john what do you think
to see a u.s senator elizabeth warren
saying stuff like this is it's just not
good like it's it's literally trying to
fuel the american people to think one
way and if you say things enough people
begin to believe that it is true when
this is just not what's going on
restaurants for example the cost of
people have gone up the cost of food has
gone up the cost of rent has gone up and
these corporations they're not price
gouging to increase their stock price
you know what's increasing their stock
price when you print trillions and
trillions of dollars in the last 18
months and stocks are just going up
they're going through the roof they
don't need the price gouge to do that
their margins are actually getting
squeezed because of the cost that
they're incurring and
i think that once these costs go up for
certain items they're not going to go
back down you see chipotle increase
their cost by what four percent across
the board basically stakes up 20
it's around 20 stake from last year to
this year's up over 20 percent so as a
restaurant they're actually i think
their margins are getting squeezed even
more and they're just trying to do what
they can to stay afloat i don't think
they're necessarily price gouging but
they also run a corporation if you don't
want to eat there you don't have to eat
there that is the beauty of the free
market and what we live in today the
last thing i'm going to say about this
and then we're going to bring on the uh
first person who bought a thousand
dollars worth of merchandise what
hyperinflation's incoming no no even
better
you know the part that they'll never
admit
the federal government increased pay
they voted this year in the senate
appropriators said yes we're going to
increase pay for federal workers next
year which by the way is a good thing
that's a good thing we should we should
say yes that's good they only did a 2.2
which means that they literally aren't
even keeping up with inflation which is
a whole other argument of literally the
federal government's going to pay
federal workers less next year than they
are this year big problem
but now should we say that the
government's greedy
the government is literally increasing
their cost uh they're greedy they're
greedy they're taking more of our money
they're taking more than our taxpayer
money to go in to pay their staff you
greedy leaders the the thing that i
would say is like don't trust any of
them
whatever side of the aisle you think you
stand on don't trust any of them what we
have found over time is uh these people
are always going to do what is in the
best interest of themselves because
that's what the incentives reward and i
think ultimately the best decision is
not to trust any of them and and don't
stick your head in the sand and say hey
i agree with this party on one issue or
on all issues you need to look at
everything kind of in a silo and say hey
let's take the facts for what they are
and decide from there because if we
found anything politicians will lie to
you that's what they'll do and and not
everyone is in it for your best interest
one of the best things was mark cuban
when he was talking about bitcoin and
specifically and he was just like look i
read or i think it was garyvee actually
they basically read
all the negative stuff and what people
were kind of rebuking about and like
what they were saying to understand the
entire argument of all this and that's
what i think you're kind of getting to
is like you have to look at both sides
because then you get a clearer picture
and then you can make your own opinion
rather than just reading one side of
saying hey inflation's going up because
of this this this you want to look at
everything and make your own opinion all
right
as a reminder we have two things we're
gonna give out more bitcoin in a second
in the store everything is 21 off in the
store today the best business show.com
everything any christmas gift you need
you can go to the store we got it there
21 off if you buy a hundred dollars or
more in the store today we're gonna go
ahead we're gonna give you a live shout
out on the show we can say what your
first name is last first initial
and also where you live what what city
you're in second thing is if you buy 500
or more you get a personalized video a
thousand dollars or more you're gonna
join us on the live stream for three
minutes and whoever spends the most
amount of money in the store this
weekend we will fly to miami and we'll
hang out with you for a day now somebody
already bought a thousand dollars in the
store his name is brian i have a
bird in my ear that is telling me that
brian is very excited about this so
brian are you there
what's up man
oh oh
my sound working you're like something
it's not working
all right we'll come back to brian
[Laughter]
all right see
see if you guys can uh help him get his
microphone fixed there uh we'll keep
going brian we'll bring you back in a
second let's see if we get your
microphone i have to spend another grand
on a microphone
ryan is ready to go i can't wait for
this all right remember if you spent
thousand dollars gonna come live on the
show make sure your microphone works be
ready to go uh real quick we saw a video
there's a video that cnbc i think it is
uh put this out and yeah it is cnbc they
put out a video how much money you need
to invest per month to retire i've
looked at this eyelashes are actually
very well done uh video the first thing
is that there's a couple of assumptions
that they're going through in this video
the first assumption is that you start
with no money in your savings you have
zero dollars of savings when you start
the second assumption is that your
investments will earn six percent
annually it's actually been low uh
assumption compared to the last couple
of years but they assume only six
percent growth annually for your
investments and they also assume that
you plan to retire at age 67 which is a
little bit later than the average age of
62. so start with no money in your
savings right your investments will earn
six percent annually and you plan to
retire at age 67. if you want to save
500 000 for a retirement here are the
numbers of what you would have to get to
and or what you have to do on a monthly
basis in order to get to 500 000
start at age 25 you have to save 220 per
month if you start at age 30 you have to
save 307 per month and if you want to
start at age 40 you have to save 620
per month so again 500 000 for
retirement you start at age 25 with no
savings and you earn six percent
annually you have to save or invest
right you save it to invest 220 bucks
per month if you start at age 40 15
years later it jumps all the way up to
620 and that only leaves you with 500
000 at retirement if we bump up the
amount of retirement to 750 000
you can see that it ranges between three
hundred and thirty dollars and nine
hundred and thirty dollars per month
depending on when you start so if you
start at age twenty five you have to
save three hundred thirty dollars per
month to get seventy five seven hundred
fifty thousand dollars to retire with at
age 40 you would have to save 930 per
month to get 750 000 to retire with so
of course you have to continue to put
more and more money to work in the
market the later that you are in age to
be able to get to these big numbers for
retirement so 750 000 for retirement
ends up being at age 40 930 per month
lastly we have if you want to get to a
million dollars for retirement a million
dollars for retirement at age 25 you
have to save 440 per month every single
month from age 25 to age 67 in order to
get to a million dollars to retire with
if you start at age 40 and you want to
get to a million dollars to retire with
you have to save and invest one thousand
two hundred and forty dollars per month
to get to one million dollars at the age
of retirement these are really big
numbers one thousand two hundred and
forty dollars every single month from
age 40 to age 67 if you want to get to a
million dollars at retirement age 67
with a six percent annual return
absolutely insane what do we think about
these numbers these attainable for the
average person yes
yeah i think so too i think it depends
on what you want to retire with right
that's the that's the end kind of
equation that you have to figure out is
you have to put that number first and
then figure out how you get to that
number so 500 000 is enough if you think
that's enough to live the lifestyle you
want at retirement great then back into
what you have to do every month and
stick to that plan and go for it if it's
a million then do that also uh the the
difficult part is a lot of these
variables can change right if the
government continues to print money like
they have is 500k enough i don't know
right is a million enough i don't know
but uh the these things are constantly
changing whatever but i think having a
plan right some kind of plan uh to
understand that you're going to take
care of yourself you're not going to
rely on subsidies or these other things
to happen out of your control say hey
look i'm going to go do these things i'm
going to educate myself i'm going to
invest in these things that's ultimately
the best strategy because what you don't
want to do is rely on other people or
other sources of income or help right i
think ultimately uh the best decision is
trying to figure out for yourself kind
of what plan you need and then just
sticking to that throughout your career
john what do you think don't rely on
social security it's going to run out by
2034 the estimates have already said
that do not rely on anyone else i am
weary of telling people this because
i don't know if a million dollars is
retired depends on kind of your plan and
what you want to do after retirement my
best advice would be just get multiple
streams of passive income so you can
still earn while you're retiring you
don't have to actively work to control
those streams right so you get a get a
laundry mat someone else is running the
laundry mat you basically are stepped
away and you're you're now a silent
owner of the laundry matter whatever
business like that so my best advice
would be get passive streams of income
and start as early as possible right
you've seen you can see by the numbers
just as the earlier you start the even
better it is so if you wait 10 years
when instead of starting at 22 and you
start at 32 um even if you put more
money in every single week at 32 you
actually still have more money if you
consistently do it from 22. compound
interest is your best friend invest in
assets get passive streams of income and
let uh
make sense i saw a post on reddit the
other day which i thought was
interesting and
i don't know if i necessarily need to
find it but ultimately what they were
saying is it was someone uh who was like
in their mid-30s and they were
essentially like a million dollars is
not really a lot of money anymore and
their whole point was like they knew
some friends that were buying like a 1.2
million house or something like that and
she was uh she was like
when i was 20 something 30 something
like that seemed like an unattainable
amount of money and it seemed like
something completely out of reach and as
she got older she was like wait it's
really not and maybe part of that is
just education and realizing kind of
what you can do on the investment side
but part of that is also realizing just
what inflation can do to your money over
time right and what it does your
purchasing power and how it increases
the prices of things so real estate is
obviously excelling at a rate that makes
these houses more expensive uh certain
careers and certain investments and all
this other stuff is also but ultimately
you have to look back and say hey what
is that money going to be worth 30 years
from now if i'm going to retire in 30
years what is it going to be worth in 20
years if i retire in 20 years is a
million dollars going to be close to
enough do i need 5 million do i need 10
million all of this really depends on
the quality of life you want to live and
what you want to do with that money but
ultimately that variable of money is
going to change with inflation right and
i think uh her point was really just a
million dollars isn't what it used to be
i thought that a million dollars i was
going to be rich right and she realized
later on that like 25 year old 27 year
olds were buying those houses and it
differs for everyone right and not and
for uh for context you know that still
is a really good amount of money here in
the united states to buy a house if
you're that if that age but i think
ultimately the point was really just you
have to understand what inflation is
going to do to money for the future for
retirement and et cetera
we've got will clemente who's going to
come on in a second here but before we
do that we just had a second purchase of
a thousand dollars we're working to get
both of them on live on the show before
we get into that we're giving out a
hundred dollars worth of bitcoin let's
go we got to keep up with this we got
we're i'm picking the winner we're
actually gonna do two people right now
hundred dollars of bitcoin picking two
people because we're about to hit uh
12.45 so all we need you guys to do is
one two three hit the like button press
the like button that is your entry fee
go ahead and bam smash the like button
second thing is just drop your twitter
or your instagram handle in the chat and
tell us what did you do yesterday for
thanksgiving what did you do yesterday
for thanksgiving include your twitter or
your instagram handle joe will pick one
person john will pick one person each
person will win a hundred dollars worth
of bitcoin right now
so
let's go
what do you do laughter bazooka boys
how much coffee you have this morning i
have one iced coffee with oat milk
bro don't oh milk is out of control this
coffee was five dollars
crazy because you drink oat milk you
know that's not good for you
someone did message me just chill with
that all right what you don't know don't
hurt you yeah
they were like they're like there's
something in the open i forget what they
said but they essentially said there was
something in the oatmeal that's not good
for you i did a little research they
said it's all right they say it's okay
online no worries no worries no problem
no problem you did your research for the
first time
hey hey
chill pick a winner i got my winner
all right who's your winner john
kyler
gerson
kyler gerson you win 100 bucks 100
of bitcoin congratulations all right i
got you said he was in dc by the way i
got james davis he ate dinner
thanksgiving dinner with his girl spam
hopefully that her pops didn't come for
you bro
hopefully you were all good on that
front was it first meeting let us know
in the chat
we want details james what happened
dude that'd be a that's a tough look
joe's invested in him
your girlfriend's dad for the first time
first time on thanksgiving that's a
tough one okay you break up bitcoin
inflation ball dicks you start asking
like is there lasagna here
you guys are you guys are thinking of
all the wrong stuff the first reason why
it's bad is because you don't just meet
the dad you meet the dad plus the whole
family it's not just that hey i'm
meeting the dad for the first time it's
the dad i think that makes it easy what
if he doesn't like he's like trying to
watch a movie during the year hey man
listen uh die hard's not a christmas
movie put on the football game you're
right you're a legend that's a hot start
that's a hot start you're a legend if
you go over he's watching a movie you're
like you might turn on the cowboys game
you roll over you roll over with cigars
he's like nah that kills yeah yeah it's
not good he might be drinking uh oat
milk though who knows what are you are
you saying that people that drink oat
milk aren't cool with cigars
because that's not true here
i'll tell you right now personal
experience i'm cool with both
what
ain't gonna say nothing let's go let's
get the let's get
damn joe don't want to talk about that
talk about me smoking cigars and
drinking oat milk
i was gonna tell a cigar story i hope
everyone had a fantastic thanksgiving me
too the second thing is uh we we did see
one of the wildest videos i think i've
ever seen joe showed it to me yesterday
oh yeah
in this it was texas right
joe yeah yeah yeah i think in texas
we don't want to get into all the
details but in texas there's basically a
video there's multiple videos of this uh
there was uh one guy who uh it's his
house he's there and it looks like it's
his girlfriend maybe and the girlfriend
has a child with uh what appears at
least one maybe multiple kids with
another man the other guy the dad of the
kids shows up and there's a disagreement
that ensues and uh at one point the guys
who house it is he goes into the house
and he gets a
a rifle a shotgun it's kind of hard to
tell uh exactly what it was but like
more kind of like a assault rifle almost
and he walks out on his porch the dad
and him go nose to nose literally the
ex-husband yeah the ex-husband go no to
no nose to nose and at some point
there's a struggle over the gun
and the
ex-husband tries to throw the guy with
the gun
and when he throws him the guy with the
gun keeps hold of the gun turns around
he shoots and kills the ex-husband
absolutely insane video but
it's
it's one of those holidays where there's
lots of drinking and driving
unfortunately there's things around
domestic violence there's guns etc so if
you're having a positive experience you
got to be thankful for that it'll be
great right yeah like like that video
and i told joe when he showed me a video
i was like look man it's just it kind of
screwed with me a little bit right you
had a place to go in a loving
environment yesterday you should be very
grateful yeah very grateful
yeah it's gonna be interesting to see uh
i don't think they decided to charge him
with anything or press charges yet i'm
sure with the video being the video was
released i guess from the from the wife
over some of the custody stuff and
trying to figure out with her lawyers
but it'll be interesting to see how it
plays out because a lot of this stuff
like is decided in the media now right
and decided on the public narrative how
much outrage there is right if people
start freaking out and saying this
shouldn't be allowed maybe that puts
pressure the legal rights i think people
believe say one thing maybe public
pressure forces people to think a
different way but interesting uh to see
obviously the the video is uh is graphic
and stuff but it's it'll be interesting
to see kind of what comes of it yeah i
mean i i i don't know what's gonna
happen there but uh when you showed it
to me that was my first reaction was
just like it was just sad too you know
what i mean that dude imagine imagine
yeah i don't care if you're a newborn or
if you're you know 15 years old and
imagine that whether you find out now or
you find out later that at some point
there was an altercation and your dad
was shot on the porch of the house you
were sitting in yeah it's just sad i
mean it's crazy stuff so uh hopefully uh
everyone had a people safe enjoyable to
switch the vibes zack's asking uh how
about sophia
first thanksgiving how was sophia's
first day ranger was chill yesterday
ranger was real chill right john good
dog yeah good dog dog we were saying he
was showing off his behavior how was
sophia's first thanksgiving sophia's
first thanksgiving was amazing i have no
uh no complaints at all uh and i don't
think that she does either i asked her
and she just looked at me so
i feel like we're good
i think we're uh supposed to be going we
have will okay we got will clemente is
going on right now will you there
how's it going pop i'm doing all right
how are you buddy
i'm good i'm good i'm good i got about
five minutes here but we can run through
some of this stuff you guys have a good
thanksgiving we had a great thanksgiving
how was your thanksgiving
it was good i had a couple of family
members over just took it easy i'm back
at the parents house
yeah i was here i was working at target
now all of a sudden i'm the big dog in
bitcoin so you know what's up
look what i found i found right here my
uh
oh you got the dog
all right let's run through this real
quick we got a couple of charts we're
gonna pull up here the first one is the
on-chain cost basis uh explain to us
what's uh what's going on with the
on-chain cost basis i don't think a lot
of people know what this is
yeah so what we're looking at here is
just the average cost basis or the
average price that uh short-term holders
have bought in or another way to look at
this for technical traders is this is an
on-chain v-wop or volume weighted
average price
and so essentially this is kind of
served as like this bull market support
band if you will from an unchained
perspective
oh
can you hear me yeah we gotta keep going
okay cool cool uh yeah so if you see
2017 this is kind of served as support
uh once we broke below that then you
know we've we've turned into kind of a
you know we headed back into the bear
market uh got rejected off of that you
know had a failed underside reached us
to that like four times once we broke
back below that kind of marked the end
of the of the bear market um as you can
see this also served as support uh once
we got back above you know after the
march uh you know covet capitulation in
in september of last year served as
support uh broke below heading into may
got back above it at the beginning of
september and then got confirmation at
the end of september
but now we're kind of sitting right on
that band that currently sits at 53k
which also aligns with technical support
uh as well as the kind of one trillion
dollar market cap threshold
and so
the the way i kind of see this is
currently you know when you look at some
of these broader on-chain dynamics that
are saying we're still in a bull market
um with that in mind if you do think
that's the case then the the asymmetry
is pretty heavily skewed to the upside
here because we're close to that what
what has traditionally been kind of this
bull market support band
and so the way i'm kind of looking at
the market is in the first chart you'll
see some of the derivative stuff um i
think in the short term like i
definitely wouldn't rule out any kind of
you know liquidation driven flush or
wick down
just because we haven't really seen any
flush in open interest as well as
funding and we haven't really seen any
like sizeable amounts of liquidations
which usually kind of mark bottoms for
bitcoin um and so you know i wouldn't i
wouldn't rule that out by any means but
as long as we're as long as we're
closing and keyword is closing above uh
53k i don't i don't see any you know
anything to be getting necessarily
panicked about um i think we're you know
right along that kind of bull market
support band area currently and you know
based off of some of these other
on-chain dynamics um you know i i still
do think we're in this you know broader
kind of bull trend um you know i think
this this coded variant news or whatever
obviously wasn't wasn't great for the
bitcoin market as well as
legacy markets but you know when i'm
looking at kind of these these dynamics
that we've we've been tracking you know
that are we're looking to play out over
the coming months etc like i don't i
don't see anything that's necessarily
changed in those things if they do you
know i'll change my outlook but yeah on
the shorter term time frames you know
right along that kind of bull market
support band as well as when we look at
soper uh we got a nice bounce off of
soaper as well
i mean the only the the bare case i
would say in the short term is just kind
of from the derivative stuff in the
sense that we haven't really seen a real
flush out yet which usually we we do see
kind of at these bottoms got it okay and
then we've got the entity adjusted sopra
it looks like it bounced pretty hard off
of uh one there
yeah we've bounced off one uh as we've
talked about before this one is where
kind of the profit and loss balance each
other out that's being realized on every
given day so when you're above one
you're in a state of profit when you're
below you're in a state of loss so what
you want to see in kind of these broader
bullish trends is to come back down to
that one threshold and retest it we've
been talking for about a month now about
kind of how it's had started to kind of
roll over and we were suspecting that
we'd probably come back down get that
retest which we actually have gotten
over the last couple days and so um
seeing that bounce is obviously a good
sign
you know i think the the kind of
invalidation for me
would be seeing soaper go below one as
well as kind of having this failed
underside retest if we if we were to go
below it in addition to um you know
starting to see a liquid supply roll
over and then as we just looked at the
on-chain cost basis going below that and
also failing to to break back above that
and that's what happened at the end of
2017 we broke below but then couldn't
get back above we got rejected off of
that whereas
after coming out of the summer we did
get back above so um you know looking
for a couple of those things is kind of
my invalidation if you will uh but you
know aside with with the shorter like
shorter term stuff aside um none of the
kind of macro cyclical behavior that you
know we've been tracking has has changed
over the last couple days um and you
know if you're i didn't throw any of
that stuff in the newsletter this week
just because it was a bit short or what
shorter than usual it's a thanksgiving i
kind of threw it together this morning
but um you know check out some of the
stuff in that thread that i have pinned
on my twitter and there's like 20 22
different metrics that you can look at
for that last chart i want to go over
and then i know that we've uh we've got
to let you go is the supply shock ratios
uh you've highlighted here with kind of
the bullish divergence um talk to us a
little bit about what the supply shock
ratio is showing us and then what these
diversions uh mean
yeah this is a metric i created with
lily back over the summer you're
essentially comparing the weak to strong
hands so you're looking at the liquid
and highly liquid entities and running a
ratio of those to the illiquid entities
and so what we see is whenever we have
these kind of dislocations between the
metric and price it resolves in the in
the direction of the metrics so if you
see you know back in the back in
september of last year
we had this move up in price meanwhile
we had you know a drawdown in the ratio
so we had a bearish divergence where the
oscillator is going one way price is
going the opposite that resolved to the
downside in price
and then conversely after that you know
we had a price draw down as well as the
ratio starting to tick up and then that
resolved to the upside um i had a couple
of these bull divs earlier this year in
january there's a pretty substantial one
as well as a minor one in march
heading into kind of this this you know
mini bear over the over the summer we
had a pretty strong uh bear divergence
between the oscillator as well as price
because you started to see supply
becoming liquid and kind of the weeks
leading up to that drawdown saw the same
thing at the end of 2017 you saw supply
becoming liquid in the weeks before that
drawdown
and so since then saw a bullish
divergence which pomp i remember very
vividly us talking about on here over
the summer uh oscillator was grinding up
meanwhile price was grinding down
another bull div at the end of september
earlier this year when we came back and
retested 40k oscillator was grinding up
price was grinding down that resolved in
the direction of the oscillator moving
up and just recently over the last
couple weeks we have again a very strong
uh bullish divergence between the
oscillator has been ticking up pretty
heavily meanwhile price has been moving
down pretty heavily so
i'm personally expecting that to resolve
in the direction of the oscillator given
that it doesn't start to roll over
because that's just what's happened uh
historically as as we've seen and
especially over the summer we saw
sometimes it can take you know several
weeks to kind of uh you know resolve
itself but
going back in bitcoin's history it's
it's hard to kind of find a time where
that hasn't really resolved in the
direction of the oscillator got it uh
real quick before you go just general
sentiment you still feel pretty good
even though price is drawn down
yeah i mean i think as long as we have
these kind of uh clear kind of
invalidation points that we talked about
a couple minutes ago uh i know the
broader sense i think we see higher
bitcoin prices over the next couple
months um you know i think whenever
legacy markets have a substantial
drawdown you're going to see that in the
bitcoin market as well
and you know i do think there's there's
a fair you know case to say that we
probably have a another kind of flush
down given some of the derivative stuff
we looked at but you know we talk about
you know kind of the broader picture for
you know more long-term holders i don't
think necessarily that you know we're
heading into any kind of multi-year bear
market given where the data stands now
you know data changes i'll change my
mind
you're the man
will the wizard i appreciate you jumping
on very quickly i know that uh during
the holidays it's hard uh oh look at you
getting a little golf clap from two
geniuses over here we got you will well
by the way we'll check we're going to
hit 500 000 followers he's been what are
you at 430 now
uh something like that yeah bag it put
it i told you
book it he's never hitting 500k before
the end of the year uh listen i
appreciate you so much doing this uh
have a great rest of uh thanksgiving
week but i got one question tell your
family i say hi good uh will who is a
better host me or him
i don't know man joe gave me a good run
for you let's get it
appreciate you watching
i appreciate that answer i appreciate
that answer how much you bitcoin you
have to send them to them i said i'm
nothing for that answer
appreciate you will i will thank you
guys guys i gotta jet you guys take it
easy thanks for having me on all right
later all right we got some housekeeping
things before the mayor of miami francis
suarez is about to come on and jack
mahler's strike ceo but before we do
that we got two things one at one
o'clock today
we got a food challenge we've been
talking a lot of smack on here about
food challenges please put the camera on
john i want everyone to see the john's
face when this happens go ahead john
what's the food challenge you're gonna
do today i am going to attempt at 1 p.m
today to eat 50 chicken nuggets from
mcdonald's in one hour in one hour i
have never even come anywhere close to
attempting something like this so you
guys are in a special treat
um pretty nervous about it to be honest
i've never done something like this are
you still full from thanksgiving or not
yeah i'm still full from thanksgiving
when i was when i kind of came to the
realization that this was gonna happen
today i immediately stopped eating the
bagel i was eating
and put everything down so i'm hoping to
get some room and uh we'll see i got
some strategies no you're doing
chick-fil-a you're doing mcdonald's no
chick-fil-a is too heavy too heavy two
they're better yeah i know i know all
right so john's gonna do a 50 nugget
challenge he's gonna try to eat 50
nuggets drop your strategy in the chat
and how is he going to join him
at 1pm also because it's black friday
and everyone's going in the store and
they're buying a bunch of stuff before
we bring on the mayor and jack we have
everyone who's purchased a hundred
dollars or more in the store already
here we go here's the shout outs for
every single person that's purchased a
hundred dollars or more at
thebestbusinessshow.com today first we
got miles b from the uk shout out miles
from new york
grassucio
from switzerland as i said grassucio i
don't know garcia i might have messed it
up but that's how it goes buddy sorry
grassucio from switzerland then we've
got a couple of others here that we're
gonna pull up shout out megan from new
york you gotta you gotta move to florida
though
what the uh the new york to miami uh
trail is happening that that is
shout out adam k in the chat said he
bought santa laser eyes sweater and the
payment bitcoin t-shirt christmas is
from new jersey we have mark mark ogen
s from new jersey we have griffin d from
california
this is a very international show uk new
york switzerland new jersey california
we're going all over the world then we
also have a couple more gavin m from
ohio i appreciate it shout out gavin
emma from sweden gavin's from iowa not
ohio oh i say ohio yeah put some respect
on gavin's name oh boy can't read
emma from sweden charles from texas and
ryan p from illinois now now it's not
illinois
it's illinois illinois illinois illinois
illinois charles k from texas emma from
sweden gavin from ohio gavin emma
charles ryan but again if you look at
this new york new jersey california
island
mobile uk
switzerland everywhere we need some
people from asia they're probably
sleeping right now but let's go wake up
guys in japan he's cooking on his
airfryer
we stay ready in any other jurisdiction
the united states what i was just
thinking if anyone's if were you
sweating thinking that someone was going
to say gavin m from an igloo
someone said that in the in the chat
they said gavin in his igloo
if you would like to get a shout out on
the show today go ahead i just dropped
the link in the chat you can go there
everything is 21 off in the store just
go ahead buy a hundred dollars or more
we're on the back end we know exactly
what you're buying
a couple people are saying hey well my
name wasn't on there if you bought
something you're gonna get you don't
worry we're periodically checking
they're batched right we can't just have
a hundred thousand people because
there's gonna be a hundred thousand
people that buy a hundred dollars so
just relax we're gonna get you up there
no problem the second thing is if you
buy a thousand dollars in the store
you're gonna get it come on there's two
people so far that have bought a
thousand dollars uh we're going to go
ahead and get you on to uh
the show as well now we have a very
special treat today we have jack mahlers
ceo of strike
and also we have the mayor of miami
francis suarez as many of you know miami
specifically uh has done a ton of work
to become the capital of bitcoin there
is not only work happening in bitcoin
there's also the capital of capital as
the mayor calls it which is trying to
incentivize and attract tons and tons of
people who invest capital to move to
miami if you can be the capital of
capital it's a pretty attractive
position to be in and on top of that
obviously bitcoin is a very hot topic we
have everything from the mayor trying to
push forward the ability to pay
employees of the city in bitcoin to
accept bitcoin for city state taxes uh
city fees or taxes also to put bitcoin
on the balance sheet of the city of
miami and then we have jack mullers the
founder and ceo of strike strike
obviously is the lightning enabled
payment system you can go you can
download the strike app when you get the
strike app you can send bitcoin or
dollars to anyone in the world that also
has the strike app or anyone who has a
bitcoin address so it's a very open type
system on top of that strike is what is
powering twitter's new tipping feature
so if you are not familiar with strike i
highly suggest you go check it out we're
gonna bring on both jack and the mayor
and we're going to have them talk about
paying people in bitcoin or accepting
their salaries in bitcoin so i think
jack and uh mayor i think we have both
of you guys here
come on
yes sir bang bang
so now listen this couldn't be more
exciting for me because we have the
mayor with obviously the the backdrop of
miami it's beautiful nice weather always
summer in miami summer fridays and then
we have jack who is in cold chicago in
an empty closet
still flexing though
all right so let's start with jack you
first talk to us about the payment
bitcoin feature that strike has rolled
out how does this work and why are
people using it
it works just like a direct deposit
product is that when you line up your
paycheck you can go to jpmorgan chase
bank you could go to chime you could go
to strike and strike allows you to
toggle and convert any percentage of
your paycheck into bitcoin so that the
salary that you earn from working a wage
can be paid in half dollars half bitcoin
75 bitcoin 25
100 bitcoin and the point in that is
that saving accounts are dead it costs
more for a bank to custody your dollars
then they'll give you yield so how do
you save money and can you get paid in
commercial real estate can you get paid
in precious metal gold bars and we
wanted a product for the individual
consumer to say hey i want to save my
non-working capital in bitcoin because
it's the best savings technology of all
time uh and that's it it's really dead
simple you hand your form to your
employer and uh from then on out for the
rest of eternity you can get paid in
bitcoin whatever percentage you want
all right
now mayor you obviously got into a uh a
little competition a good competition in
my opinion where you said that you were
gonna take your next paycheck in bitcoin
and then the mayor-elect in new york
city said oh yeah you're gonna do one
i'm gonna do three and then i think
you've come back over the top with i'm
gonna take all of my paychecks in
bitcoin so talk to us a little bit about
getting paid in bitcoin how you think
about it personally and then also the
potential to eventually do this with
other people within the city's uh
employee base
yeah so first of all you know a while
back uh you know i pledged that i wanted
to allow my employees to get paid in
bitcoin uh allow our
residents to be able to pay for fees and
taxes in bitcoin which we're still
working on and then eventually
potentially hold bitcoin on our balance
sheet so we've accomplished step one
already uh our cio mike saurasi was the
first uh city of miami employee to use
strike and to be able to get paid in
bitcoin um i i said you know what i'm
gonna i gotta i gotta follow him i gotta
you know uh like jack would say you
gotta lead by example and uh you know
and so i decided to do it and then of
course eric adams uh i think the mayor
of tampa uh the mayor of jacksonville i
think uh uh jack was telling us up to
six mayors already across the united
states are taking uh either all or some
or some percentage in bitcoin their
salaries you know when i started talking
about
a bitcoin in terms of uh you know in
terms of paying our employees a
percentage or whatever they want to like
like jack said it can be whatever
whatever they want right you know
bitcoin i think was like at 40 000. so
you know it's gone up 50
uh you know people talk a lot about the
volatility particularly people that
don't like bitcoin for whatever reason
they like to talk about the volatility
but they don't talk about the
year-over-year gains which is crazy i
don't understand how they can talk about
one thing without the other which is
really the more relevant statistic right
and so uh you know it's amazing and with
inflation certainly being underreported
as we all know um you know it's it's an
important hedge uh and it's becoming the
base currency for many many people
jack when you think about uh folks
getting paid in bitcoin this obviously
serves as a kind of a de facto uh dollar
cost averaging right is every every week
uh every other week every month whenever
i get paid i'm just converting into
bitcoin talk a little bit about the
power of that and why that's so
important
yeah well first i didn't say happy
thanksgiving i'm on this show thankful
as [ __ ] right now the mayor the man and
the pomp brothers i hope everyone's
having a good holiday um
yeah all right so let's go on a little
bit of a rant um
inflation uh six percent according to
cpi uh but housing is my favorite metric
um because everyone needs a roof over
their head to live uh 24 and a half
percent in the united states so let me
put this abundantly clear and not in uh
word salad speak if you
watching this are not getting a 25 raise
every single year
housing is getting more expensive than
you are earning income so you are not
making progress towards owning a home
okay
that's a huge problem how many of you
your family your friends are getting a
25 raise every single year to keep up
with how expensive housing is getting
and so are you [ __ ]
no you just cannot save in dollars
that's a very known thing whether it's
housing your kids education vacation
cars everything that's a hard asset
that's hard to obtain is getting more
expensive than you can earn so you have
to change the way you save and what's
very unique about bitcoin pump is it's
the most accessible savings technology
of all time traditionally you'd have to
buy a big chunk of real estate you'd
have to find a way to store gold you
know maybe the ken griffins of the world
the big hedge fund managers maybe those
guys can go get new york city manhattan
penthouses and store their wealth there
what about me what about the mayor's
employees what about the everyday
individual is there an accessible scarce
uh monetary policy that's predictable
that lives external of any central party
that we can even get a penny of our
paycheck in and yes it's bitcoin and so
for me the whole power of the product is
that you don't need to convince your cfo
you don't need to work for a special
company you don't need to be a hedge
fund manager this is an asset that works
in the best interest of everybody it has
no bias it doesn't care towards any
certain type of wealth class it is the
most fair free open savings technology
in human history
and so all we're doing is letting you
line up your direct deposit and you get
to decide what portion of your savings
should be allocated towards bitcoin but
pump what if i tried to build a payment
gold bars product or a payment
commercial real estate product get the
[ __ ] out of here it'd be impossible the
things natively digital it's divisible
into 100 million pieces you could store
it on your phone you could store it for
yourself it's an absolute no-brainer and
so we've got a dozen mayors we've got
nfl athletes we've got the biggest
musicians in the world but i also have
you want to know one of the biggest
companies of paycheck to our service
uber
you got guys that are trying to make a
living wage and outpace inflation and
work their way towards owning a home and
they're driving uber and an ability to
save to when the richest in the world
like michael saylor makes a buck the
uber driver makes a buck too and the
post mates delivery man right everyone
is in this together and so that it was
so intuitive to me of um let's just make
this as accessible as possible to the
people and allow them to outpace
inflation because inflation devastates
the poor more than the ken griffins in
the world it's really that simple mayor
suarez there's not very many people
who'd laid out better than jack does i
think that uh what he's been able to
build is obviously a very unique type of
product but talk to us about the
challenges right i i you sent me a
picture or you tweeted a picture or
something i remember seeing a picture of
you right after you had gone uh and you
looked exhausted because you had gone
and tried to convince people to allow
the employees to get paid in bitcoin put
bitcoin on the balance sheet except
bitcoin for payments like this is a very
hard task to do and there's a lot of
bureaucracy and there's a lot of kind of
rules that need to be changed or looked
at again so maybe just talk about like
the difficulty in doing that which i
think really highlights why strike
specifically allows people to get the
same direct deposit and auto convert it
into bitcoin rather than have to maybe
jump through kind of all the bureaucracy
that you're dealing with at the city
level
yeah well i mean first of all i was
exhausted when i did that video uh it
was a thursday night uh and and you know
it wasn't like the ideal time to post a
video and the metrics which is another
thing that people understand people
don't understand how many people have
bitcoin or are part of this community
it's massive it's far far far far far
greater than what people actually
believe
so that's been a lesson to me that's
been proven time and time again but the
the resistance has has been plentiful i
remember when i first started talking
about bitcoin i had people telling me
you're going to ruin your career um this
is a ponzi scheme uh you know stop
talking about it uh you know i i've had
all kinds of of people come to me and
and tell me all kinds of things and so
you know that that's part of it i think
the other part of it is there is a bit
of a generational uh issue my dad was a
really smart guy two graduate degrees
from harvard 72 years old mechanical
engineer
you know he struggles understanding the
concept because remember they grew up in
a gold back based world right currency
world to then a a you know central back
bank bank full faith and credit world
fiat world uh to what we're going into
now and so
it's it's it is an abstract paradigm
shift for them and then i think the
third thing is is that generation
that is struggling to understand it
is by and large the generation that's in
power i'm an anomaly i'm 44 years old
mayor of a big city i'm not the
prototypical
guy you know what i mean i i'm i like to
say that
i'm at an interesting inflection point
in my life i'm young enough to
understand new technology and old enough
to do something about it and so it's uh
it's it's a unique opportunity for me
which is why i think you know i've been
able to lead so much on this because i
get it and then it's just about
evangelizing it so uh it it hasn't been
easy um i've been blessed to have people
like you pump and jack and others that
have created either products that are
supportive of it or or educated me on it
and giving me ideas on things that we
can do to keep you know the volume up
because i think a big part of this we've
talked about this from day one it's
almost been a year you know it's about
about mainstreaming something that we
know uh can empower so many people can
democratize investment for so many
people so uh it's been a an incredible
run we have some more exciting things
that we're going to announce uh soon uh
you're going to really like and i think
jack's going to like too and uh it was
going to keep the momentum going it's a
lot of fun
joe john what questions you guys got for
these guys
all right jack you got some go ahead
jack
yeah i just want to put it one more way
because i really want people to
understand this [ __ ]
if 25 you over your this is my favorite
way i explained to a family yesterday
25 year over year inflation for housing
that means compounded over the next
three to five years housing will double
so if you hold dollars
your house your dream home that you got
bookmarked on zillow is going to get 25
percent
more expensive every single year and
doubly as expensive every three to five
years now if you hold bitcoin what are
the bitcoin metrics bitcoin is an
averaging appreciation of over 100
year every year so that means everything
around you if you hold bitcoin is
getting
half off
every single year
so your dream home which was a million
bucks
and then was 1.25 and then five years
later 2 million dollars decade laters
double five million dollars is getting
more expensive dream home in bitcoin
used to be ten thousand bitcoin then it
was a thousand bitcoin and it's 500
bitcoin a lot of people's dream home in
america is less than 100 bitcoin less
than 50 bitcoin and four years from now
it's probably less than that so what
asset do you want to hold and save and
if you hold dollars your life gets more
expensive at a shocking rate if you hold
bitcoin it's half off all year round
baby it's half off your whole life you
don't got to do [ __ ]
black friday in perpetuity
so i'll leave you with that all right
what question you guys got i love it and
i love the energy you're bringing jack
that's just what we needed
i sent him some cuban coffee from miami
to chicago
trust me he doesn't need any more coffee
i don't know what he puts in his veins
every day
he's like ready to just flick everybody
off and get to work all right what
question is good uh jack so you were
talking earlier about uh the mayors
obviously the celebrities the athletes
the entertainers who are using this
product and understand kind of what
using bitcoin as a savings account can
do but as someone who has been working
on this for a long period of time and
talked to a lot of retail traders or
kind of just everyday blue-collar
workers have those conversations changed
are more people understanding this are
more people looking for this solution
just talk through kind of what you're
seeing on that side
yeah i think inflation is a trending
topic right now i think
um whoever the the central banks the
nation state your local government
everyone's kind of lost pulse and grasp
of of the narrative i think the
narrative is in the hands of the people
right now and there's a lot of
speculation whether that's because of
covid there's just a general distrust in
the authority period in your boss in
your local government and you're i mean
it is um and so i think people are
genuinely scared um in it and i and i
think it actually is a really concerning
time for the market at large i think the
federal reserve has perverted risk
tolerance across all assets and you're
seeing [ __ ] like shiba unucoin trade at
premiums and that's really sad it's
because people are fleeing for the exits
and they don't know where to run and
they don't know where to hide and i
think it's scary and so i think it is my
job to try and guide people and give
them accessible tools to what we believe
is right which is the sound safe and
principled savings technology and that
conversation has extended to the biggest
athletes in the world there's a a very
popular golfer who tees off at 4pm
eastern that may get get that paycheck
in bitcoin so really prime time folks to
my neighbors i mean every it's a problem
we all face is if you have capital that
you intend to save how do you save it um
and
so i'm the numbers i'm seeing on my
dashboard we just hit an all-time high
today uh in the payday direct deposit
metrics i mean it goes up every single
day
so i don't know if that answered your
question but uh yeah i i i'll say this
it is uniquely a problem that everyone
in the world faces
um it is money is the most viral product
of all time and it's a product that will
perpetually be in demand and so
it's weird that the president of el
salvador aaron rodgers and the guy that
dropped me off at my thanksgiving with
uber are all cheering for each other and
all trying to solve the same problem i
don't know the last time that that was a
real thing and that that was the case um
and so
yeah that's my answer john
yeah
thanks jack and uh mayor swears for
joining us today so my question would be
mayor swears can you just talk about the
regulation and kind of what's going on
in that conversation if you've heard
anything that uh is either just good or
bad and what you think about regulation
in general in the space
yeah i mean i so what i think about
regulation is that we have to be very
careful as a country china has given us
a tremendous gift
by banning bitcoin and banning mining
which which will allow us to do it in an
esg friendly way most miners in america
that i've talked to that i've spoken
with are esg conscious or or carbon
neutral so this esg
uh issue has i think been overblown um
for a variety of reasons we could do a
whole show on that
but i think that's something that as a
community we need to communicate better
uh because look there's a lot of threats
uh uh to bitcoin there's a lot of people
that feel threatened by bitcoin and so
it's important that a we all communicate
continue to communicate continue to
build our platforms uh b
we have to evangelize to the generation
that right now is still predominantly in
power and that generation
doesn't quite understand it doesn't
quite know what to do with it they kind
of see a lot of the good they realize
how many people are getting it and i
think that's that's a big part of it but
i think they're also afraid you know
look in this country we uh quote unquote
protect people
um from themselves right and so what
does that mean that means oftentimes
we're stripping away
the ability for people to make money on
the under the premise that we don't want
them to be defrauded and so nobody wants
to be defrauded we don't want people to
be defrauded but at the same time if you
take away people's ability to risk
capital you're taking away their ability
to make a return and so that's something
that as bitcoin uh you know becomes more
and more prevalent and and of other
kinds of of of crypto technology you
know we have to really be conscientious
of it uh you know uh you know when
people are able to stake their bitcoin
and get four percent seven percent yield
ten percent yield i mean you know you're
getting the appreciation that jack
talks about but you're not only getting
the appreciation you're also getting a
yield an interest yield on top of the
appreciation right so you know
there is no other financial product as
he said that that gives that there's
none and then and so the question is are
we as a society and as a country going
to stifle innovation or are we gonna
lead into this new what i call
technological industrial revolution
right by embracing the kinds of
technologies that are going to create
financial freedom for more and more
americans in a democratized fashion by
the way it's incredibly democratized not
just for americans for central america
south america obviously we see what's
happening with el salvador or panama's
looking at it a lot of countries in
south america and africa so i think
ironically the the underdeveloped
country or
some would argue as a third world
country they're the ones that really
stand to benefit the most when you look
at the inflation rates in those
countries
i mean there are like 50 and above right
i mean they're crazy crazy inflation
rates so
you know i think i saw venezuela was
like 5 000 or something i don't remember
the exact number but it was a crazy
percentage obviously it's a communist
country so they just print their money
and and deflate their currency and
that's the problem the problem is you
have human beings controlling these
institutions and they're they're making
public policy on the basis of what's
best for them as individuals not what's
best for their country and that's why uh
people are are you know fleeing uh fiat
currencies left and right and and
becoming more and more uh bitcoin
holders uh you know across the world
well said i completely agree mayor
mayor you don't know this yet but uh
john has told me and he's told people on
this show that uh he's waiting for you
to decide to run for governor or
president or decide what your next
career move is and then if you'd be so
kind he'll just go ahead and take over
as mayor he's got some ideas he's come
visit my office next week
listen
we we need good people in public service
i think that's something that our
generation i think now when we see this
bitcoin debate and we see how regulation
can stifle innovation and can hurt
people right it makes you really really
appreciate why it's necessary to have
good people in public service so i
definitely think you know getting in
public service is something that i
totally recommend it's a hard business
um it's not easy uh you have to have
thick skin i know all of you guys do but
um you know but but but i recommend it
because we're listen we're a billion
dollar business we're a billion dollar
entity with 4 500 employees for labor
unions and all the international
problems imaginable so it's it's not an
easy easy thing to do but we need your
people to do it i appreciate you in the
way you have represented the people of
miami i think you've done it very good
all right last question and then i'll
let you two go jack talk to us about
twitter tips that seems to have exploded
uh i think you and i were sending money
back and forth to each other yesterday
as a messaging service what's going on
with uh with twitter tips and how that's
going
uh it's going well i think um
listen bitcoin is a monetary network
it's the only inherently global
accessible asset monetary network in
human history and so internet companies
there's going to be a tremendous amount
of demand for internet companies to
service monetary products to their users
twitter has 500 million active daily
users and they're all over the world how
do you sell them a monetary experience
without bitcoin uh and you know what
they i think the more important
narrative problem we've talked about
this offline is what they started um now
every internet company and every big
companies call my phone um and so no
it's going well why would it not you
have instant free global cash final
payments and tips um and so we're
working with twitter on how to make sure
that that can be outside of just our
service we don't want to be the only one
supporting and and how they can make it
extensible to everyone in the world uh
and then i'm working with other
companies on how to plug in there's a
world not far from now
where your twitter can tip someone on
instagram your instagram account can tip
someone on tick tock my tick tock
account go check out and buy my
starbucks and what does that tell you
that tells you that there's a singular
monetary protocol that can achieve
settlement cheaper faster and more
global than anything else we've ever
seen the last time we saw that form of
consolidation in any industry was the
internet the internet is free instant
global communication for the world
there's not many internet spont there's
one
the bitcoin and lightning network is
free instant global monetary settlement
for the world and there's not going to
be 250 of them there's going to be one
and we're starting to see that
consolidation for money as a service and
as a product and so twitter was the
first it won't be the last it's going
well
i uh i appreciate
can we get a little pawn to e4 just for
the people
there's a chess board back there you
want me to get up and move the pawn
no no no no all right listen i
appreciate both of you obviously you uh
jack you're doing a fantastic job with
strike mayor you've done a fantastic job
as well uh continue to push this forward
so we will definitely continue to bring
you guys back but uh thank you guys so
much for taking time out of your uh your
weekend to do this and uh as uh as we
continue to say just pay me and bitcoin
in the world will be a better place so i
appreciate both
love it thanks love you guys thanks for
having me
okay
all right
lots of stuff going on first of all just
two legends right there yeah i mean he
opened the show like this
he's beating his chest
where else are you guys gonna see will
clemente mayor suarez then you get uh
jack mullers bringing on dylan leclaire
in a second we'd have a murderer's road
today of folks now before we continue we
got a couple of housekeeping these one i
just ordered the 50 nuggets for john
it's on the way john by the way they
don't sell 50 nuggets from what i could
tell i didn't order a 40 and a 10. so
coming over john's going to do the 50.
discourage people
i'm not mentally prepared for this i'm
going to do it anyways
that's first of all second of all is
that uh we are gonna bring on the
thousand person the person who spent a
thousand dollars in the store there's
been two people now the first one we're
gonna bring on here in a second if you
need a refresher
today
everything in the store is 21 off 21 off
means that you go to the bestbusiness
show.com when you go there there's a
couple of different things you can do if
you spend over 100 you'll get a live
shout out on the show we've already done
a couple of them we'll do more in a
minute the second is if you spend over
500 we'll go ahead we'll make a
personalized video me joe and john will
make a personalized video for you the
third thing is if you spend over a
thousand dollars and you
are in the store we will invite you to
come on the show so now we have i think
his name is brian who spent a thousand
dollars in the store today well he's
gonna come on for two or three minutes
we're gonna have a little conversation
you spent a thousand dollars in the
store on merch today i'll bring you on
the show we'll talk about whatever you
want you show all coins we're kicking
you off immediately other than that
knock yourself out is brian here
all right brian's not ready yet we need
another second in the meantime we're
waiting on brian we have a video about
the merchandise chris from our team made
this video very good video i liked the
video so maybe we could play the video
we're waiting on brian to get ready who
spent a thousand dollars in the store
give us one second here then we're going
to go ahead eric said good luck on the
chicken nuggets so thank you eric i'll
publicly say that
all right here we go eat as fast as
possible no breaks 50 is easy if you do
it fast
santa and rudolph may be my favorite
oh that's clean
i got the beanie in front of me
those little joggers joggers a little
bitcoin b jaggas that's something that's
going to deck out your tree i'm gonna
have a few of those on my tree for sure
tree's going up soon the wrapping paper
under the trees all the time yeah i mean
you gotta
i feel like that's an easy buy that's
like let's go again let's go get a
no-brainer now
coffee mug in the morning christmas
morning
johnny might come get you with some uh
little bear some hot chocolate
jogging under your tree
i love that one
there he is
johnny
ready to go yeah so the union's taking
over again y'all thought we were done
he's gone we kicked them out see you
later he couldn't handle the bazooka so
your boys took him out
what do you want to talk about john we
talk about whatever we want i'm talking
about christmas this is now my favorite
time of the year we get going that
christmas ornament when's your christmas
tree going up it's going up is it okay
to put your christmas tree up yes yes
yes my mine uh is on the way uh we got a
christmas tree on the way yeah i got a i
got a fake one oh what are you having a
fake christmas no i had to get the fake
tree uh and it's a it's a it's a tall
one it's like seven and a half feet oh
you got high ceilings but it's but it's
skinny so i could put it next to the uh
in the corner next to the tv and stuff
so it's gonna be nice we're gonna get
that up uh hopefully in the next couple
days i had to go to the bathroom sorry
my favorite part of the bathroom let's
be clear the union members which you
always claim the union they don't work
or they don't do all this stuff i
haven't taken a break yet no breaks
because that's how you enroll a single
show but it's negotiated in our deals
that we can take breaks whenever we want
yeah let's get brian ready there
i'm here
flipping coins let's go all right brian
first of all where where do you live i
like this hat better i like this one but
no i like your hat the one you're
wearing and i tried to buy a merchandise
i couldn't buy that [ __ ] hat i love
it this is a special hat but where do
you live
oh [ __ ] all right beverly hills beverly
hills all right you live in beverly
hills obviously you like bitcoin tell me
about the hat that you're holding there
what is that hat
ah of course it's bitcoin no no not that
hat the other hat oh it's an artist you
know
yeah yeah i mean i just i just like the
collect bitcoin
all right how many do you got like a
whole stack of them or the only two i
only bought two i bought one for my
white but you can't really wear these
hats because this art so it's okay
all right so what did you buy in the
store you spent a thousand dollars so i
got to know what you bought oh actually
i spent 2 000 i bought another
legend what did you buy in this store
for two thousand dollars
it's called don't [ __ ] give up like
the first time you couldn't do i'm like
i'll spend on achievement i'll probably
be back on we'll do it all right what
are you doing what do you do on a
day-to-day basis this is wild to me
right it's like you and i are talking
here you're in beverly hills i'm in
miami what do you do
i mean oh god i'm a retired drug lord
so um
legend
no one better ever accuse this show
about being live
hey what up
all right so what questions you got what
do you want to talk about what is it are
you drinking wine
of course i'm doing some cocaine too you
want something no
it's a family show brian family show
jesus christ all right what do you want
to talk about you got another 90 seconds
come on all right just cut me off let's
do it no i mean honestly
uh it's interesting how the mayor's
talking about his age 44 45 and i just
like i feel that we're all adopting into
this new movement i'm a big proponent of
it
i love my bitcoin you actually have to
slice me to take my bitcoin from me
that's how much i feel about it
i mean that's still graphic i'm sorry
but um but yeah i mean i'm just a big
adopter i'm like 12 different exchanges
every time i make money i just buy buy
huddle dollar cost average i don't
really care about
you know the short term when it goes
down and dips you know whatever i'm in
the 5 10 year game that's where i'm at
what's your twitter account everyone
wants to know what your twitter account
is they say i don't i don't have
brian david suiter yes all right we i'm
gonna put that in here for people if
they want to go follow you you got to
get a twitter i feel like you want to
you would be electric on twitter
if you get a twitter you just go ahead
and you uh you just tweet at me and i'll
know exactly who it is it's interesting
because i think i'm gonna go back to
miami i was actually down for the
bitcoin conference last year and uh and
i'm gonna probably buy a place in
brickell it's just like everything is so
pro like you know like cryptocurrency i
love it
so i'm definitely do that
if you come to miami we will you can
come get on the show no alcohol no drugs
come on
come on
i appreciate i appreciate you i hope
that everything you got you give to your
family your friends for christmas
that's how that's how i got my mommy i
just buy her [ __ ] ethereum
that's how it got her adopted to it
i appreciate you all right
i'll message you on instagram so that
we're connected you could send me all
kinds of memes or whatever else you're
sending to people on the internet
i mean that's the wildest two two-minute
segment we've ever had on the show bro
he's gonna get us banned from youtube
again
this freaking guy i told you we're the
most dangerous show that was wild
whoo
yeah i mean that was just an old brian
from beverly hills the goat mountain for
that the beer goat mountain like this
i'm going to brickle yeah
i don't even know what 9 30 a.m guys
drinking yeah let's not forget beverly
hills in california which means he's
three hours behind our time zone here
that was ryan
in the spirit of brian i'm not giving
out any alcohol or anything but we're
giving about a hundred dollars with a
bitcoin right now so all you got to do
one two three smash the like button once
you smash the like button go ahead drop
your twitter or your instagram handle
into the chat we're gonna pick one
person hundred bucks in bitcoin right
now we're just gonna keep going we're
gonna keep just
just keep going we got dylan leclair
coming on next after dylan we've got uh
paulina it's gonna come on then we've
got natalie bruno coming on then we got
danny boy also hard coming on then we
got preston pish coming on then we got a
neal from delphi coming on then we've
got pj kevin coming on i mean we're just
murderers row of guests today we're
going to say here we're going to keep
talking to people understanding johnny
nuggets
john
at one o'clock
by the way did you guys know you can't
order chick-fil-a on seamless this is a
conspiracy
are we going to order on like ubereats
no i'm i'm in the process of still
ordering are you good joe i'm good yeah
i'm just going to be here
we need uh michael saylor in here he's
part of the union michael saylor is not
part of the union yes he is no fosho
okay
who we got john
drop is your twitter instagram account
john who's winning 100 with the bitcoin
henry and the horses said it's his
birthday next week so here's a little
birthday present for you there we go
let's go shout out happy birthday
birthday henry
and the horses
and the horses that's his name all right
we we also are going to bring up the
other uh thousand person winner in a few
minutes i think we're working on getting
him a link someone just spent 500 in the
store too let's get it 500 bucks we're
do it we're tracking well we're tracking
well 500 bones every thousand dollars
you spend you get to come on the show
live like that was a pretty smooth thing
i mean that was londoner he said no i
spent two he said i spent two thousand
nothing
all we're saying is you can go if you're
gonna spend a thousand dollars on
christmas gifts why not spend it in the
store 21 off you get more goods for your
price not inflation that's deflation
working for you right there and then
we'll bring you on the show you get
three minutes on the show talk about
whatever you want so the bazooka boys
yeah you could say the union socks
you're gonna bust it up or whatever you
want you can join the union on the show
that's the show you can do all that
stuff all right there he is johnny
johnny lean back
oh you too johnny lean sorry when the
mcdonald's nuggets get here he's gonna
be sitting like that ranger's in the
is in the building
is in the building i told you guys we
had surprises for you uh ranger we might
have to bring on the show we have to do
his hair and makeup first but
should we get him not right now not
right now all right in a little bit
we'll bring ranger on dylan are you
there
yo yo
dylan guys in the backyard
i'm not even taking this seriously today
is that a fire pit back there
where are you in florida
um like right right uh about like half
an hour from orlando right in the middle
oh all right kind of far away i was
going to say if you're in florida you
can come see us that's that's being
upset all right first
first of all is that a fire pit behind
you
yeah all right just making sure uh
second thing is uh how are you not
catching the wind in the microphone
uh i don't know it's not too windy
like he's like i'm outside orlando yeah
he is hey i'm outside orlando we're
landlocked
in the plane well hold up first of all
it's not landlocked in florida
florida's a little bit no orlando i'm
talking about he's he's in the middle
he's good all right dylan talk us
through the price is going down right
now what's up with the bitcoin's price
why is it going down
yeah i think it's just some uh
macroeconomic uncertainty uh some of the
stuff with the the new variant which is
you know you can i guess assess the
validity of that uh you know yourself
but i think that's you know you're
seeing equity sell off you're seeing uh
you know like crude oils down like 13
today just various asset classes are
selling off and bitcoins just kind of
reacting sort of as a risk on asset but
um you know really it's just i think
investors are kind of
uh searching for a little bit of
protection not in the way that we think
of it uh in the terms of like they're
going to print a lot of money which i
think that's the response that's going
to come with any sort of you know
macroeconomic shock but just on a you
know intraday time frame i think that's
what's occurring
all right and when you see that are
there specific metrics in the bitcoin
network that you look at when there's
something that appears to be affecting
it from outside like an external shock
like this is there things that you look
at for either measuring health or things
that you look at like if this happens
i'd be really worried
yeah so i think um you know looking at
something like long-term holders uh you
know coin days destroyed stuff like that
where you can see like day to day what's
happening with kind of old coins i'm
seeing just like a little bit of
elevated spikes on both of those things
today um and so i think that's just you
know like with long-term holders that
you know there's a decline of about 76
000 bitcoin which sounds like a lot but
um it's you know we're still far above
the levels we were at this summer in
terms of accumulation so i'm not too
worrisome but just kind of i think it's
investors are looking for a little bit
of protection and maybe maybe taking a
small amount of chips off the table
got it and when we start to think about
the
numbers that i pulled up earlier in the
show so 0.01 bitcoin balance on bitcoin
addresses the number of bitcoin
addresses with 0.01 as the balance or
more hit an all-time high we're now at
almost 9.3 million also 89 of bitcoin is
in profit do you put any credence or
value to like some of those underlying
metrics that continue to hit all-time
highs or remain very very attractive or
is this simply a game of supply demand
everything else is uh kind of a function
or an outcome of the supply demand
that's all you care about is looking at
supply and demand
yeah so i mean i think there's there's a
couple different like cohorts of of
bitcoin investors or kind of you know
supply and demand there's there's the
stackers and the hodlers who you know
strike just rolled out hourly dca right
so so i set up an hourly dca and every
single you know every single hour i'm
taking some satoshi's off the market and
i know there are a ton of people that
are also doing that and at a lot larger
scale than i am
all over the world so so that's kind of
like that base level demand and you're
seeing that that's that's occurred for
the last 10 years and that will continue
to occur uh but you also see you know
with the derivatives market and with the
bitcoin on exchanges there's like a few
million bitcoin about two three million
bitcoin that are basically just wash
traded day to day uh and you know
whether it's a headline uh whether it's
cpi or the coronavirus uh you know
variant risk and all this stuff it's
just headline traders and so you know
they kind of whip saw the price around
over the short term over the interim uh
but over the you know weeks months
quarter year time frame uh it's really
the stackers the hodlers that kind of
set the floor and and you know kind of
create this reservation demand for
bitcoin
all right and then when you start to
look at things like dca
via that is that where you see the world
kind of moving to is just more of like
this automatic uh dca streaming payments
like people just kind of set it and
forget it or do you think that as
bitcoin's price goes up people will
still look at this as like a very much
like macro investment thesis like okay
here's my thesis here's what my
allocation of my portfolio is here's
what i'm willing to risk here's how much
i'm looking for as a upside here's what
i'm gonna sell at if there's downside
risk management like how do you think
this plays out is it more of an
investment asset or people really do
look at the savings account
i think it's both and that's what what's
the fascinating thing about it is like
and i and i kind of play both a little
bit myself where i view it as my
long-term savings account
as my savings medium you know i have i
have a stash that i'm not going to touch
for for decades um you know hopefully
hopefully leave it to uh you know
my kids that i don't even have yet
but also at the same time it's treated
as as kind of this this risk on risk-off
asset um day-to-day and so you know and
like with the derivatives like we were
talking about um you're going to see
stuff uh on the shorter time frames
where where it pumps like crazy or dumps
and a lot of people are just kind of
confused by that volatility and saying
how is this possibly uh you know a safe
haven uh you know medium for for for
your long term value but um you know the
there's kind of those those two investor
classes like we talked about or maybe
not investors but the savers the hodlers
and then kind of the day traders and so
you know you can you can be both but i
think for most people around the world
more and more people are kind of
treating it as this savings medium and
i'm just going to passively allocate to
this on a day-to-day basis or week to
week or whatever it is um and you know
whether that's corporations whether
that's uh wall street's institutions
whether that's nation states um or just
individuals i think you know broadly
more people are adopting this and with
absolute scarcity you know the price can
only go one way in the long term
got it when uh joe and john's got
questions they're gonna ask you here in
a second but uh one other thing that i'm
very interested in is uh we've now seen
bitcoin city and we talked a little bit
about this uh earlier in the week but it
feels like this bitcoin backed bond uh
we continue to see samson mao talk a ton
about there's lots of interest lots of
interest uh do you still feel pretty
strongly that this thing's gonna be like
oversubscribed and lots of people are
gonna want access to it like i do or
after having some more time to think
about it like have your thoughts changed
a little bit as to what the reception
for that bitcoin backed bond might be
i think it's pretty interesting just in
the sense that you know with fixed
income there's there's no upside it's
really only downside in the sense that
um you're getting paid a you know a
fixed amount of fiat currency
traditionally with fixed income and so
any sort of inflation risk or um you
know usually it's not at a sovereign
level but any sort of default risk
there's really only downside you know if
you're talking about other sorts of
investments whether it's equities
bitcoin you're thinking about how much
can i make but fixed income investors
off you know they're thinking about how
much can i lose um and with with yields
around the world basically at record
lows um you're not even accounting for
deflation or default risk fixed income
investors really
are in a tough spot so when you have
kind of this this call option upside
with the bitcoin exposure that el
salvador's bitcoin bond comes with i
think a lot of you know maybe investors
or fixed income investors that were
skeptical of bitcoin in the past are
looking at this thing that's been the
best performing asset probably i think
eight years out of the last decade
saying hey uh you know this is this is
pretty interesting
got it joe john what questions do you
guys have for dylan dylan uh a lot of
people joke about uh everyone talking to
their grandparents and their parents and
their siblings and everything like that
and selling them on bitcoin uh during
the holidays i'm curious is there like
actually anything on chain that we can
look at to see if any of this is is
happening on a substantial level or not
not that not that i've seen i mean
anecdotally um i threw out some some
joke tweets yesterday um no my my uncle
jim did not mortgage the house uh to buy
bitcoin on the spot but um i i mean i
have had all the conversations with all
of them uh and bitcoin did come up you
know 10 20 times throughout the last
couple days and so i think that's
happening around the world i mean uh you
know there's there's that that bitcoiner
in the in the friend group and the
family that continues to talk about it
year over year and you know the results
don't lie so in terms of like whether we
can see that in the data in terms of
yesterday uh i don't i don't think so at
least not from what i've seen but i
think you know there's just that that
kind of that lindy effect uh and you
know that that crazy cousin uh you know
it continues continues to be right and
so you know there's something to say
about that
john what questions do you have what's
up dylan nice to see you in florida you
look uh you're happy i'm glad
thanksgiving well for you so my question
is what is your argument for people that
say like how do i convince people when i
get together with the for the holidays
how do i convince them that bitcoin is a
store value like what bitcoin is like
what is your easiest 30 second pitch for
people to say
yeah um i think one of the things that
worked really well for me and it may not
be like hold up true right now with the
recent price dump but um i checked as of
like a week or two ago it was you took
10 bucks a day over the last four years
and just passively allocated to it
instead of going to the gas station or
you know 10 bucks a day right it's not
too much um 10 times 365 times four
that's about fourteen thousand dollars
passively put away uh and that's of
about a week ago that was a hundred
thousand dollars and so obviously as
bitcoin grows um those returns are going
to be diminished um the upside isn't
isn't what it was four years ago or four
years before that
but just you know in terms of a lot of
people get scared away by the volatility
but you know from a compound annual
growth rate perspective not many asset
classes are going to beat that sort of
performance and i think that's going to
hold true going into the future um and a
lot of you know there's a lot of shock
and awe when you kind of throw those
numbers around saying hey you know just
10 bucks a day you know a lot of a lot
of people that aren't investors or don't
know where to even start hear that and
you know their eyes kind of get a little
wide so that's what i've been using as
my kind of 30 second pitch boomers at
the table might uh their jaws might hit
the floor if you talk about the amount
that it's appreciated over the last
decade compared to bonds or anything
else
yeah exactly i mean those treasury bonds
that you know whatever 1.5 percent don't
look too attractive
dylan another thing that we saw this
morning is uh singapore has uh approved
two bitcoin spot funds how do you think
about like geopolitical competition uh
from other regulatory regimes with the
united states if the u.s doesn't approve
a bitcoin spot etf uh and kind of
continues to drag its feet on some of
that stuff do you see investors wanting
to just go get the exposure in these
other markets or is still the u.s kind
of the king and once it gets approved
there'll still be massive capital
inflows in your opinion
yeah i mean i think u.s capital uh
public capital markets are the biggest
in the world and and we'll continue to
you know
there's just no kind of competition from
just total size perspective but in terms
of like the bitcoin geopolitical kind of
game theory or maybe jurisdictional
arbitrage it's really really interesting
and seeing that especially following the
china ban earlier in the year um seeing
some politicians say you know we have to
capitalize east first west and and we
want to come out ahead this is a matter
of national security i mean it's playing
out how a lot of people said it would
play out in theory but it's not theory
anymore and i think that's one of the
things that the biggest bitcoin skeptics
still are missing it's like you know
we're going to ban bitcoin and it's like
well obviously we're not because there's
there's so much uh interest in this
there's so much vested interest in this
asset class uh whether that's from the
political standpoint or just in terms of
the pure capital behind it and all the
lobbying efforts that are happening you
know beneath the surface so uh you know
we still don't have a spot etf but uh
there's just no way a band will occur
and i think you know eventually the
pressure will mount so high that you
know we have all these other countries
that have it why don't why don't our
capital markets have one um and so we'll
probably see that in 2022 but the
timeline on that is still unknown
got it and then last question i have for
you and then we'll let you go and let
you go back to your family and enjoy in
florida is when you look out at uh the
bull market obviously this price
drawdown there's a lot of people who are
nervous they're scared they're they're
fearful does anything change about your
outlook or do you still see us uh kind
of in a continuing bull market and have
a pretty um kind of deep conviction and
that price will go much much higher you
know through the end of this year and
potentially into q1 of next year
yeah i mean i think in terms of like the
thesis is completely unchanged in terms
of the recent events over the last week
over the last couple weeks we talked
earlier this week about the dollar
strengthening against other fiats um and
even though you know inflation is
running hot in the us uh strengthening
dollar in the global economic system is
is is bad news for all asset classes and
so you know that's what we saw in oa
that's what we saw in 2020 uh but but
the good news is any sort of response to
some sort of uh dollar shock and an
asset sell-off is more of the same right
so you know it's kind of heads heads you
win tails uh you also win in the sense
that they're gonna continue to have to
print a lot of money uh the response can
be more of the same and even if the you
know the fed or you know politicians
jawbone we know what's gonna happen
money supply is gonna increase and you
know basically equities in every sort of
asset class bitcoin included even if
they don't admit it uh keeping that
price sustained as a matter of national
security just with with you know how the
the financial system the economic system
is currently uh stocks everything can't
go down for a sustained period of time
just because with how the fiat system is
built and so you know we kind of know
the long game is that you know if
there's a shock to the downside it's an
opportunity
because you know the response will be
more of the same and bitcoin is the
asset you want to hold in that scenario
makes sense to me real quick follower
check dylan's at 89 000.
means by the end of the month he'll be
at 100. keep tweeting don't mess up keep
tweeting we had 100 by the end of the
year that means we got to put one big
50k follower month together in december
and we're at 150k like i said he would
be you you got it in you
i think so hopefully
john
you can get 200k by the end of the year
i'm trying
it won't be for lack of effort i'll tell
you that
all right dylan
i appreciate you taking a few minutes to
uh to jump on here uh obviously you've
been uh been all over a lot of this
stuff and uh uh we appreciate all the
the data you've been sharing joe john
you get any last comments thoughts
statements
i'm trying to order this chick-fil-a
over here
i appreciate you joining us for
thanksgiving dylan i hope you have a
wonderful holiday season and we'll talk
soon good luck to the 150 go fall down
what is it at dylan leclair
underscore yep underscore gotcha all
right buddy
thank you so much appreciate you
happy holidays you too all right now you
might have just heard i got a surprise
for everyone uh but before we uh we move
on at one o'clock we have uh natalie
brunell coming on but you know i decided
that maybe ranger's in the building
ranger's not gonna be on the show yet
but he will be on later
we got
my wife paulina marinova here who has
not been on the show for a very long
time there she is
she has not been glowing
for a while
this is my camera that's your camera
right there yes there you go how are you
i'm great i was promised chick-fil-a and
i just heard that like you haven't
ordered it i'm ordering it because
because the big dog is in charge no i'm
over here
i'm running the show i'm giving out
bitcoin i'm giving shout outs the dude's
doing drugs on the show you hear this
he's acting like we're not driving [ __ ]
everywhere
this is bad news all right
stop feeling why have you not been on
the show
i have not been on the show well because
you know i was sleeping a lot but um
because it was huh because because there
is now a baby but i was on the show i
was like eight months pregnant we did it
let's give a quick shout out to sophia
sophia will not be on the show today so
she's not ready
so keep it down but uh i will say that i
i will give me and you kudos we hit it
pretty well
well yeah because the table you know it
was it was put the table up kind of
covered up your stomach it was great all
right uh i want to talk real quick for a
few minutes about uh your dad your dad
evo yes uh he
in bulgaria lived through hyperinflation
and you guys have talked about it before
yes talk a little bit about uh his kind
of recollection of hyperinflation just
how bad it was yeah so i think there
have been
he's lived through it through two
periods of hyperinflation one before i
was born oh god sorry wow uh one before
us
i have a lot of hand gestures and it's
you're rusty
i know
uh one before i was born in the 80s and
then one after i was born in the 90s
but the one after i was born in the 90s
is when he was working at a pretty good
job in bulgaria i think it was the
ministry of finance so he had a pretty
good salary except one day when
hyperinflation hit his salary went down
to like 30 cents a month or something
ridiculously stupid so he was like well
what's the point of going to work i'm
just not going to go to work if you're
going to pay me 30 cents a month um
and
but like a lot of his co-workers kept
going because they were scared they were
going to lose their jobs otherwise can
you imagine that
well i can only imagine it because he's
told me about it but the part to me that
uh
was my two takeaways one
other people kept going to work like
other people were like oh i don't care
that the hyperinflation is happening i
don't know what else to do so i'm just
going to keep going to work do you think
they kept going to work because they're
like oh it'll fix itself and i still
want my job at this nice place
no i don't think that uh
i i don't think that that's the case i
think instead what the case is
that people end up um
not having anything to do other than
their routine
right and so if you only have your
routine
then what else is like you just keep
going to work everyone else goes to work
there's social pressure to go to work
you're there's social tie-in to go to
work frankly what am i gonna do be
depressed and sit at home by myself like
no i'm gonna go to work and we'll be
miserable together it's like there's
this element of like the social ties the
second takeaway that i had was
if you're only getting paid 30 cents or
whatever eventually you're just like yo
i'm out but i think there is a tipping
point where it's just like wait a minute
are people kind of get shaken awake and
we're seeing that in some countries
right now where there is hyperinflation
that's not happening in the united
states it's not happening in most
developed nations but if you get massive
debasement of the currency like if at
some point you do get there yeah and i
think it was interesting because uh my
dad didn't know a lot about bitcoin when
i first told him about it it was just
like whatever was in the news and then
when anthony came and explained it in
terms of like hyperinflation and how it
could work in that situation i think it
makes sense for people who have been
through something like that
i'm still trying to order chick-fil-a
it's not easy dude we gotta go joe
joe scrap my order by the way you don't
want it no no why because i'm gonna go
eat elsewhere well i'm it's already
we're in the final we're in the final
stages
we're gonna get extra i'm just so
jealous you guys are about to eat
chick-fil-a well there's extra coming so
i don't think i'll be full
doing it on the phone on ubereats is not
easy though the other thing i want to
quickly talk about there's a million
options
real quick while playing this here is uh
joe and john you two now are uh our
uncles how do you feel about being a
google phone uncle joe uncle john i love
being an uncle yeah john it's an honor
i i like being an uncle i hope sophia
likes me being her uncle as much as i
like her being her uncle i asked her i
said what do you think about joe being
your uncle and she just stared at me she
didn't say anything well she hasn't said
any words yet that's not true all topics
what did she say huh she said dad died
she literally came out of the movies
like dad and i was like hey
what anthony tell them about what you
were saying to her the other day and
what she did okay look there's some
controversy already with the baby listen
the baby is a baby it's small you know
it's got two arms two legs we're good
it's healthy he's happy we're good to go
but
i don't know when you can start to
program the baby's brain yeah so he only
programs the baby's brain when i'm not
around true that's a fact because you
know i don't need to have censorship
when i'm trying to program the baby's
brain so twice plain has walked in the
room the first time plano walked in the
room uh i was said probably i was on
number 970 second time of saying dada
dada dad just like over and over and
over again eventually like the baby will
get it right so like that's first the
second thing that i was programming the
baby's brain with was paulina walked in
the room and i didn't realize she was
about to walk in the room and i said uh
revenue minus expenses equals
profit and no joke the baby put her
hands on her ears that is oh she did it
no she didn't know she did it she was
looking at me like okay tell me the next
lesson like we were locked in we were
good to go
is that bad things to be telling the
baby i mean it could be worse it could
be so
like i could be talking about politics
or uh vaccination status we're good we
keep going with the profits but like
revenue minus expenses equals profit i
feel like that's a real base level
that's a baby level understanding wait
can i ask questions yeah sure so what's
going on with the show like what's going
on here what do you mean you know i just
tuned in a little bit ago
what's going on how's it going
i tuned into the guy talking about drugs
i was like i don't know what's going on
that that was pretty wild yeah but
ubereats is frozen oh my god joe
do you want me to order it no well let's
be clear here everyone's saying wow wow
wow like i'm doing a bad job over here i
got sent six different orders everyone's
got different menus i'm trying to get
sauces i don't want to be the guy
messing stuff up here all right
everyone's gonna get their sauces are
crucial yeah sauces are key how are my
friends on the internet because i don't
have my laptop i feel kind of they're
doing very well uh they want to know uh
if sophia's first bedtime story will be
the bitcoin white paper no but we do we
do have a bitcoin book remember we do
yeah somebody did send us a baby book uh
bitcoin baby book um i think that's
pretty good oh people are saying of
course the union they can't get a food
order right
[Laughter]
john is not amused i think nacho doesn't
want to pay
[Laughter]
shut up all right
you're conveniently over here i did just
get a i just did got a text message that
says your food order from mcdonald's is
here so somewhere in some way all right
mcdonald's how did you i'll go get it we
in route 40 minutes 30 they said
standard delivery 30 to 40 minutes
the mcnugget challenge yeah i'll go grab
it right now what no somebody we we've
got folks we got you ordered it for
yourself no wait john's going to eat 50
nuggets in an hour oh god chick-fil-a's
on the way
do you want to do it as well no but i
could do it you could eat fifty dollars
i don't keep saying i'm gonna i'm gonna
try to wait
john you already got yourself ordered
planet just hit us with that she could i
could i've done it you've seen me eat
this
food delivery
eight nine one two nine
planet you think you could eat i didn't
you've seen me eat
you 15 nuggets in an hour please be my
guest in an hour by the way people said
that planet has the best vibes that's
true i do have great vibes
that's because jordy and matt over
exposed me on the camera i don't know
what that means i just know it makes me
look good you're overexposed i'm over i
i texted them before i got on and they
said overexpose me damn i gotta get
overexposed
probably there's nothing they can do
today they got tricks to make me look
better [ __ ]
bro your face is i can use some help
by the way just so everyone knows uh our
parents my mother and father sophia's
grandparents are here in miami i've been
trying to get my dad to come on the show
and he just keeps telling me nah the
head economist that pomp boyz
is going to tell us all about
translation on the streets if he if he
comes on the show i promise you youtube
kicks us off
that's the death that's the death
sentence what they're here but they're
not here here do you know where they are
they were here earlier but you weren't
so they were here they checked out the
place they were like it's pretty good i
should uh my dad i said you could sit in
this chair and he hit me with the you
don't want that and i said why did he go
instead of present uh yeah here you want
it wait wait really oh gosh hands deep
wait can i open it no no no no it's
showing the wrapping paper it's a prop
oh
yeah so toss it back so by the way
some of you may know i put up a
christmas tree on november
2nd
and um
there's presents underneath it
that i have wrapped for anthony i i
don't see any rap for me anthony ready
yeah
it's okay we got there it got on my
blanket um all right anything else
no i think we're good is there anything
that you would like to tell the people
be kind to your friends we appreciate it
are you gonna now now that we have a
child another living breathing animal
that we have to take care of
are you going to oh we have a question
she's joining the show more often yeah
uh what's your favorite like there she
is right there wait let me see yeah
sophia little picture of sophia so
what's your favorite thing about dad
life oh oh i don't want to say this
because people are going to get mad
changing diapers no i have a uh
no do not do not i'm great i'm crazy
last night we had a incident
snafu snafu so there's a couple of ways
you could take diaper you could sound
like you're not supposed to say so watch
yourself yeah but but what i will say by
the way john giant science experiment
over here
i got a song i got a strategy for that
by the way i already saw something i
ordered extra sauce just because i
didn't know which one i believe in
jonathan
that's what i was thinking i was like
hold on hold on this is important this
is important what is uh remember when i
would tweet and i'd be like oh i slept
on an eight-sleep mattress like i got
all this great sleep and everyone's
gonna go wait till you have a kid well
i'm one weekend now yesterday was one
week since the baby was born and i just
want every single one of you guys to
hear me out there's no night nurse
there's no help i'm the help plan is to
help that's it there's no help he does
help a lot the second thing is that i'm
sleeping more now than i was before the
baby but so
don't be coming at me tell me we'll wait
till you have a kid it's all about how
efficient you want to be and how
intentional you want to be we got the
same baby it cries it breathes it eats
it poops it sleeps with everything your
baby would do but i'm sleeping more now
than i was before because the baby makes
me go to sleep someone asked what sauces
i got ranch barbecue and sweet and sour
i didn't pick these this is perfect
though there's no free ads but you just
gave an ad basically for eight sleep
because you're sleeping more if anyone
wants any sleep mattress
you can you can go to eightsleep.com
joe and it's the biggest sale of the
year no that's just one joe says with
two fries so you know there's 50. i
don't got to worry about nutrition
because i sleep like a baby regardless
of my age
i appreciate you coming on the show
thank you very much thank you so much
your excuse thank you for your service
no thank you for your service okay show
everyone your shirt real quick oh yeah
joe and i are matching
joe has it if you go into the store and
you buy a hundred dollars you get a
shout out if you buy five hundred
dollars we'll give you a personalized
video if you buy a thousand dollars in
the store you get to come on the show
today that those are the rules i made
them so i get to enforce them second of
all is am i leaving yeah you're bi see
ya gone all right second thank you for
joining
paulina we bring down what they said
john's about to poop and fall asleep
after this deal
before we continue and natalie
john real quick show everybody that he
got 50 buckets here and i'm gonna i'm
gonna hit a timer i'm gonna hit go so
that everyone knows that john's really
doing it oh they're full oh they're
they're it's all full danny boy hustle
hard keeps texting me and all he keeps
asking is what am i not allowed to say
[Laughter]
there's 20 10
10. so we got 50 nuggets we got the 50
nuggets everyone be quiet and chill out
are you ready john no no you're not
ready i'm never really i know you're
there just give us a second we're coming
natalie i got no questions for you how
you doing
hold on all right you ready john um on
the count of three
one
one
two two at a time to start now i wanna
put the camera on him for so when he
starts this real quick one what time is
it one two three go i got a timer whoa
oh oh you ain't gonna make it oh he's
going right for it i don't know that's
five seconds how much you need four
already
[Laughter]
ten seconds in
what do you what sauce is he dipping in
he's got multiple sauces
he's got a bunch of different options
though all right i'm gonna have some
fries in the meantime all right real
quick natalie are you there
hey hello how are you
good how are you we're doing great sorry
questions to you and paulina thank you
baby thank you very much happy
thanksgiving to you i appreciate you
jumping on here for a few minutes i'm
sorry things got sidetracked my brother
is going to try to eat 50 nuggets in an
hour yes
we'll see how this goes
i could beat that you i can beat that
john's like do it yeah john's like yeah
go ahead and do it
sponsored by mcdonald's now no we're not
we don't do free ads on here we don't
know where these nuggets came from but
john is uh john what are we at by the
way you don't know yet okay all right
natalie let's talk real quick uh i want
to talk about two things one you've gone
on mainstream uh news a couple times now
you're just dropping knowledge bombs on
these people uh and the two things that
i keep hearing you talk about is one
inflation and two the fact that no one
knows what the hell to do when inflation
hits so maybe walk us through what is
the problem with inflation and then what
should people be doing
well the frustrating thing to me is that
the people on mainstream news and our
politicians aren't being honest about
not only the fact that we have inflation
but what causes it so i'm hoping to use
my skills that i acquired being in
mainstream news to hopefully educate the
public on money printing and the fact
that you know in the last year 40 of the
dollars that are in circulation were
printed and there's a reason that the
prices are going up and there's you know
certain people that are benefiting i
don't know if you saw that article on
cnbc that private jets like there's a
record number of private jets being sold
right now the rich are getting richer
meanwhile it's hard to buy milk at the
store for the average person so you know
i just think it's really important to
tell the truth and it's frustrating when
you see
you know the politicians sort of denying
that inflation even exists or they act
shocked economists are shocked that 6.2
percent is the is the rate that they're
admitting to and um i just hope that
people educate themselves and bitcoin's
the perfect way to educate yourself
because it really helps you go down the
rabbit hole of of economics in our
monetary system
and when you think about uh the
disparity between the top let's say 10
the bottom 90 percent is it something
that can be solved with things other
than bitcoin or is it literally they
have to use something like bitcoin that
can't be debased as that savings account
in order to protect themselves
well i think that's what's so great
about this being a savings technology
and a form of digital property that
nobody can confiscate from you because
at this point i feel like we're just
kicking the can down the road and we
can't fix this problem unless it's going
to be a very painful crash to unwind
some of the leverage that we have so at
this point it's like they're stuck
between a rock and a hard place they
could either hike you know interest
rates and they could taper but it could
it would be very very painful or they're
going to lead us into hyperinflation so
you know this is a great way to just opt
out i truly believe that bitcoin is that
peaceful way to opt out for anyone to be
able to start accumulating wealth for
their family again we used to be able to
put our money in the bank and get what
like six percent a couple decades ago
well now with bitcoin what you could get
like 300 in a year i think it's amazing
and i hope that more people educate
themselves on it
you've talked to a ton of what i'll call
normie friends right people who know
nothing about bitcoin that you know from
uh your professional life or social
circles and you've done a great job kind
of orange pilling them what's the
narrative that you see really resonating
with them in terms of how they wake up
to uh whether it's inflation or to uh
bitcoin itself
well i really think that the recent
headlines have helped with you know
inflation being 6.2 percent and just
seeing the fact that everything's
getting so much more expensive and then
when you denominate it in bitcoin terms
everything's getting cheaper and cheaper
so i think that those you know
those references in the media have
started to help and i try to put out
there just sort of that basic knowledge
of what is money printing and why it
helps the upper class as opposed to the
the income earners and the savers and
the middle and the bottom classes so
yeah and honestly i've been really
surprised because as i've put my self
out there more i wasn't able to do this
when i had my network job people have
started to ask me more questions and
said hey you know i actually ended up
investing in bitcoin and it was because
of you you inspired it so i'm super
grateful because some of the people that
were the most skeptical on my feeds and
who followed me especially from my old
career now they're starting to be like
hey what was that app that you wanted me
to buy bitcoin on or
so it's been great i think it's you know
slowly but surely it's inevitable
and when you start to think about how
people come into the market do you see
them dollar costs averaging like 10 20
30 at a time do you see them coming in
and being like hey here's a hundred
thousand dollars i'm all in like
what is the kind of those first steps
that people are taking after you
convince them
most of them are putting in like a
hundred bucks
um no i think that a lot of them are
starting with dca just because the price
looks so intimidating and overwhelming
you know some people i'm sure can can
drop the 50 to 60 000 for one whole
bitcoin but what i'm noticing is people
are just like slowly inching their way
in dipping their toes in the water with
a couple dollars or a couple hundred
dollars and i'm sure that it will
continue especially the the way that
we're headed now i'm pretty sure this
variant is going to spark the money
printer to just go even faster
eventually so yeah i think dca all the
way
and speaking of uh kind of the monetary
policy and fiscal policy in response to
more of these variants more of these
viruses
i'm not a scientist i don't know what
the hell is going on but it seems like
people are really nervous again uh is
that just the standard is that the
default now is every time something like
this happens we should expect uh some
sort of manipulation or intervention in
the economic markets
well i i'm certainly starting to expect
that because they were just slowly
starting to mention the t word you know
taper people i think we're expecting it
early next year but with a variant and
the potential for more lockdowns and
more you know economic activity that's
slowing because of the pandemic
continuing on and on i mean what we're
almost going to be two years in march i
just think that the response is going to
be you know keep the bubble afloat and
print more money and that's always a
good value proposition for bitcoin
because the more that they print the
more that i think people realize that
the system is broken and it's a total
sham and there's nothing behind it like
where's the wizard you know so i just
think it's going to ultimately help
bitcoin but i do i really believe that
the money printer is going to go bur
even more if we have a variant that's
going to lock people down again
countries in europe already are locking
down so i just think that's the
direction we're headed in
joe what questions you got hey natalie
uh good to see you again
m m yeah john's over here just powering
through
don't mind him he's he's over 30.
no i got 15 left
i'm not joking no you're not going down
hold on natalie sorry wait you're
already over 30. yeah he's dude he's
seven minutes in it's seven minutes and
thirty nuggets right here i got ten more
this was ten right here all right all
right go ahead five seconds
36 nuggets in seven minutes
which has to be a record of some type of
uh natalie so my question would just be
we talked about last time how you ended
up leaving your job to focus more on
bitcoin content and all this stuff
full-time how's that all going
it's going great i'm so glad i made this
decision it's really been paying off i
am getting to actually talk about what
i'm most passionate about which is
helping people achieve financial freedom
and being able to save for the future i
wrote this article for bitcoin magazine
about how i truly believe bitcoins this
renaissance of the american dream which
is important to me because i immigrated
here and my family lost everything in
the last financial crisis and i just
don't want to see people struggle when
there's such an amazing option for them
to claim their you know make sure that
their money holds value into the future
and i love everyone that i've met
including you guys i'm so humbled and
grateful today i hit a hundred thousand
followers somehow so i'm giving away
some satoshi head to my twitter page at
nat brunel i was inspired by you anthony
you always give away stuff on your show
so i'm going to be giving away a million
satoshi's so yeah i'm just super
grateful i think it was a really good
good decision and i can't wait to
educate and orange pull more people
that's awesome i love it john go you got
a question yeah i got it i got a letter
i'm so confident you're gonna ask 11
nuggets left um
hey natalie happy thanksgiving so my
question would be about like what do you
think about this recent kind of bear
market that we've seen in the tiniest
sense of the last week or so how bitcoin
has drawn down obviously we're big
believers in the future but what do you
think about what's happened recently
with the price
yeah it's kind of a bummer right we're
in these choppy sideways waters i think
actually it's a really good buying
opportunity because i don't know about
you guys but when it when it hit like 68
i was like oh darn it come back down so
i could buy a little bit more you know
so i think this is a great buying
opportunity it's a black friday sale for
everyone out there um but you know i'm
not too worried i'm very very bullish in
the long run i know that people are
you know disappointed in the stock to
flow model not really panning out right
now or even the floor plan that he was
talking about the floor model that said
we should be at 98 000 in a couple of
days we're gonna get there we're gonna
get there i believe that um i get i
think this is a great time for your
friends who maybe were worried about the
price being over 60 000 to finally start
inching their way into the into the
asset um but yeah i just i think that
you know right now we need to get those
institutions in maybe we need to get
through the holidays but i'm very
bullish for for next year i think we're
gonna hit the six figures
agreed
i tend to agree as well all right
natalie where can we send people to uh
to follow you what uh what is your
twitter account i'm gonna drop it here
in the chat as well
at nat brunell because natalie bruno was
taken at nap brunel and then also please
follow my podcast coin stories you can
find it on the podcast platforms and on
youtube i'd love for you to check out my
youtube page
you're a pro she you see the uh the
wedge for hey what's my twitter account
bam here's my podcast here's that's like
a that's a pro move that joe and john
have learned over time too i appreciate
you very much coming on uh you're doing
fantastic work so keep it up uh tell the
haters shut up and uh and just keep
going it's we need as many people as
possible
thank you so much i love you guys
congratulations on your beautiful baby
god bless love you guys all right thank
you have a great day
bye you too all right john give us a
quick seven nuggets left
seven nuggets left
i'm absolutely smashing this challenge
to be completely honest i'm really
impressed i'm impressing myself i got
six left in this little in less than 11
minutes in less than 11 minutes you've
already eaten 43 nuggets
well i mean he's got my own backpack
he's he's breathing pretty heavy you
finished seven in in uh can you do it in
four minutes you'll have eaten 50
nuggets in 15 minutes and start calling
you the glizzy god
relax with that
all right real quick we got this hold up
we got we got things to do and then
danny boy hustle hard is coming on
alert alert alert danny boyhouse is
coming on a second first we got three
graphics of hundred dollar uh
uh i can't do anything people went to
the store they bought a hundred dollars
worth of gear we're gonna give them a
shout out right now if you go into the
store today you buy a hundred dollars
worth stuff you get a shout out rudy
from florida shout out to you steven
from florida shout out to you as well
florida boys that's what i'm talking
about then we got wilbur from south
carolina and nancy from south carolina
from north carolina north and south
carolina stacked up together john you're
at 11 minutes and 40 seconds oh wilbur
from south carolina nancy of north
carolina we got bryce from wisconsin we
are all over the country georgia new
york shout out to george david in
missouri joshua in new york jason in
pennsylvania charlene in maryland we're
going to go all 50 states we're going to
go 50 for 50 today and then we have
yo andy from new jersey we got
yola
haldi yaldi from new york i screwed both
those names up i apologize tony from new
jersey maybe that's tony's an easier one
yeah jeff from pennsylvania
and john
carolina coming in with the 500 order
gonna get a personalized video uh oh go
back we appreciate all of you but we
gotta cut the john real quick
john's got two nuggets left and it's
only 12 minutes and 23 seconds
what a legend a legend what a legend
this is probably one of the most
impressive things real quick so people
know that we're not cheating
real quick go ahead john i've been using
sauce too
and you asked the question
one
can you do another third in under 13
minutes
there he is ladies and gentlemen
15 nuggets in 13 minutes
absolute legend hey to be honest i'm
very i feel awful
i'm very impressed that was very good 12
minutes 58 seconds 48 milliseconds john
the goat
nuggets the goat all right now
we've got
somebody else bought a thousand dollars
in the store i'm gonna drop in the chat
if you want to get on the show go to the
merchandise store and go buy a thousand
dollars worth of merch and you can come
on the show now we have what is this
gentleman or woman's name
oh bitcoin ben we have going to bed i
don't know who bitcoin bet is but we're
about to find out bitcoin ben what's up
hey what's up brother not much how are
you
hey living the dream brother that's what
we're living in this crypto dream that's
what i'd like to hear are you in st
louis
yes sir saint louis mo
all right now are you uh uh uh upset
that the saint louis rams moved
no god no [ __ ] them
all right what what do you do bitcoin
crypto what what uh what do you spend
all your time doing
uh i am a
crypto
currency uh i guess influencer i've
actually been around
since like 2016
and uh i host a show
on youtube roku amazon
all over really
what what do you do on amazon and roku
my brother here made 10 10x on roku he
thinks he's a genius what do you do on
roku and amazon ten baggers uh i have a
show about
cryptocurrencies i actually talk about
like you know like bitcoin ethereum
uh
that's it we don't need to hear about
the rest yeah just
oh yeah
what's that what's that logo behind you
what's the logo behind you
it's me
that was legendary what just happened
that was awesome i didn't see the face
at all i just thought it was the truck
that was awesome
that was smooth as hell
all
uh bitcoin ban where can we send people
to follow you on the internet
uh youtube i have a channel on youtube i
had a larger one but uh
youtube
you know no longer said i needed it
yeah we
youtube's a full censorship we got it we
they kicked us off earlier too
oh i know
anybody who is effective they get rid of
yeah and i'm also on twitter check me
out
uh
bitcoin bin
and uh
like i said i'm
i'm all
crypto and
i also own
a
cryptocurrency company
where i sell laptops
specifically made
for
cryptocurrencies
all right listen i appreciate you what
what are you gonna give all the gear to
you're gonna give it out for us
christmas gifts or what are you gonna do
with it
uh i actually do events all over the
country and i got swag and i give it out
i'll actually hand out all of the
sweaters and t-shirts and stuff you're
smart you're smart you're a businessman
i could tell i like that oh absolutely
but
if you ain't making money in kryptos
you're done [ __ ]
this is the most dangerous show that
we'll let people call it
i'm telling you man i mean kryptos
literally if you ain't stupid
you can make money i
i literally was
a truck driver
i educated myself on cryptos and
economics
and now i host a show
explaining economics cryptos
interest rates you know entrepreneurial
ship
and
i launched a laptop only
calyx solutions
dot io
we sell crypto only laptops we train
people how you use them
what exchanges are good we help like the
newer people
and
we literally
have sold 1.5 million dollars
in about eight months wow you're a
legend
legend it's
it's crypto baby we're so early yeah
like i said i mean
look
look at jack
jack looks like he's 12 years old
that [ __ ] is making more money
than trump
and i mean he looks like a kid he's a
kid in a closet
and he's making more money than trump
here here's ready hold on hold on
i got one other question for you is most
people who drive trucks they tend to be
older right from a demographic
standpoint how many of those people know
about bitcoin understand bitcoin are
interested in bitcoin like your own
colleagues a lot of them right i
i have
people who watch my show lots of truck
drivers
and
and i mean they are buying the dips
these people know man and and and we are
not
talking people that don't know the
technology they know the technology too
and this is people my age i'm
47 or 46 what a hell i don't even know
21. you're good
you're dating might i do you should see
me nude i'm a bad [ __ ]
[Laughter]
all right listen bitcoin been on twitter
and on youtube we appreciate you thank
you so much for uh we're going in the
store like
all right my friend we gotta go we got
other people we got to bring on here but
i appreciate you having fun for
thanksgiving and uh we'll talk soon
later
bro he said jack looks like he's 12 in
the closet making more money than trump
that was all time
i'm so scared to bring guests on uh all
right real quick before we bring on uh
we bring on danny boy hustle hard we got
a couple more things we gotta go through
here one we got some pictures uh
danny's telling me he's got to leave at
145. all right dave we're coming to you
in a second hold on pj cam said coming
in on my jet
[Laughter]
jordy uh has three pictures of fans
watching live where the here we go here
we go you got pictures of fans watching
the best business show on the big screen
today we made it to the big screen boys
i appreciate you who's this crypto wins
appreciate you it was next one marat
zeed
uh orange pillin my bunny every bunny
every dog every cousin every aunt uncle
brother sister mother wife's boyfriend
everyone's got to be orange pill
appreciate you there and then we got
here mr fahrenheit love like juliet
watching with two other folks watch it
on the phone watch it on the uh the
horizontal phone people love the phone
big time move right there all right we
appreciate you all watching hope you
guys are enjoying this we're having fun
doing this i hope you guys are as well
john are you good i'm great i just need
to lay back for a second are you about
to fall asleep on this no you ain't
gonna have a little i got a lot tired
though after all right do we have danny
is danny here no
not yet no not yet
all right all right so can you can you
intro danny for the people that don't
know okay so real quick hold on let me
play they don't know who's coming on
let them know let me let me let me uh
this is important cause danny danny is
serious all right
danny boy hustle hard is absolute legend
for anyone who doesn't know if you go on
instagram and you follow at danny boy
hustle heart i think it's his name joe
will check to make sure that's his real
instagram handle this guy's a legend
he started out he literally was driving
folks from the airport he was an airport
like shuttle driver
and then he met one professional athlete
then another another and then another
also david boyle hustle hard is the man
if you get to new york city and you need
a ride you call danny he was introduced
to joe and i because he happens to drive
a lot of the new york giants players
around and they told us they said if you
need to go anywhere in the tri-state
area in 15 minutes danny boy can do it i
said well listen i'm not a genius but uh
it takes a little bit longer
than 15 minutes to get anywhere in the
tri-state area so don't worry if danny's
driving you'll get there i've seen this
man drive on shoulders i've seen him run
red lights i've seen him park sideways
in parking spots i've seen him go up
one-way streets down one-way street he
got us out of the city by going through
the the one-way bus terminal the one
that is only it's fine he's he ain't
going to get in trouble and go review
the cameras from months ago no we're
good if you need a good follow follow
him on instagram danny are you there
i'm here baby what's up
[Music]
all right real quick when somebody asked
you what do you do for a living what do
you say
i work at the library
starting off hot all right the first
thing i want to talk to you about is
gasoline prices you drive a ton of
people a ton of places what's going on
with the gasoline prices
they wanted that other guy in there man
paying seven dollars a gallon for gas
every time it's 120 130 to fill my truck
up man and and when the prices go up
it's been pretty quick or this has been
happening for a while
i mean
they [ __ ] trickle up like one day
it's six dollars a gallon the next day
it's 620 a gallon the next day it's 630
a gallon
yeah and yeah and i'm not the type to
look at gas prices i just look at the
final price i go into a [ __ ] gas
station i fill the thing up
and and next thing you know the thing
says 119 130
it's craziness bro it's crazy all right
second thing is food
the food prices seem to be exploding as
well and everything oh my god i used to
put my car down when i used to go out
with the guys like saquon odell
i just put like try to put my car down
back [ __ ] that i ain't put no car down
as that bill comes i'm going to the
bathroom bro
[Laughter]
[ __ ] out of here
who's that bill's coming
i'm going to pull that car up
[Laughter]
[ __ ] that bro all right i need i need
some uh i need some uh help here ready
tell me anything what's the craziest
thing you've seen a professional athlete
spend money on
the easiest thing i've seen
crazy spend money on the craziest
oh the craziest
uh
i was with pj tucker one time we walked
in the flight club
i mean i've seen some sick [ __ ] in my
work in my in my world
i seen this man put his car down to buy
two pairs of sneakers for seventy four
thousand dollars
what were the shoes
i don't even [ __ ] know i saw the
price i turned away bro
he spent 74 000 on [ __ ] sneakers i
gotta wait three days and get paid
[ __ ] 2 500
[Laughter]
that's my dog though that's my dog so it
don't matter you know what i'm saying
because you take care of me crazy
it's not just pj it's not just pj though
it's all the athletes you [ __ ] got to
get paid you got to wait bro all right
the richer they are the more you wait
talk to me about odell what's odell
doing
oh man that's my dog man odell
one of the most kindest human beings on
the face of this earth bro facts one of
the most kindest
most most
don't let that tv [ __ ] you up and those
those news report all that fake news and
[ __ ] bro he is the he will give you the
shirt off his back i can hit him up
right now and say i need 100k why it's
my account it will be wired to my
account in five minutes so explain
explain why what is the disconnect
between cause the media makes you think
that he's crazy that he's completely out
of control all this stuff and every
single person i know that knows him says
exactly what you're saying which he's
the kindest no shot it's because it's
because the media you can't believe
everything the media only shows you what
they want to show you they want to show
you throat him throwing a [ __ ]
garbage can across the sidelines when
he's mad you know he wants
they want to show you him cursing
another player he's really not he's a
very competitive guy he wants to win and
and that's not him in real life man bro
any time i went to go pay for something
yo yo i got it bro put your card up
anytime i needed something it happens
instantly group chat with the financial
advisor the money's in my account two
seconds anything i ever needed i asked
him or something i got it not not to
mention all the people he's put me on to
he's just one of the most most genuine
human beings on this planet it's it's
it's
i mean i don't know anyone like odell
you know what i'm saying who's the
smartest athlete that you know with
money
smartest athlete yeah like who's the
who's the best with their money
so there's a guy he's not he's not like
an odell beckham or or uh he's not an
odell beckham he's not a saquon barclay
his name is brandon copeland he plays
for the uh atlantic uh atlanta falcons
he used to be on the jets he's a huge
huge investor he's um he's got his money
in all kinds of crypto
um he does these um he does these uh
zoom calls like i mean uh
these things
yeah how to how do i say he does he does
these he teaches people how to save
money and and wealth and all that other
stuff
yeah he he's he's actually very very
intelligent we've i think we've done a
call with him right now we've done a
call with him and very very super
intelligent yeah yeah he's he's that's a
great answer danny what's going on with
bitcoin you own bitcoin
honestly uh i don't own a lot of bitcoin
um
i i threw i threw i mean i'm not i don't
got you know my the guys i drive i don't
have that kind of money but i threw some
money in bitcoin after i i drove you
guys when it was down down um
a significant number of what it is now
um i threw some money in there just to
um just to play with it because i'm i'm
a gambler i'm a heavy gambler you know
what i'm saying so i didn't i don't mind
throwing my money in something like that
to see what see what's going to happen
um
i threw a good amount of money in there
and and i'm just letting it sit and
every time it drops it dips i go and buy
more because i'm just a i'm a [ __ ]
lunatic like that
how many times have you thought about
selling don't lie
i thought it well yeah well i thought
about selling of course like you know
when the money gets short or my money
never really gets short but like you
know i go to like me me me and uh
me and saquon you know i'm saying we go
places i lose a few dollars you know
like we'll go to a restaurant in a
casino just to go eat and i'm in the
[ __ ] back playing on blackjack i lose
my shirt i go home like bro when i get
home that bitcoin is getting [ __ ]
sold bro
to get on that coinbase i'm [ __ ]
selling that thing
but you never do right never do nah i
never do the reason why i don't is it's
just
i feel personally and you know
i i usually my gut is always right i
feel like bitcoin by the end of the year
you guys set a hundred grand i say it's
going to be between 100
and 150 somewhere in that ballpark by
the end of this year p right now it's
it's declines a little bit and then like
one day you wake up the [ __ ] thing
shoots right back up it's crazy john
what questions you got what's up danny
nice to meet you um boy so
what else what else y'all you got money
in stocks what's going on how do you
manage your stuff you got an excel sheet
because i know nothing about [ __ ]
stocks
you're lucky i know about bitcoin all
right that's fair
yeah yeah nothing about stocks only
stocks i do is [ __ ] is is stock in my
[ __ ] pockets
[Laughter]
i got no time for what's [ __ ] going
up dow jones this [ __ ] ass back went
get the [ __ ] out
i got no time for that
only reason why bitcoins good easy for
me is because i always got my cash app
up and i can always see that [ __ ]
number right there bro
all right last thing i'm gonna i'm gonna
ask you and then i know you gotta go and
uh and get back to work is
when you think of all the years you've
been driving people you think all the
years of all the people you met
i need one story what's the craziest
thing you've ever done or seen someone
do it doesn't have to be with money but
what's the absolute most insane thing
that you could say on this show
say it one more time what's the question
one more time what's the craziest thing
you have seen anyone you've ever driven
do that you're allowed to say on the
show
anyone i ever seen anyone do
yeah what's the craziest thing someone's
ever done
the craziest thing someone's ever done
all right
bro
it's over now i don't give a [ __ ] it's
so it's over now i don't give a [ __ ]
i i drove i drove six nine one time when
he was signed to his other manager
and his manager i mean he's locked up
now so it really doesn't matter he's
locked up for this he played guilty but
his manager got out of my truck with a
[ __ ] gun and chased a guy down some
block in east new york i don't even know
where the [ __ ] i was bro i have no
[ __ ] clue where i was
he got out he chased the guy down with a
[ __ ] with it with a handgun got back
jumped back in my car
and i couldn't wait to drop these
[ __ ] off bro i didn't know and
and i wasn't really scared because i had
no license plate on the car a lot of
times i drive around with no license
please i don't i really don't give a
[ __ ] to be honest with you if i get
pulled over because it's a it's a 55
ticket like people a cop will pull me
over like yo why don't you got a license
plate on i'm like bro i don't give a
[ __ ] it's 55 unclear go right to [ __ ]
take it bro i got to go
[Laughter]
i got no license plate on the car the
car is registered the car is fully
insured
the car the car's legit just doesn't
have a plate on it please go back write
the ticket i got to get the [ __ ] out of
here bro simple
you're a legend dude
all the time um but on on that note the
other the other day i got pulled over i
got the tickets right inside i got
pulled over going through the lincoln
tunnel there was no joke i'm not making
this up there was nine
it had to be at least five miles of
traffic backed up i finally get to the
lincoln tunnel i went straight into a
[ __ ] do not enter no license plate on
the car got pulled over cop was being a
total dick don't give a [ __ ]
he says what'd you go through to do now
i said bro i went through the do not
enter because i'm not sitting in this
traffic i got people that got to be
somewhere they pay me a a significant
amount of money more money than you get
paid to stand there at that [ __ ]
lincoln tunnel all night so what you're
gonna do is you're gonna go back you're
gonna write me the ticket and i gotta
get the [ __ ] out of here and then have
the ticket book ready because you're
gonna see me every other [ __ ] night
there's traffic here i don't give a [ __ ]
bro right into the do not enter
what the cops say when you said that
don't give a [ __ ] no the cop didn't say
he handed me the tickets i said have a
good day but i'll see you tomorrow
see you tomorrow
all right man listen daddy boy so hard
if it's good enough for danny boy it
must be good enough for you if my guy
holds bitcoin yo yo yo let me just tell
everybody put your money right now don't
look at the number on bitcoin how much
it is whatever money you have put it
into it
whatever it is it's gonna it's gonna
skyrocket bro it's an easy
i listen i know a thousand i know a
million gamblers everybody i know is a
[ __ ] gamble if you're gonna put your
money on a blackjack table or on a
football team put it in the [ __ ]
bitcoin it's not going nowhere simple
not financial advice but you know that's
a good way to look at it is if you're
gonna gamble the money then maybe this
might be a little bit safer
it's great bro can't i can't wait see
what the numbers do everyone should go
follow danny boy hustle hard instagram
handle
danny boy hustle hard baby danny boy
that works
[ __ ] library yeah tell them about
that real quick before we let you go
talk about the lebanese seth rogen
let me i get seth rogen every day bro
every single day you see my fears out
more
the biggest [ __ ] arab seth rogen
you've ever seen in your life and i
think he's jewish is he jewish yeah he's
jewish
yeah jewish good i'm i'm an arab seth
roger bro
listen when i get pulled over this hat
comes off and those glasses stay on how
you doing officer sorry about that
you said
i play the drums the cops on my side i'm
playing the drums on my steering wheel
like the white people you know
no problem here
all right my brother i appreciate you
very much we'll love you guys
come on every week
oh man appreciate you guys see you guys
later bro all right thanks for coming on
all time absolute legend there's no
there's nobody in the world that could
compete with danny boy also hard right
he said when the gospel i played the
drums on my steering wheel like the
white people
the fact that he told a god of getting
poor reason be here tomorrow i'm gonna
do the same thing well listen i i don't
want to he he's he can tell whatever
stories he wants to tell i'm telling you
that he's probably gotten pulled over
150 times minimum might be low might be
low he's i mean he sent me a video one
time he's driving on this on the
shoulder uh and there's a bunch of
traffic and he literally while he was
doing it he was filming it and he had
his window down he was yelling at him
i'm waiting in this [ __ ] i'm not gonna
lie since following danny boy hustle
hard on instagram i have seen a lot of
videos while he's doing this type of
driving going through juneau enters he's
putting it on a story on instagram so
good guy to follow oh his instagram's
great he's uh i mean yeah somebody was
like that was like the opposite of will
clemente
no on chain metrics from danny that was
a 180 i mean
honestly
these are liter literally danny boy also
hard pj kev's coming late we got a whole
crew of friends that we could just bring
on on a uh on a consistent basis let's
not forget i ate 50 nuggets in 13
minutes you didn't do that all right
next up we got preston pitch preston you
there
hey i'm here
[Laughter]
how are you i'm doing great you know i'm
just here with my hoodie
and uh up here in chicago he's doing my
thing man
all right i got a lot of questions for
you the first thing i want to start with
is uh inflation 6.2 percent how off is
that number
um that's the number they're telling you
and that's the scary part
you know so i mean you want to talk
about an elephant in the room kind of
scenario
um here you are looking at 6.2 percent
the equity markets priced at 2 or 3
percent
the fixed income markets priced at 1.5
if you're looking at the 10-year
treasury so
you know for me i'm just looking around
the the marketplace and saying
how are how are people not talking about
this elephant in the room of a 300 400
basis point negative spread on pretty
much everything on the planet
right and i just don't see it going away
and i know i'm i'm way more
i'm a little different than danny boy as
far as how i'm looking at things
when you think when you think about
these metrics right
yeah
the 6.2 percent inflation let's just say
that we'll give them the benefit of the
doubt that's the real number it's
probably not i think you and i agree on
that but let's just say it is
yeah
the traditional assets
and traditional asset allocation
sixty seventy percent of it's dead in
the water at six at six percent
right like even if that was the real
number every bonds underwater pretty
much almost all commodities are either
break even or under underwater on a real
return basis and so you're basically
left with public equities that likely
are overvalued from multiple bases or
you can go look at something like
bitcoin but like other than that like
where the hell do you go real estate
where do you go
you said every single bond on the planet
is negative yielding and not by a little
bit but like a lot and that's what the
number they're telling you
so now let's let's
pull up the lynn alden sailor you know
i've been throwing out the m2 argument
really kind of being like the real
metric
of how much debasement's happening and
you're in double digits so the number
might be twice as as bad as what what
they're telling you
so and you mentioned commodities so like
when i'm thinking of like a commodity
business like their margins suck they're
after tax margins you know three percent
i don't i
it depends on which you know commodity
you're talking about most of these
commodities after tax their margins are
like three maybe five percent at best so
like how in the world are all these
companies which make up
the business around the world
gonna possibly survive in these
circumstances which kind of leads to
like the bigger point is the supply
chain issues that we're seeing right now
a function of the influx of fiat that
was added or are we actually seeing all
price signals like meltdown in real time
and does it maybe even accelerate from
here i i don't know the answer to that
but i i definitely wouldn't uh write it
off as being
um not what's happening
when you start to look at this right so
let's say that you're one of these bond
investors um or maybe let's take pension
funds pension funds are actually the
better example i think it was uh calpers
uh recently said that they're going to
go ahead and they're going to start
taking on some uh leverage in their
portfolio they're going to start uh
adding a larger allocation to
alternative assets i see you grinning
right now which uh which means you know
exactly where i'm going with this uh
i mean is this insane stuff to literally
have a pension fund that's got a
responsibility to millions of pensioners
to say they're going to take on leverage
everybody who's not who doesn't own
bitcoin
basically has a gun to their head and
they're being told go further out on the
risk curve
it's it's that simple like you you don't
even need to
uh say anything more than that that's it
and i know people want to hear more
analysis but i mean the analysis is this
if they keep
debasing and manipulating the fixed
income market
which they've been doing for decades
um what they're effectively doing is
just going to every single person and
saying hey you like stocks well now we
really want you to go out on the curve
you want bonds well get in get into the
high yield stuff because that's the only
thing that can
even remotely
look like it's going to outpace your cpi
numbers now and it's not it's it's all
negative the whole thing's negative
so you know people people might look at
the sell-off and bitcoin right now it
you know here we are the day after we're
black friday you get your dis you got
your you got your fire sale uh prices
happening on black friday here
i think it's down i don't know what 20
percent 25 or something right now and
we're
we're uh 54 000 or whatever it is and
people might look at that and say wow
that thing's really scary looking
because it's so volatile
and i just look at it as being
pretty much the only market left in the
world that is not being manipulated
right like nobody's coming to save this
thing could drop to 30 000. nobody's
going to come and save you and that's
why i'm in it
it's because of that
um and i think that what that's going to
do over time is it's going to garner
more trust it's going to be hard for
people to bear the volatility as they
don't maybe fully understand the
fundamentals but for those who do
i mean i'm just looking at this and
saying well you got tons of impairment
over in china it looks like it's
starting to spill into the rest of the
of the markets around the world and
that's probably what's you know causing
the sell-off when you're looking at
bitcoin in fiat terms you're looking at
you know a lot of impairment in the
credit markets
and so what's it gonna take to get these
guys to either wake up or start to buy
bitcoin is it just a time thing like
literally they have to get more familiar
with it they have to get more of a track
record of it not disappearing uh or is
there other things that you think can
happen to really kind of accelerate it
it's time
um because
based on the situation we're in they
have to keep the base
right the market's going to keep
throwing fits in fiat terms uh because
there's so much credit that's been added
keep expanding the monetary baseline
each time it does throw a fit
and so we're going to have it throw
another fit when it happens it's very
hard to forecast i mean we could pull up
some charts that i sent over to your
guys there that's showing the euro
bond market and you can see that you're
starting to see the longer duration
bonds over in europe start to break the
the 40-year trend
which has never happened right so that's
starting to play out
um in the u.s it's still under the trend
uh so that's the equity one if you the
euro bond yields
i'll go to the next one right there so
this this chart right here is you know
that trend line you're seeing is is a 30
to 40 year trend line and fixed income
and you're starting to see
um long duration bond europe start to
break the trend already
um if you go to the us one which was the
one that preceded that chart
that's showing you that
you can see the 40-year trend line it's
starting to creep up as as there's
going higher that's a sell-off in the
first income market so it's selling off
like crazy the yield's going higher and
it's selling because your cpi is
printing over five percent just about a
six point two percent in this last uh
print and that's been happening for six
so if you're sitting in this stuff
you're just eating a negative 300 basis
point
yeah
and what these yields are i mean how
long can you continue to to sit there
and endure that pain
uh that that's the billion trillion
dollar question right now
when you're looking at the uh if we go
back to that first chart that we had up
with the uh the trend line down in the
uh interest rates does everything go
negative
like do we literally get just negative
everything across the globe in terms of
in nominal terms yeah so like that's the
next steps
in in real terms everything across
across even here in the us it's all
negative in real terms but the next step
is they're going to try to take them
negative and nominal terms
so now
like anybody who's buying this stuff
knows that if they hold it through the
uh the duration of the yield or for the
the coupon like if you're holding it to
the maturity date you're guaranteed to
lose right now based on these inflation
numbers once the once they start getting
printed negative and nominal terms
you're basically having people come in
and sign contracts that guarantee the
loss of buying power in nominal terms
it's like hey come over here sign this
contract i guarantee you i'll give you
back 95 dollars for every 100 you give
me i promise you
right it's already like that in real
terms but in nominal terms that's what
it's just like so demented you can't
even believe that we're living in in
fantasyland like it's crazy is the u.s
the last one to do it like it because
yeah it's so religious
yeah based on the charts that's that's
what it looks like yeah
and and so i guess what when i'm looking
at the the sell-off we're having in
bitcoin right now right and i'm saying
all right is this just uh you know some
speculators versus long-term holders
kind of sell-off like a short-term
little cycle that we're seeing whereas
maybe this bigger because uh if you go
back to the chart the equity chart there
which was the first one you guys pulled
up there the global equity index
when you look at this one okay these are
all the big major stock markets around
the world the one in the purple down
there that's china and you can see in
the big dip there you had at the
beginning of 2020 that's your covet dump
that's your big giant impairment event
supply demand shock and you can see how
well china's done since kovit and it has
done really bad now the reason i tell
you it's done bad is because they
haven't been playing the basement game
like everybody else has been playing at
the basement game so if you're playing
you know going back to this monopoly
example that we sometimes talk about on
on shows like if everybody at the game
is cheating and everybody's sticking
their hand in the in the bankers
uh you know where the where the fiat
sitting and everybody's clawing some
into the game but you aren't
are you winning or are you losing
because playing by the rules or being
fiscally responsible right now isn't
probably the best strategy the best
strategy is print as much as you can and
start buying bitcoin with whatever you
print
when you look at something like this
it's very easy to see there's this macro
you know debasement going on interest
rates going down but then all of a
sudden somebody like el salvador shows
up with a bitcoin back bond how do you
look at that bitcoin back bond uh as an
attractiveness compared to all these
other bonds around the world and what
does that mean in terms of like do we
eventually see more and more people go
ahead and say wait maybe i'm not gonna
do 50
of the bond to go buy bitcoin but should
i do two percent three percent like is
that the yeah is that the pathway out
like what's your views there i look at
el salvador the same way i look at micro
strategy right like micro strategy over
the last year has murdered it so
badly right like they have just crushed
it
but how many other
uh companies are out there doing the
same strategy in the in a public kind of
way now you might have it on the private
side but in a public kind of way you're
not seeing it
and when i think of el salvador i think
of them in an exact same way
they're going to murder this like
absolutely murder this because the yield
alone that they're that they're doing is
is where cpi is at or at least the
published cpi right that doesn't even
talk about the bitcoin
special coupon kicker that's associated
with the bond right
um just like michael's debt that he was
issuing it was the best performing debt
issuance for the year
so el salvador's doing they're they're
basically pulling a michael saylor but
they're doing it from a nation-state
level by the time the rest of the nation
states start figuring it out we might be
another year or two or whatever from now
but they're going to figure it out and
it's going to become the textbook play
and once a couple of them start figuring
out i think this thing's going to move
out a whole lot faster than people could
ever imagine
how important is it that it's a nation
state versus a city or a state or
something like that like actually having
a country do it is that matter or if
miami or san francisco or austin texas
if you know kind of some city in the
united states did this it would have the
same impact
yeah i think so i think it's a little
bit more demonstrative uh for other
nation states to see so if you have some
cities doing it it's an interesting
story but when you have literally an
entire country who's who's wired into
this whole imf bis like
global model and they're saying you know
what screw that we don't need this model
like this is
this is what we're going to do and we
don't need you
let's demonstrate why we don't need you
right in front of everybody's faces
right and that's
that's exactly what they're doing
and when that occurs
do you think other nation states run to
go do this exact same thing in terms of
uh adopt bitcoin or i call it like
plugging into the bitcoin network or is
it what we've seen in the public market
so there's two or three others that have
followed uh that were non you know
bitcoin or crypto native but for the
most part most people haven't uh decided
to go ahead and do the exact same thing
i think once you get to a market cap of
maybe 10 trillion it's a little hard to
to ignore at that point
so yeah it was like once billion now i
think once bitcoin gets to a 10 trillion
market cap i think it's going to be a
little hard to like ignore it at that
point got it so one trillion was kind of
the first milestone then we got to get
to 10 trillion once we get there that's
gold parity basically then all
you know not now people got started
really paying attention
yeah i think once you get to a certain
point it's going to be so big that i
don't care what kind of argument you
come up with
you just you're going to look like an
idiot trying to argue against it at that
point all right i got another uh kind of
topic i want to talk about which i saw
you retweeted luke groman uh earlier
today
and in it he said it's not that stocks
can't go down it's that the u.s
government can't default u.s
policymakers have allowed the system to
evolve such that stocks going down too
far and staying down for too long almost
certainly caused the us to default on
their treasuries or entitlements
can you describe a little bit more about
like what happens here if the stock
market did go into a bear market for a
prolonged period of time like how would
that look like for the u.s for the
balance sheet for the debt etc
i think for the like the top 100 uh
companies in the country or even the top
500
you might not see
the the real economic impact what you're
going to see is is the fed step in or
over in europe they're going to step in
with the ecb they're going to
recapitalize everything all that
printing that would go in through the
bond market or even through ubi straight
into the hands of people it's going to
just
immediately turn back into spending
that's going to
uh suck all that all that printing
straight into the most highly
capitalized companies because they have
all the competitive advantage so on the
indexes i would expect them to continue
to melt up
um
they won't outpace bitcoin
um in that melt up but as far as the
real economic impact the smaller
companies and the ones that don't have
large margins or like a deep entrenched
uh
uh competitive advantage they're gonna
get wrecked
and so that's where you're you know your
smaller towns that are dealing with
smaller capitalized companies that don't
have deep margins like the economic
impact there is going to continue to
trend in a really kind of devastating
way
um and and very concerning and so you're
going to have this growing trend of this
divide between what's being published in
the indexes versus what's happening in
the real economy we've already seen it
playing out that just amplifies itself
here in the coming five years
and when you start to think about um
if you're an
institutional asset manager and you've
got
the environment we're talking about
do you go all in on bitcoin like if you
can't let's just say that you've got a
20 mandate you can't go all in on any
one asset class you can only allocate up
to 20 etc what do you do with the other
80 percent right so you you you're the
the most aggressive you go 20 bitcoin
other 80 you should go equities like
what would you do yeah i mean you
definitely don't want to be in you don't
want to be in fixed income because
that's going to be completely impaired
um so it really comes down to you have
to own something that's equity-based and
you have to own something that's
equity-based that's going to have an
enduring competitive advantage in a
depression-like kind of scenario that
continues to play out in real time
so um you know which kind of companies
kind of fit that bill i would i would
really focus on the companies that are
essential things that you have to
continue to own through people are
always going to need food people are
going to need certain types of things
you know i i don't see people getting
rid of of their phones and things like
that so
like
um that's how i would think through the
framework for me
uh yeah i mean i pretty much own bitcoin
it's the only thing i trust because
here's here's the here's the critical
thing everything today equity based is
based on a pe
of really low interest rates
continue to transition to this new
system right that interest rate
environment is going to change because
it's going to become free and open again
opposed to completely manipulated and
yields being negative
so as that happens all equity is going
to reprice itself and capitalize itself
at a lower uh multiple than what it is
now
but
when that takes place or when the market
starts realizing that
is the big if
so that's why i have a very hard time
owning equities is because i don't want
to own something that's a pe of 35 or 45
when my expectation is is it's going to
start trending in a direction of a p e
of 10
because if that happens well now you've
lost 80 percent of the the market cap
through that transition right
one of the things that i keep going back
to
is obviously more and more people are
pushing out further on the risk curve
which would bring you towards venture
capital and kind of these private market
opportunities but the illiquidity is not
changing right and actually
if you go back to 99 2000 where was
there more pain was there more pain in
the public markets or is there more pain
in the private markets you can make an
argument for either one
yeah
yeah i mean it's it's really hard
because i think most market participants
cannot get past the cognitive bias
of
there's always going to be government
issued fiat currency
they can't get past that that mental
leap
and that you know that critical thinking
that's required to get beyond is that
even possible and so they're just well
if central banks are going to take
yields nominally negative
then i guess i need to keep owning
stocks because it's going to continue to
melt up but what they're not looking at
is their loss and buying power relative
to a potentially new
uh form of money and that's how i
personally look at the the equation
and when i look at it and and you look
at the volatility i think that's all
part of it if you think if you think
bitcoin can go to 100 trillion and
you're at 1 trillion right now well it's
kind of normal to have 30 volatility you
should expect that based on what it's
trying to
uh with what it's trying to mature into
and so when you go ahead and you look
out and you think to yourself
michael saylor has got this argument
that he's made multiple times where
bitcoin will serve as
a global store of uh value and then
you'll have the dollar continue and
actually get stronger and stronger
against other weak fiat currencies
let's look out five or ten years is that
the view of the world that you have or
do you see it some other way kind of in
the short term uh in terms of how the
dollar and bitcoin are related to each
other
i i completely agree with michael
i guess we're um where i'm a little bit
different in a public kind of way and i
have no idea what michael's private
opinion on this is i know what his
public opinion is
and and i think he publicly talks about
that transition slowly playing out
over a very long period of time
for me i'm looking at history and
history typically suggests that that
that happens but then it aggressively
transitions to the new form of of money
and so
i don't know where that point is i kind
of suspect it's
i think a lot of people would disagree
with this i think it's kind of on like
the next five year time frame
um just because i think that what comes
next in the fixed income space is going
to be so grossly obvious
and stupid
that it's going to be almost near
impossible to ignore
and i think that's the thing that i'm
uh why i'm so bullish on bitcoin is
because of
how mutilated
uh the fixed income space is and i think
that's going to be the thing that erodes
all trust in the old system
not that bitcoin's gonna
uh you know the stock to flow is gonna
make everybody just get to this point
that they think that that's the better
form of money i think it's gonna be more
fear of the old system that drives
people to
heavily adopt bitcoin in a
in a uh kind of face ripping event
got it and then when you think about uh
over the very long term is your thought
process that bitcoin you know gets kind
of monetized as a store of value and
eventually becomes that medium of
exchange and rises to become uh kind of
a
global reserve currency on the internet
or kind of however you want to talk
about it yes that's exactly what i think
will happen and so people that are
saying like nobody will ever spend it
well you will spend it when the buying
power doesn't go up by 200 percent a
year and like the buying power is pretty
flat which is
what will happen if you have you know
100 trillion plus of valuation on it is
like you'll get to a point where
nobody's going to accept the old
currencies and they're they're demanding
that everything is settled in bitcoin
and at that point like you're going to
want to start owning equities
because all of those equities
balance sheets and their income
statement is completely in bitcoin
because you're gonna have to own
something that just is pumping out free
cash flows at that point
yeah
talk to me about uh the podcast network
you guys have built as well because i
think one of the things people forget
about uh is that you've got um
obviously your own personal beliefs in
terms of uh macro environment and
investing but you've been
studying billionaires literally it's in
the name of the first podcast and then
you guys have built out an entire
network of other podcasts that talk
about finance interview people around
investing strategies et cetera like how
does that help you uh in your journey of
learning and then ultimately expressing
that view in a financial portfolio
i mean at the end of the day we're just
trying to keep
um
um now i the the thing that i kind of
learned through the years by studying
all these various billionaires and just
people in finance is i mean it's just
one giant math equation for the most
part where you're just trying to find
what can i own
that is going to um
give me as buying power relative to
everything else that's on the market
and um you know buffett's the guy that i
first started studying um and i mean
i learned just how he how he thought
about equities versus fixed income and
which one you want to own at certain
points in time based on how their value
how the yield is is uh being forecast
versus the price that you pay in the
market
um
when i think of like our business as far
as like the network we want to try to
cater to um as many people as possible
but also
um put out content that we think is most
beneficial to the listener and so is
some of our bias
entered into like what kind of media
we're creating absolutely
um do we think bitcoin's probably the
most important thing in the next five
years absolutely that's why we're
covering it the way we are
does this mean that
everybody that listens to the show is
going to be open to that of course not
and so we're still trying to cater to
all the listeners and but while also
kind of highlighting what we think is
value to the marketplace and hopefully
we do a good job at that but that's
something that we take very serious and
in kind of an ethical kind of way like
if if it's not something that i think is
going to add value to the listener i'm
i'm sorry i'm just not gonna i'm not
gonna give it any air time i think
that's uh a good way to view the world i
i learned that over time as well as hey
sorry we're just not gonna publish that
one uh joe john what questions you guys
got for preston hey preston how you
doing thank you for joining us hey
what's up joe happy thanksgiving uh to
you and your family
uh thank you so my question would be
around jerome powell he obviously got
reappointed to be the fed chairman again
do you think that matters a lot does it
matter very little just what are your
thoughts around kind of his
reappointment
i think and i have pretty much nothing
the basis on but i just get the
impression that him and janet yellen
kind of have a decent working
relationship and when you look at what
has to come next which is complete
coordination between the central bank
and the treasury um maybe that's why he
got you know renominated is because uh
janet didn't see him as a threat and
they kind of see the the direction and
the coordination that's going to be
required moving forward let me just uh
emphasize when the when the central bank
and the treasury start coordinating hand
in hand it's usually a very concerning
time in any nation's history
gotcha
john what questions you got hey preston
nice to see you again hey hey hey
you don't know this but john ate uh 50
nuggets earlier sounds a little tired
said he had a little food eating contest
i'm fine i'm fine
so
you gotta put on a face put on face so
my question would be around inflation
like the number is 6.2 percent that
they're telling us what do you think the
number is do you think it's going to
continue next year what are your
thoughts around how that will affect
kind of all the equity markets and
bitcoin in general
so i think the number is more between
like 10 to 15 based on the compound
annual growth rate of the m2
um my bigger concern is it appears that
it's accelerating so it's not a linear
uh anytime you do a compounding growth
rate you're you're kind of interpolating
a percent that's over something that's
not linear
and so
uh my bigger concern is the the higher
portion of that number that makes up
that 10 to 15 percent has happened in
the last couple years
and if that trend continues in a
non-linear way that means that the
number in the coming you know three
years five years should be higher than
the number that we're quoting over the
last 10 when you're when you're doing
the calculation so i think that's very
concerning it's going to be interesting
to see uh what the next big giant qe
event is going to look like and how much
they're going to add i would argue that
the number is going to be way higher
than what we saw in covid
and that should surprise a lot of people
considering
that supply demand shock that we had
with kovid is viewed
obviously mark the participants of being
an on-off type event
and something that will never happen
again but i i completely disagree with
that and i think that the next big uh
fit that the market's going to throw is
going to produce a printing in the
basement that's going to make covid look
like a joke probably
three to four times maybe higher as far
as what they're going to have to do to
insert into the market and then that's
going to probably be a point where the
market's saying all right
what in the world is happening here
um
and if i was going to say one more thing
on on that topic so when you think about
the debasement
you got to ask yourself like
if there's a hundred units in the system
and you expand it by double and now
you're making it 200 units in the system
when you when you add that additional
100 units into the system you have to
choose where it's going
right for the last decade they've chosen
to add those units via the fixed income
market into the bond market by bidding
the prices of bonds so the yields come
down and then those people who are
receiving that cash for those bonds that
they used to hold are now deciding where
they're going to take that cash and put
it into the rest of the market so if
you're watching the price of corn
right or you're watching the price of
wheat
and these people who are receiving these
these hundred additional units
through the fixed income market are
deciding to
take them and then buy stocks or buy
equity with those newly added units into
the system well you're probably not
going to see it show up in the price of
wheat or corn
and i think that's where um
market participants have been saying
well we don't have any inflation we
don't have any inflation but like it's
not real well it is real and it's
nesting itself into the area that uh the
people who are receiving the benefit of
that printing decide where they want it
to go next and they've decided that they
wanted to go into equities because
there's only so many yachts you can buy
until you say hey i'd like to have more
equity which is going to generate more
free cash flows and more returns for me
so i'm going to own equities right and
that's what's been happening over the
last decade plus
and uh you know so people that like to
throw around this term inflation
um
i don't think they really understand
what the real definition of it is and i
would i would define it as anything that
expands the monetary baseline units in
the system and then whatever credits
constructed on top of it
well said preston before i let you go uh
you don't know that this has happened
because you've been on this live stream
but uh president buchelli of el salvador
tweeted 15 minutes ago and said el
salvador just bought the dip 100 extra
coins acquired with the discount hashtag
bitcoin
uh the fact that we have a nation state
buying the dip
i mean
this is insane uh it's awesome but it's
also insane what do you think about this
i love it uh
i love his vibe by the way like i i
jokingly tweeted at him a couple days
ago
that sweden wanted him to turn off his
volcano
and he then retweeted me and said uh
that the volcano is going to turn itself
off here in in the next million years so
we don't have to worry about that
his whole vibe is just hilarious right
like who would have thought you'd have a
president of a nation like
taking the joke and retweeting it i
think he's really kind of thumbing his
nose at the entire
at the entire world as like how are how
is everybody so dense that they can't
see this that's what i i think
indirectly that's what he's saying with
all these posts he's saying how in the
hell
can you guys not see this
yeah it also seems uh i think to your
point of like it's not just the action
it's the way he's doing it and he's
doing it in the face of the imf and all
these other people yeah i forget who i
saw uh tweeted um maybe yesterday before
like the imf it has like you know it's
like a made-up organization right made
up like in terms of they basically got
put in place as um having some authority
or power but that's because a bunch of
people all agreed to it at any point if
people all just say okay now they don't
you know what would be the ramifications
of that and so it seems like there's
nobody who can stop them you know go
short of maybe like an actual like
physical uh kind of violent war uh he's
the leader of a sovereign nation and
he's gonna do what he thinks is best for
his citizens and barring some sort of
external intervention
and then keep doing it right
i think that i think the concern isn't
him
i think the concern is probably the
hundred other nation states that are
looking at what he's doing that have a
similar setup as far as how they can
benefit from this they've got the
natural resources right they don't need
the imf if they go and do a block stream
uh bond note or
um like everything here they've got the
uh the remittance type uh win on their
hands if they would implement this
um
i'm just looking at this and saying
who's next and how many of them are
coming
who do you think is next what five
nation states doing this like
i i don't know i would i would argue the
people that are gonna be next are the
ones that have the biggest win on their
hands by doing something similar so i
would think it'd be another nation state
that looks and and is similar in in the
way that it's set up like el salvador
with some of those key things that i was
just talking about
got it
the ones that are gonna be the last to
figure it out are the ones that that
benefit the least from the transition
yeah which means the u.s is probably
last to uh to do it and it depends on
the leadership right so you have leaders
that can figure this out and understand
it and then
very similar like michael saylor like
why did michael saylor do what he did
a you have to understand it
which
in my opinion is a pretty big hurdle
because you have to understand the macro
backdrop and then you have to understand
like why bitcoin isn't going to fail
which is a lot of research studying
understand you have to be a person with
like deep critical thinking you got to
enjoy the critical thinking
um so you have to a do that
and then b you have to have control
in a manner that that
if you have one vote and you need 20
votes to implement something like this
well you can know everything you
know in existence but you still got to
convince the other 19 people to do it
and so i think that's the challenge so
like microstrategy uh michael had a
majority voting rights because he had uh
you know the way that his voting rights
were restructured structured inside of
his country um i suspect that down in el
salvador the current president has a lot
more influence in order to sway the vote
than maybe some other nation states
and so those nation states that maybe
have more decentralized voting might
have a more difficult time getting
something like this pushed through to
take such an aggressive change of
direction because remember all these
people that are elected the thing they
want is enough stability
with just enough happiness with their
district so that they get reelected
so if you go and do something that's
dramatic
you're you're potentially jeopardizing
your reelection efforts because you
created too much volatility in how how
the change would be perceived
so it's kind of like this this this
scenario but i would say i would break
it down into the two like core things
like you have to understand it and you
have to have enough voting rights or
voting sway in order to kind of get it
through yeah
it's um the geopolitical aspect of this
is nuts like i don't think that's the
right answer but uh it really does feel
like um
everyone is undervaluing what he's doing
uh from an impact standpoint and in
hindsight everyone would be like how did
we not assign more importance to that
but completely agree maybe you and i are
wrong and we're morons like possible
very high probability there too yeah
exactly all right where uh where can we
send people to find you on the internet
i appreciate you taking the time from a
thanksgiving to uh to come on here
yeah no i appreciate the invite uh i'm
on twitter at preston there it is right
there uh i also have a podcast uh you
can see the link there on my twitter
it's the investorspodcast.com
i do the we study billionaire show every
wednesday where i'm talking about
bitcoin and yeah just appreciate the
invite and nice to meet you john and joe
i we haven't talked before so i'm pretty
excited to say hi to you guys
we're uh we're pumped that you came on
thanks for doing it during thanksgiving
yeah i want to i want to swing into the
studio when i'm down there in april for
the miami event let's go open invite
we have uh open seat right over there so
he's got your name all over everybody in
april
maybe we'll give you some chick-fil-a
john i'll do a mcdonald's no more of
those
i love chick-fil-a
i want to give all my thoughts to john
awesome man thank you so much for coming
preston we appreciate it make sure every
if you guys don't already please go
follow preston on uh on twitter and then
definitely check out uh not only his
podcast but the entire podcast network
is uh very very good um i found myself
listening quite often so make sure you
go check that out as well but
when are you coming on the show that's
the question when when can i interview
you paul
when do you want to do it
let's do it soon i know it's hard to
claw you away because you create so much
content but we got to do it you tell me
when you want to do it and i'm in i'll
shoot you at the end
all right buddy sounds good thank you
see you preston thanks for all right see
you guys later
all right we got three things
first of all
he gets it oh gee that's that's a great
way to put it he just gets it like
bonds
they all
they're gonna have to do it they got no
choice he should on a fixed income joe
was a little upset
he used to be a fixed income guy
not buying it myself working in it
working oh so you're selling things you
didn't believe in
yeah
that's what wall street does
i said yep they made me then i was like
i'm out of here
second thing
is that pj kev is in the building he'll
be on here on the show in a second we
got to do two uh two other things first
more hundred dollar winners now before
we show who the uh that winners the uh
shout outs before we show let me remind
everyone in the merch store today there
is 21 off everything in the merch store
if you want to go get the ugly sweat
shirts
ugly christmas sweaters whatever a
little freedom one right here few hats
william wallace few hats everything got
the 100k hat everything is in the store
john's got the shirts the whole nine
yards bestbusiness show.com 21 off if
you go in the store if you buy 100 worth
of gear we will go ahead and we will
give you a shout out on the show by 500
500
worth of gear in the merchandise store
we will go ahead and we will make a
personalized video for you and if you
buy over a thousand dollars you get to
come live on the show so i think we have
brian who's going to be joining us here
uh
in a second
wait there's two winners
oh there oh let me do the 100 winners
first hundred dollar purchasers go ahead
uh let's pull up the first one we got
taylor d from florida
richard from canada cole p from texas
scott s from new york augustine from
california and we are all we have
massive massive geographic coverage in
here antonio from california philip g
from tennessee connie s from florida
dustin c from idaho not ohio not iowa
idaho dustin from idaho and kim a from
california every single one of you
went into the store about 100 worth of
merch hopefully for a great christmas
gift for somebody you love somebody you
care about whether it's your brother
your cousin your nephew philip g from
tennessee i like that were you a rapper
over there that i'm just reading the
name off the paper
well technically it's a scream but yeah
philip g from tennessee thank you
antonio from wherever he was from
california california thank you oh you
gotta get out of there
[Laughter]
all right now we got a thousand dollar
purchaser brian are you there oh hold on
hold on
recording in progress
i messed up
all right brian
wait one second i messed up i screwed up
john how's your stomach feel by the way
um my stomach feels fine
heart's kind of taking a pounding right
now from all the nuggets but uh i'm good
surprisingly i'm pretty impressed with
myself so i'm happy
you can be impressed too you can say it
you can say
i was very impressed that you knocked
down 50 of those in 13 minutes
all right here we go brian you there
what's happening pomp bros how you guys
doing out there we're doing great how
are you
i'm doing absolutely fabulous but just
give me a second real quick give me a
second
legend
what a legend
where where are you based
i'm based at valhalla new york western
counties right outside of new york city
yeah i know exactly where it is
uh all right what's go what's going on
there with bitcoin anything
well man listen uh bitcoin
i got into bitcoin not that long ago and
uh um in the beginning you know it's
like everybody else it's a little little
dca effect going in and then one day i
was talking to a buddy of mine he's like
brian you spend so much time researching
bitcoin talking about bitcoin why don't
you do something big so i went ahead and
i created a financial entity a
self-directed 401k and i took my entire
bag and i put into the crypto market
so your entire 401k is invested in uh
bitcoin or cryptocurrencies that's right
and actually this is uh this is a
strategy that i took from when i used to
be in real estate investing i used to
have some properties out in michigan
and i had a bunch of single family homes
it was a great investment cash out of
that
401 k just sitting there we all know the
story about 401ks and when you're in the
real estate investment world you could
or any world for that matter you could
actually leverage loans against your
assets
and um i said well why can't i do this
with bitcoin and then you know the
curiosity started setting in i did some
research and i found the right people
and i created the entity so now uh now
i'm all in man so i'll tell you what
this black friday is not feeling too
good right now but i believe in it what
el salvador is doing
i'm colombian so we got to represent
this is our opportunity
all right
this is our opportunity for latin
america and all the minorities to
actually level up and be able to do
something with their financial freedom
financial lives
i tend to think that you uh you're more
right than wrong what's uh what's
shocking to me we're talking about with
uh with preston is that so many people
aren't uh paying attention they're not
they just don't assign the same value uh
of importance to this as maybe i do my
brothers or maybe you do as well so it's
pretty crazy when you look at uh kind of
you know how people are reacting to this
i agree with you and uh you know when
you have i mean what's the stat was it
three or 13 percent of the world's
population that has bitcoin right now
uh yeah it's probably oh it's probably
lower than 13 yeah i don't know exactly
what the number is it's definitely much
lower because if everybody was at
thanksgiving yesterday you could tell
that over half of the room didn't even
know what bitcoin was which is shocking
to me but when you're sitting on these
type of mediums i work from home i run
my business out of my bedroom in my in
my home and uh i watch you guys every
single day and a couple of other
youtubers that are really influential so
you have that that ability to be exposed
this type of cryptocurrency this type of
world uh when a lot of people just don't
understand it but that's okay
because you know that's why we're
rocking these bitcoin 100 000 caps i was
at costco before doing some black friday
shopping the guy at the door i walk in
and he's like dude bitcoin nice cat you
know it's like people are starting to
understand it but this time next year
it's going to grow it's going to be
exponential and then before you know it
we're going to be at a million dollars
and uh we're going to be sitting all
pretty what's going on at costco for uh
uh for black friday is their mad house
are they like trampling over each other
for tvs and stuff not really man no no
costco was pretty empty this morning i
uh i got there walked right in the
longest line was to get to the pharmacy
where i had to go pick up my dog's
prescription i mean this thing is the
most expensive thing in the world owning
a dog sucks if you guys don't have any
money don't get a dog that's it joe just
got a dog ryan i just got a dog man
chill chill chill yeah but i said if you
guys don't got any money joe's over
there freaking wiping his tears 100
bills
actually by the way shout out to anthony
scaramucci his book is in the mail and
is coming over to my house i got his uh
his ae
uh actually reached out to me so she
sent me the book for free so that's a
nice nice
yeah anthony by the way you don't know
this brian but uh anthony uh texts me at
one point he goes hey man what's up with
that audience i was like what do you
mean he was like i said you know offhand
comment free books and there was like
three thousand people that emailed him
you got to take advantage bro listen
you're giving away 21 off in the uh on
the merch store and i went ahead and
bought like 5 000 christmas ornaments i
don't know what i'm going to do with
them but it was just i'm going to give
those bad boys out in the street just
toss them out all over white plains new
york i see you out there yeah white
plains new york's going to be blanketed
i appreciate you very much where can we
send people to find you on the internet
or or something
you know i know i know this is the best
business show and the most dangerous
best business show and i appreciate
everything you guys are doing i know we
just don't talk about bitcoin but i
would love you to send people out to my
linkedin brianlatory.com that's my
linkedin hit me up on twitter at
teclatory i'm not just about a bitcoin
thing i'll tell you i'm a bitcoin novice
in the grand scheme of things but i do
work in the world of technology if you
have a business out there and you want
to automate any of your business
processes your front end your backend hr
your financial process i got bots that
can do it all for you for the price of
an fte so hit me up on linkedin for sure
awesome man well listen thank you so
much for coming on here anyone who's
looking for you go find them on linkedin
or on twitter we appreciate you right on
boys and take it easy one last question
for you yeah out of curiosity
i go vacation in the carolinas every
single year i always see pom boy motors
is that you guys yeah of course yeah
it's definitely yeah this whole time i
didn't even know hey
good i'll see you guys man hey keep up
the good work guys i appreciate
everything you do thank you all right
see you later thanks brian
legend yeah so he's gonna be dropping
christmas ornaments around white plains
new york he's gonna go visit pops at the
dealership
i'm still trying to get our dad to come
on all right ladies and gentlemen
our time together
is not over
i have one more guest here
he
just walked into the studio
uh
i'm getting messages people are saying
that uh the show has been too wild today
yeah whatever maybe maybe not
uh pj kevin is here with us how are you
how you doing
i just came to redeem myself first
question first question
now you gotta redeem yourself first
question
meek
said i saw the tweet and when i saw i
didn't even message you because i was
like oh boy here we go
what was the conversation before meek
mill tweeted out i said that you were
gonna host madison square you held it
down thank you i appreciate it now to be
honest with you like
i was like listen meek
i'm from new york yes right so
i need to come out some way and like on
msg that's just like [ __ ] crazy to me
and i was like yo listen me if you let
me host this [ __ ] i'm gonna rock this
and he was like you sure
i'm like yeah he's like i was thinking
about letting you host it anyway
so
with that being said um
he had put a tweet out he was like yo
matter of fact i'm gonna let pj kev host
it i think he got the energy for you
guys and i was like yo am i really
hosting msg
and then i started getting emails from
live nation rock nation like hey we have
your dressing room upstairs when you get
here make it right i'm like oh [ __ ] i'm
ready
msg
20 000 people
i had fun that was fun it was cool
i i watched the uh some of the videos
that came out afterwards i thought you
were the main act
i was like you jumping on speakers you
had the place rocking yeah yeah i was
like that was the host that wasn't even
yeah yeah i had a good time so when uh
when you're going into it
are you like nervous about it or are you
just like man it's gonna be a blast no
i'm just like i'm a natural so like i'm
just going in there just being myself
and hoping the crowd rocks with me
playing the right music but i did
rehearse
yeah so that that's the key like you
know you always got to prepare yourself
because you're going out there 20 000
people they could really boo you in new
york
like yo i'm from here too
every other night
so you got to be careful and we just had
a crazy good like setlist um the
transition made sense
and um i'm just happy to be a part of it
all right
now let's talk about the private jets
yeah uh your name is pj kevin yeah so
explain first the business and then
we're gonna get into the economics of
these businesses um to be honest with
you i've been in the business for 10
years now uh chartering jets
from all around the world and um to be
honest with you uh last year during the
pandemic
the numbers just increased at an
all-time high like i didn't
i didn't know um it was going to be like
this but you know just by
you know everybody you know with the
colvin and everybody scared to go these
airports and be around people
the numbers started in march and april
just spiked up and it hasn't come down
yet
um the business right now is at an
all-time high i mean
finding a private jet is like almost
impossible um between me and you i just
put a loi in to buy a plane
because at the end of date it's like
it's it's
it's all about supply and demand right
and the demand is just at an all-time
high i mean people with money even came
in finding planes i was talking to swiss
the other day and he was like
i had to take a citation x from new york
to san diego you know how i felt kev and
that's like you know for his standard
that's like really really small like
that's you know super mid-sized jet he's
usually on like heavy jets but
you know when you got to go and you you
know the price is the price and you have
no other choice and no other option you
just got to go so walk me through the
economics of this right so let's say i
want to take uh the a small jet from
miami to new york how much is that going
to cost me from miami to new york right
now in today's market you're looking at
from 18 000 to 21 000. all right and but
that's on a uh a smaller just like a
mid-size yeah all right and then what
about like the largest jet i could get
the largest jet right now and today's
market is going for like anywhere from
like 25 to 30 000 one way and that's
only on a two two and a half hour flight
if it wasn't the pandemic it usually
about you know all day long 18 to 20
grand on a heavy jet yeah but you just
see the spike up when you know it almost
it don't it didn't quite double it's
like up 50 or so yeah for sure all right
then what about like new york to la new
york the la's about 35 grand on a g4
so that's about a heavy jet um and right
now in today's market i mean i'm seeing
things 45
60 one way i had a client the other day
call me and he was like i need to go
from new york to l.a i was like what is
your budget he said 65 000 kev
i said 65 000 one way and he paid it no
problem but you're like i could get you
there
i'm sure i can find something you know
a lot of people are making money and i
mean especially with this crypto and
everything going up i mean
it's a lot a lot of money it's crazy
it's crazy so what happens though they
call you up and they're basically like i
want to take this trip and you go call
your contacts yes i have a lot of
relationships with the owners and the
operas of these jets uh that manage
these jets and um i have a massive
network of people that actually own
these assets and
um i build up great relationships
throughout the industry and um
yeah i just try to get them the best
price i'm all about you know longevity
in the business i don't care about
making a quick buck on a first-time
transaction and more about i'd rather
you do a hundred trips and i make a
hundred dollars then you know i make a
thousand dollars on one trip yeah
when somebody gets on what are the rules
they can do whatever they want on the
jet
i mean
that's a yes
not whatever they want but they they can
have fun you know all right have you
ever had someone get kicked kicked off
like not allowed back uh yeah i had a
couple people actually um it was a
client that called me that wanted to
smoke on a plane and
the owner just didn't allow smoking but
he actually still smoked and he's
actually been from
that aviation company that private
company so basically if i own a plane
yeah i give it to you or i loan it out
to these guys to go and take for a trip
just to earn some cash on it while i
still own it yeah it's more of a tax
break but now it's more of a you know
passive income now especially if you
have the clienteles i'm doing about four
to five jets a week right now so i'm
pretty busy um but yeah you can earn
some if you don't chart it out yourself
you can earn some cash and if you don't
care about taking your own personal
trips you could definitely earn some
income for sure and has the the gas has
obviously gone up has that changed the
price of this stuff of course so jet
fuel is at
pretty high in different locations i
mean i had a client right now that's
going to boston boston is at a like
all-time high things like that 4 000
some change right now just
you know it was at an all-time high
but um yeah i mean
it's the industry is crazy right now and
i don't think it's slowing down
especially with the holly's coming up
people are like
you know even like more corporations i'm
starting to see uh uh you know china
into the private jet sector more than
first class tickets and things like that
i mean it was a [ __ ] shoot another
day in atlanta airport i mean that
doesn't help right so
um i see more and more people flying
private in the near future for sure and
then you accept bitcoin yes i accept
bitcoin ethereum cardone now uh usdt
uh xrp
uh what are people paying in bitcoin
bitcoin bitcoin and ethereum yeah um
it's crazy because i started accepting
and in february
my number spiked up about 60
in bitcoin transactions um
i look at it like this
you can't send a wire on a sunday you
can't send a wire on a saturday but
bitcoin is open 24 hours fax
fax you know what i mean so
um you know if you call me up on a
saturday on a sunday morning i'm not
panicking no more like hey you need to
send a wire i can't get you out i'm like
hey
uh i have a way where you can transfer
your usdt to
bitcoin or whatever form of currency
that i i accept i'm also launching a
partnership with open node in the near
future
um and yeah it's it's been and what do
you do with the bitcoin when they pay
you i hope you hold it yeah
you know
[ __ ] and now that's why you're buying a
plane
i put on my american express and um
i do what i got to do but all right i
hold it so so walk me through like the
types of folks who you normally are
dealing with these are athletes
musicians yeah athletes musicians
celebrities um i just got the corporate
account of netflix travel now
um so netflix they hit you up for if
they need a private jet yeah netflix
channel yeah yeah all right that's big
time big time that's big time that's
real big this big time that's where
you're trying to expand the business do
more corporate stuff yeah more corporate
stuff but i'm really trying to expand in
africa i mean that's an untapped market
that i'm you know i've always been
focused on i'm from ghana myself so i've
seen the industry going towards that way
because it's
it's now like a lot of people are
starting to fly in and out of africa uh
just for different businesses and things
like that so my whole thing is just to
get a fleet of jets
man there's some in the us and some in
africa how much would a flight from like
here to ghana be uh
roughly
175 000 one way
yeah it's a lot
yeah to get there right it's not like
you can stop halfway in the atlantic
ocean i mean g550 could get you here
g650 could get you there i see grant
just bought a g650 er that's a nice one
yeah you know what i mean and um so why
is he why is he by the planes i saw that
break okay how the tax breaks on planes
100 appreciation wait what
that was the cheap ass point
booked every week
literally
so if i buy a point let's say how much
is uh uh
not like a small plane how much of a
small plane depends hawker of course
anywhere from like a million to 1.4
right now
uh g4 a good one it's about four million
they got these in soccer it's there's a
weightless i mean right now it's crazy
so the weightless but i have some
off-market deals that we can talk about
also thinks we're buying one this
afternoon
hey you gotta know the weight might not
be but i might be here
g4 is four million dollars
if i bought a g4 for four million
dollars i've never even been on a
private jet i don't know what i'm
talking about but
no no no no
no no
i almost set a tier for you
the first time the first time i go on a
private jet is either mine or i ain't
going on one
ain't going on nobody else's goddamn jet
listen but g4
g4
listen the g4 if i bought a g4 for four
million dollars then you just write it
all off on day one you can write it all
off why do they do that 100 depreciation
so
um next season's coming up damn man
that's why these dudes be buying the
jets
listen i'm not a tax expert
and i will help you all right you know
charter it out but talk to your
accountant it is a 100 depreciation
um and so when they depreciate it uh how
much let me take what we say g4 whatever
that is right four million dollars how
much does that cost to uh operate
uh on a good year i'll say 900 to a
million bucks um
a year
depends on you know what type of g4 you
buy depends on if it's updated as far as
the avionics program the maintenance
records all that takes into place on how
you use it
um but yeah some good points but if
you're writing it but if you're renting
it out and let's say you rent it out
once a week right not i'm not a uh
look at it like
do about
300 hours a year
okay and that would be uneven
yeah most likely you get about 50 hours
to use for yourself for the year
yeah so basically you you fly for like
350 hours yeah but you got a plane
exactly and somebody else is paying for
it essentially exactly
the most expensive parts of planes are
the engines right so how long do the
engines last for uh depends on what type
of plane you buy you know some planes
have two engines some pains you know you
talking about a small plane single
engine i won't recommend them get on
anymore but this is my preference yeah
that's just my preference but
um yeah it just depends you know you
have to just check the maintenance
records and of course before buying a
plane you have to do a pre-buy and make
sure everything adds up you know on
paper
um
listen i'll move quick i already googled
this [ __ ] 2018 goldstream g650 is 52
million
did you look at that dollars you're
looking at okay a 650 that's a big one
yeah i mean you're looking at number one
you're looking at the year you're
looking at uh the 650 yeah i need you to
go and look at do you know how old these
planes is that you get on on dell two no
that's it tell me this yeah they're all
scary yeah they're really really old but
people don't axe and people don't know
you know what i mean and information is
out there like if you google right now
boeing 77 delta and just look at the
year and you guys fly on it you know
what i mean yeah yeah
seven seven yeah boeing seven seven
seven uh i think it's an er yeah 300 er
yeah 300 er yeah i mean drake got his
plane for free yeah how do you do that
how do you get a free plane i mean his
connections it's all about relationships
i tell everybody the most important
currency is relationships
facts that's the most important currency
and then there's bitcoin
oh they got a g4 right here just like
you said four million bucks
four million and what year is it it's an
88 so you know
but look at look at the okay so look at
the engine hours what's the engine
knowledge on it are you on
controller.com or website buyer okay go
to controller.com and type in golf
stream
all right i'm on controller okay
type in golf stream y'all bout to mess
around and watch somebody buy a jet real
quick
all right bitcoin
what he said he said we can get this
done
let me start out let me be reasonable i
said price low to high and uh
yeah price low to high let's see a lot
of you say hey you gotta call me for the
price
yeah g280 total time 1700 hours um what
is the year
uh that's the 2018. okay what is the
price
it says call me which is already on so
that's the that's a negotiation okay
negotiate oh yeah i like that approach
there's a there's a 2008 gulf stream
yeah g550 for 20 million okay
so okay all right let me just tell you
guys don't ever look at the price look
at the down payment
ever in life yeah you know and nothing's
not never like too expensive i always
look okay 105k monthly okay that's
nothing i'm doing about 105k is nothing
monthly or that's just the down payment
you have to put it up you have a 15 down
payment
how much 20 million bucks
but you got okay so look at it like this
if you
you can
you don't have to buy the pain
singularly on by the way
so
you all guys can you know say hey we own
this plane
and i'm not a tax expert the attacks i'm
not a financial advisor
but you can actually set up a
corporation that's corp
and um
get the best financing
okay get the corporation exactly so so
it's s it says total time that's the
that's the supply yeah so 7 000 it's not
bad at all not bad that's the 88 the
goal stream that we were looking at
that's 4 million bucks it's not bad
that's 20k a month wait wait is 20 you
say 4 million dollars 4 million dollars
wait hold on back up he's got a four
million dollar jet what year is it it's
a that's the 88. okay but you guys you
can refurb it to 2028 i think it is
yeah no the inside is nice
paint job interior is that wi-fi check
that if it got if it only got wi-fi oh
we need wi-fi yeah it definitely won't
it make sure
my thighs don't work in the sky
[Laughter]
installing wi-fi could be expensive here
it seats 13 people 13 people so uh if
someone wants to take the jet right you
got the jet and you're renting it out or
whatever does uh does it matter how many
people they're going to take
or like does it you increase the price
if they want to take more people or it's
just not you no no
[Music]
the maximum people is 13 passengers if
you if that's what you see online but um
you know most people fly as a group
anyway i mean i have to have some single
you know clients that like to fly by
themselves
but most people fly in groups anyway i
mean you're not going anywhere in aspen
or like
[ __ ] new york and you're just going
by yourself yeah like on here there's a
1987 astra gulfstream
1125 87. it's got 7 000 uh hours 7 100
hours but this is like 895 grand which
seems like i'm out because i might be
paying 895 grand to die
it's like it's probably like 10 for
maintenance and operations costs
throughout the year yeah i'll i'll say
about um
you know it depends on what what plan
you have um
just budget yourself to have at least a
million bucks a year a million bucks a
year yeah okay because the 4 million ten
percent would be like 400k so 20 well
right okay right and then you also got
to look at if it's on rolls royce
corporate here and that's your question
about the engines and making sure
um
you know you have your maintenance
records up to date
um you then have to look at
you know certain things as far as the
avionics program because that could cost
you a fortune
um you have to check um the the flight
log and make sure
um you know your plane is basically what
they say is is on paper is actually
um
state and and and things like that but
that's all in the pre-buy and
you know but yeah i made landings
there's too many landings
we're playing defense uh this is the
2011 goldstream g1
5 million bucks how many landings one
million bucks they said 2 600 landings
what year is it uh 2011. no it's 2011.
oh you got a different one yeah
2600 500 hours that's a lot right it's
not that bad though
for that price for that price not that
bad how does it work for your company
with like the pilots and getting them
moving them around so we have um so i'm
a charter company i have a management
company that i outsource and they handle
the whole nine yards um and there's
different management companies out there
that can help you out um of course they
take a management fee so right now i'm
negotiating 85 15 where i get 85 and
they get 15 percent but they haven't
they handle everything from pilots to
uh
you know everything maintenance and you
just bring them you bring them to
clients and basically tell them they
want this plane or they want to go here
right well it'll be on my plane um
if i buy it you know you'll be on my
plane and basically i have first right
to my plane first if that's charted out
then they have 31
uh gulf streams on their fleet that i
can choose from so
so
so say i want to charter a jet right i
know i'm going to do a bunch of these
trips a year i'm going to call you up
5-10 times what's the difference between
you and like a net jets or something
like that see netjets they have a
different uh what's their model they
yeah they have a lot
they're using more of the membership
model
where um people pay a membership fee to
join a program they also have a joint uh
ownership program where you can buy into
a couple hours on a partner jet
and um
it works you know for that type of
client but my clients normally is like
on the go they just want to just call
you up they're like dude
and you're able to find it uh or
sometimes you gotta fly in uh you gotta
fly people in
um like fly a jet in to pick them up or
the jets usually in the city so yeah
usually if it's you know depends on
where they're flying from um it's always
a jet and tita bro it's always a gen
opelaca there's always a jet in these
major cities but if it's a city like you
know like kansas and these are you know
tennessee and these other weird cities
that are it's not really as popular
um
it's usually you know you have to pay a
reposition fee and that you know that
goes taxable to the client yeah that's
expensive or no depends on where the jet
is coming from it could be
yeah it could be pretty funny yeah
sounds like it sounds like we should
talk out of this and no what's the crazy
what's the craziest thing what's the
craziest thing you've seen anyone do
buying a jet or rental
uh
the craziest thing um
like what happened on the flight or off
the floor or or just buying it
like did anybody ever call you up you're
on buying this [ __ ] right now i just
made the decision and band-aids going
they buy it uh
i spoke to diddy's team and um
yeah they they pulled the trigger pretty
quick they um
what kind of point he put a g5 and he
was like i'm about to wrap this [ __ ] all
black and i'm like don't do that
and if you know and he actually did it
though yeah why not do it
um just because i thought basically what
the black paint is uh
is like it affects the engine
you know with the heat especially if
it's gonna be down here in florida i was
gonna be in l.a yeah um
but he used a special type of paint
which it was fine and it was actually
cool so you said google did he's playing
it's actually pretty cool yeah bro he
really did that shit's all black
yeah he did it right hey you looking at
it
yeah he did it and then of course it's
cause he's taking photos with all black
cars next to me
he said it's gonna look like that's my
mentor that's a good dude man like how
much is it how much it costs to uh uh to
wrap a plane like that it's got to be
expensive 200 grand
i saw uh what's his name uh grant
cardone i saw him uh he posted somewhere
he said um
it cost him a million dollars to put
like a separator or 800 grand or
something to put like a like a door in
the plane he bought a plane and he
didn't have a door like halfway through
and he wanted the door so he put in he's
like 800 grand to put a door in the
plane by the way um it's a real real
demand on aviation parts right now like
seriously man on aviation parts there's
diddy
yeah there he is
he's got a got a picture in his car
he's got a black car in front
yeah yeah i seen that picture yeah my
god i was my mentor man he's a good dude
i love him
what's the most someone's ever paid for
like a one-way trip or something like
that i had a client the other day in
bitcoin on cash
on cash
um i had a client of the day paid me 238
thousand dollars to go one way from new
york to dubai
is that a lot for that trip yes yeah
yeah one way
they got to come back one way bro they
didn't have any money
they moved yeah i mean in the back seat
of spirit
that was pretty that's pretty heavy yeah
that's crazy
and international fights obviously just
because of the distance they're more
expensive but yeah per hour
yeah so just look at it per hour
anywhere from four thousand to six
thousand per hour i mean right now in
today's market
7 500 hours what do you what do you take
care of they just show up they call you
from new york to l.a and they just show
up yeah i take everything from a to z so
anything off the plane that i can do as
far as the ground transportation
catering
uh we also doing a lot of like um
designing um interior wise when it comes
to if it's like a special occasion like
a birthday valentine's day
um any special occasions you saw you had
your mom on a plane the other day i put
my mom i was
i was kind of uh emotional for that one
because
i was just telling her like mom i'm
going to like a new level in life and
like i'm trying to tell like
she didn't know i was like my you're
taking a jet back by yourself and she
was like what i'm like yeah you're about
to take a jet back by yourself i'm not
coming this is all you and then she
texts me she's like um we have this like
group chat
and i'm like um
mommy's on the jet she put yeah a big
one too
[Laughter]
she said get it right
on facebook
i posted it to the conversation because
it's like
you know it's just the way i'm not in
life you know what i mean and it's on my
social media is actually the second
picture
and um it was just like you know it was
super impressive to actually do that for
my mom
um but yeah i'm i'm always like
i'm just showing the family what what
i'm i'm what i'm able to do right now
i'll put them on yeah i got to put them
on what what's going on in sofi uh
sophia bulgaria why are these planes in
sofia bulgaria
uh there's like six of them on here that
are all uh
in either annapolis maryland or uh
sophia bulgaria i gotta find that i
gotta find out what's going on nobody i
don't know yet yeah my wife's from there
i don't know what uh what's going on
there either i ain't seen no private
jets
i like i like how you do the pj kev
approved on the on the menus and stuff
yeah i love that that's um you know we
we i created a brand around this and um
you know it's just been expanding and
it's crazy because i really don't ask
anybody to post me i just let it
organically happen and i think
um once you have the organic reaction to
your clients and just being you know uh
you know
especially like
for me i'm all about the details so you
got to be like real detail oriented when
you come when it comes to like you know
taking care of these clients because
they are paying top dollar so
we just try to create the best
experience possible and i can't wait to
put you guys on the air first jet
nah bro i ain't going on one time buy it
that's right you sure yeah okay so what
would you do in a situation where you
have to get somewhere there's no flights
available but you have to get someone
whether to take a meeting i ain't going
to call my cell phone
you need to talk to me how about you
have to be present to like really get
this deal done what are you going to do
are you not going to look at me we have
driven
growing up okay there were seven of us
so we drove everywhere okay everywhere
from we're in north carolina we drive
down to florida we drive up new york we
go to pennsylvania wherever we had to go
we drove okay there was no flights ever
okay so we're used to this stuff we
gotta get somewhere we drive
y'all
special shout out to my brother
happy birthday dj khaled aka the mr tour
guy his the tour bus himself he used to
take tour buses everywhere yeah he now
flies private of course special shout
out to you my brother happy birthday dj
khaled what was he doing on the uh on
the tour buses he was driving he was
scared to fly oh really oh you're scared
that's why he's doing it he hasn't flown
in like 10 years and i told him i'm like
it's all good are the private jets safer
or not as super safe they're safer
there's more taxes that happen in cars
than
jets for sure yeah and that's and what
about commercial flights versus private
flights
it's probably the flying is the safest
way to travel anywhere you go
yeah that's that's and what a lot of
these guys just like it because it saves
them a bunch of time obviously save them
time you're paying for time that's what
you're paying for yeah paying for time
when you look at companies like walmart
they have a private jet they have one of
the largest private jet fleets in the
world right and that's why they do it
because time you can you can go west
coast all around you know you can go to
smaller airports you don't have to wait
you can you can do things a lot easier
right yeah i flew one time uh we got
into new york
uh we took on a meet and it was two
hours and i flew back to l.a and i was
back in l.a before 8pm so like
[Laughter]
i told you i went on the private jet the
one time with this kid in his his uh is
a small plane like a cessna or something
okay and
his uh his dad owned it and we pulled up
we legit pulled into the in the into the
parking spot we were in the air within
five minutes like legit like in the air
we walked straight from the car right on
the plane
got that thing in the air it was amazing
no they didn't have anything
down they don't make sure shampoo wasn't
too big bro i was sitting up front with
the pilot
don't give a [ __ ]
yeah
but like i told you that when on the way
back the uh the plane wasn't starting
right he had some trick to get it
started he was like turn this off turn
it back on i was like bro like maybe we
wait till tomorrow and get on delta or
something
this thing's a little old
how old was it oh it was pretty old i
mean it was a small plane too it was
like uh it was like a four-seater or
something like that oh so yeah
i'm gonna talk to you guys about some
nft stuff as well too because i'm like
i'm like learning all this like nft with
the metaverse um what are your thoughts
on the future of nft is it like a big
like hype right now is it like are you
guys following like like the bald apes
and the crypto punks and like
uh wonder woman and everything that's
like going right on right now so here's
my take is first of all the whole nft
thing is people think about it they're
thinking of like the art
it'll have some value whatever right but
like i don't think that's gonna be the
really big thing if you go back and you
think about um
when the internet came around if the
media companies have been like oh my god
the internet's amazing guess what we do
we take our newspaper we just put it uh
like a pdf we print it uh we take our
physical paper we make a pdf and we put
on a website they go to the website you
can read the newspaper on the internet
a bunch of people are like man that's
really big that's gonna be huge right
but like how many people really aren't
gonna read the physical paper versus go
to some website and just read a static
you know pdf of the newspaper probably
not that many
but the whole value of the internet to
the media publishers was they could do
uh like content management systems they
could have dynamic headlines they could
insert multimedia they could use social
media for distribution like the real
value wasn't just replicate the
newspaper on the internet it was
completely changed the way that you
produce the content you distribute the
content et cetera so a lot of what the
nfts and like i even made this mistake
you know last year way before most of
people were into it i was like oh my god
it's gonna be big
but i was thinking of it as like take
the art and then just bring it into like
a digital version so like the digital
art will be bigger than the physical
which is true
but that's like two percent of the true
value the real value is just this whole
idea of like it's it's a private
property that you can control right
right now
i think part of the the risk or the
error that people are making is
they're like oh man uh uh it's
decentralized a lot of these platforms
aren't really decentralized whatever i
don't think they need to be right like
you're not worried about somebody
censoring me sending you a board ape
right like
like if somebody sensor and i got bigger
problems in my life than that right so
it's like a lot of these systems don't
actually need to be uh decentralized so
it's like if you want to have some level
of like sovereignty or the ability to
hold
private keys or property that's okay but
how much of it is actually decentralized
or centralized like there's an argument
that no you need to be decentralized in
order to get that private property
aspect and hold the private keys some
people argue there's other ways to do it
whatever
the bigger thing i think ends up being
that uh
ev every single asset on the internet if
we move to these digital systems will
have to be either functional or
non-functional right if you think about
every analog asset it's like look this
is the example i always use if i take
this one dollar bill right and you put
down a dollar and they put down a dollar
and we mix them all up i just grabbed
one dollar and leave as long as they're
all real dollars it don't matter if i
got my serial number back or not if i if
i just got a dollar back it still buys
the same thing at the store right but if
i show up and i got a picasso painting
and you guys got three other artists
they're all real but we put them down we
mix them up and i just grab a random
piece if i don't get the picasso back
well that is really important the
picasso not the no-name artist right
and so they're still real right or
originals it's just that one of them was
really important because of who it is so
the the fungibility or non-fungibility
becomes important in art not necessarily
so much in currency so when you think
about that you're like all right like
what are all the cases in the digital
world where non-fungible assets would be
important like of course there's going
to be something there it's just who uses
them how do you use them what's the
connection between the online and
offline world like
uh garyvee a couple other people they
have uh they're starting a restaurant
where rather until memberships are gonna
sell like nfts and then the nft gets you
access to the restaurant gets you a seat
at the table and stuff so like people
are gonna try a bunch of stuff it's just
like what ends up being the the right
solution right
i'm not smart enough to figure it out
right the best thing i like about nfts
is the resale and how you can get a
percentage of the resale so i think one
thing that's really great for people is
if they can figure out a way to sell
like an mba ticket and then when i sell
it once the nba doesn't make money
because i sold it on stubhub stubhub
makes the money right so why can't i get
2.5 of it being resold somewhere else
and then again and again and again so
every time switches hands you make a
little bit more money and it's a way to
track that as well got it that's what i
like about the technology part of it art
is art if you enjoy it you enjoy it well
now i was just asking a question because
i'm collecting a lot of african art i'm
actually doing an art uh show for art
basically on december 4th
but um i just don't see the
you know
the real value in digital art yet like
you know i i mean
don't get me wrong i mean i wish i would
have bought a board eight but i wasn't
able to build a crypto pump you know
what i mean but the resale value is
actually crazy but
it's just i don't just see the real
value in it yeah i mean
the crazy thing is i just bought the um
uh what is it called the uh oculus uh
the meta version oh yeah yeah i just
bought one and i'm actually using it now
and i'm like yo this [ __ ] is crazy but
like
what can i use here in a metaverse as
far as like a digital asset like can i
put art in my little walkway where you
when you first put on the the goggles or
whatever so like
i just don't see the real value in it
but i do
i'm starting to like really understand
the nft space and see what
um i can buy you know but i what i do
believe in for sure is the dns which is
like the pjk
which i bought um i bought a couple
different um you know dns domains and
and i think that's going to have some
real value into it but
um
but the nft is not yet nmt's i don't see
it yet yeah
i mean i follow it and it's you know
what about the clients they they they're
into this stuff yet or now not yet a lot
of people don't really understand it yet
um
i was talking to rich the kid and he was
like yo buy a board date buy a board i'm
like
i'm not just dropping no 200 grand on
that like i could buy something else
for 200. you know what i mean man um
he's got one yeah yeah
he bought it real cheap or he bought it
recently um he bought it like eight
months ago it was real cheap that's what
i'm saying yeah like i mean it all
depends too right like it's kind of like
with bitcoin like if you bought your
first bitcoin at 60k and it drops and
you're like man you know screw bitcoin
yeah but you bought your first bitcoin
at a dollar you're like big one's
amazing right so like that there is some
element of uh
uh i think he got it for 120. he said
120. so it's a 200 now or something
right so like yeah yeah he says 200 now
yep yeah
all right i mean that's not too bad it's
not too bad not at all
all right what else you got going on
anything else i saw you just did a
friend's giving you got an alcohol
sponsor for that that was all time
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh good thing i brought it up
well hold it up so the camera can see it
wait so what's the story behind how do
those deals work like what happened with
that well what is dylan whose brand is
it yeah all right so it's diddy's brand
it's owned by black man is uh smooth as
tequila and um you know we just
supporting the brand and just making
sure that people really get a taste of
how tequila is supposed to taste and
it's smooth i don't know if you guys
want to take a shot you guys drink
no they drink it i drink it
yeah i think you know we just so so
diddy's the one who uh created it yeah
the creator owns it um
and um basically he just you know we're
allowing us to just basically bring it
like it's ours and
just making sure that you know people
know about it and they they got it at uh
clubs and bars and stuff too or you
gotta only buy it private yeah they
gotta have clubs and boss yeah like to
me that that's what um uh ace of spades
right that's how they really popped off
was like everyone knew that it was legit
but then you would see somebody order it
at a club or whatever and they would
bring it out and really oh
have you tasted it well well ace of
spades yeah yeah it's really good yeah
it's very good well they're making them
for like 13. what's that jay-z's right
yeah yeah he's actually just sold he
sold it right yep i saw i told this
story on here before but uh i saw a clip
one time on youtube and when he's like
viral clips and it was you know that guy
dave ramsey the like that guy and
somebody wrote into me was like dave you
told me to you know save all my money
and uh i saw jay-z spend 150 000 on
friday night at the club uh did a
calculation like no and they were like
uh
like he's not following your advice and
he's rich why should i listen to you
and dave was like let me walk you
through this real quick he's like you
know jay-z made 40 million dollars last
year you know whatever and he's buying
his own alcohol at the club like he's
like and by the way that'd be the
equivalent if you make 100 grand that
you spent eleven dollars
you see this big headline number but
it's all relative yeah uh but but his
other point was like but he's also
buying the product that is he's paying
himself to drink at the club for sure
yeah it's pretty uh pretty smart so we
also did uh in 2018 we did a christmas
party at the 40 40 club oh nice new year
new york city yeah and uh uh i think
people were a little shook when that's
where uh we held it because it's so big
and uh there was like i don't know
probably
maybe not a thousand people 800 900
people showed up on a couple days notice
and um
they got all the the alcohol yeah they
got the
ace of spades on the bar yeah above the
bar and uh i was man i was this nice ass
place yeah
did you go to the back room huh did you
guys see the back room yeah with the
pool table i didn't hang out there
[Laughter]
i saw it
uh but he did just sell it right
uh the ace of spades like like recently
he sold him
he still has 40 40 though yeah yeah he
starts the club but yeah but they sold
the ace of spades yeah look and then
what is it uh who's the guy um
ken austin right ken austin's the guy
who did uh proper 12 with mcgregor and
he did uh uh tara mana uh with the rock
avion too i think so i mean that's like
that guy's all over it right he just
keeps kind of repeating the same thing
the rocks got the massive one all these
guys are doing it now right yeah i mean
it makes sense to do right i mean the
rock now rock's got what he's got uh
under armour uh deal he has a lot of
friends he has the alcohol then he's got
he may be
energy in not the number one energy
drink in the world right now i don't
know probably it is it's like it's
something i'm pretty sure that zoa ended
up i think
again we've talked about this before but
i think he's going to be the president
one day really i've been saying that i
think he's going to be definitely the
president
think about it think how big he is no
he's you know
right here's my pitch for why the rocks
can be president
there's three things that matter one
he's physically intimidating so what
they there's a ton of studies that show
when they put him up on the debate stage
whoever the biggest guy like trump's 6'4
right so whoever's the biggest one that
uh just naturally like bio biology is
like oh he's the leader because he's the
biggest most like physically
intimidating he ain't nobody going to
run this even close to his size right so
that's what two is uh he's actually very
intelligent we hear him in interviews
and stuff he's not like some people you
can feel like they're protecting them a
little bit and they don't speak freely
like no he's really intelligent now he
may not be an expert at politics or
certain topics or whatever but he's
intelligent and the third thing is he's
got the ability to be charismatic enough
where like imagine i used to say like uh
uh trump style was very much uh he would
attack right like he would just
constantly attack people on both sides
of the aisle
if the rock and him were debating and
trump attacked him
shut your candy ass up
right but he could like push back in a
way that other people couldn't push back
he's charismatic enough like so like
he just has this like skill set that i
think is actually really good for
politics that you don't have to be the
expert at the political stuff because
you could hire for the okay you're going
to be my you know uh national security
campaign whatever and it's just like you
put it all together and you're like
damn man like he's got a shot i don't
know if he'll yeah but he's got a shot
more than he's gonna think until you
like really you know sit down do you
wanna know the second person i think
he's gonna be president
people get people get real upset no so
kanye uh i don't think he could win at
this point because i think that uh
if you run from outside of politics i
think you get one shot to like to get a
big enough push after that like each
individual push after that like it just
kind of gets uh
commoditized away
kim kardashian
really
here's why
kim kardashian uh has reinvented herself
like four or five times right so
obviously the tape to the reality star
to entrepreneur to now criminal justice
reform and all that so and it always is
heading in like a more mature
sophisticated you know states woman-like
way
the second thing is that a large portion
of the population finds her attractive
whether we like it or not i do think
that that's gonna be a big piece for a
woman who ends up running for president
uh and then the other thing is uh if all
of a sudden she shows up and she goes by
the way i've been focused on um uh
criminal justice reform and i've been
able to get x number of people out of
prison i've been able to reform these
laws
that sounds like what a politician would
be saying right right so like maybe she
doesn't go from no politics to president
but like could she be governor of
california arnold schwarzenegger did it
yeah right like you know and that's not
a knock against him like he he's smart
guy too whatever but like celebrity is
celebrity power and so
i think that that's like a world that
people started to like damn who else
could be president
like you start thinking to yourself
you're like yeah there's a lot of people
uh that you you can't come out of uh the
finance world i think that's the only
world that you can't come out yeah cause
like what was the guy's name um michael
bloomberg yeah bloomberg tried it on the
left and on the right you had uh uh mitt
romney right so like two guys
incredibly wealthy i mean you know
bloomberg supposedly spent a billion
dollars on his presidential campaign he
dropped out after a week i don't know
how you spend a billion dollars in a
week but he was out and then you had uh
i mean he did he bought memes on the
internet that's what he did right and
then uh mitt romney they said that he
had uh like 250 million dollars in his
retirement account
right and it's like i mean these guys
are really really wealthy but they don't
win because i i do think that it's not
just uh money you got to have the
charisma you got to have the celebrity
outside the popularity contest yeah it
still is a popularity contest whether
sure uh we like it or not right i mean
he's like 280 million followers on this
he's the most recognizable person in the
world to study show
so nobody in the world is more
recognizable than that guy it i mean
just that alone you're in the
conversation you could be president yeah
right so the 80s heavy
it's 280 million i mean what there's uh
that's like five like just under five
percent of the world population follows
him on an app
kim kardashian got 265.
yeah but like think about it the rock's
got more than kim kardashian and i would
i bet that the rock i don't know is for
sure but if i had to guess the rocks
audience outside the united states has
exploded right like on a percentage
basis so maybe he had one percent
international at one point now it's you
know 20 30 40 percent yeah and he's got
more runway because uh he's in movies
all the stuff she does isn't necessarily
going to get translated or dubbed into
like other languages and other countries
and stuff he
you know and again we all want to get
into the uh the chinese uh censorship
and like the the appealing to them in
the movie industry but like they just
launched a movie uh straight to netflix
number one movie on netflix and it's
gonna definitely get into china and when
it gets into china like he just builds
an audience in a country that she
probably doesn't have as easy of an
ability to build no you're right 100
yeah right so like you know and and the
other thing too is he he's been asked
multiple times when he run he's always
like well the people wanted me too
[Laughter]
i think he's open too like he like when
he was asking i think a vanity uh fair
profile they were basically like would
you run he's like look i don't really
know much about it i haven't looked into
being the president but he was open to
it and he like understands where his
weaknesses are right you're going to run
pj kevin no i'm not no you know you're
done i know you're staying out of that
you could charge air force one though
right
i might do something in ghana but i
don't think i'm gonna run oh yeah yeah
the the
the whole idea about politics is uh why
why would you want
that
stress like that struggle and waking up
every day feeling like that i i'm happy
but it's not it's not like that it's
also there's this element of uh
what could you really get done
right so i want to say who it is but
somebody who legitimately could run for
one of these political offices very well
known very well liked uh very wealthy uh
said to me once he goes i'm more capable
of getting things done outside of
political office than i would be in it
i was like what do you mean he was like
well guess what if i'm a politician all
i got to do is a bureaucratic process
outside of here i got cash
and i was like yeah like true again
right he could fund companies he could
set up nonprofits he could like do a
bunch of stuff and i was like you know
okay go to the extreme example who's
gotten more done from a global
perspective take the top uh
philanthropist that came from the
private market take like a bill gates or
something like that i know people get
all worked up about him but like take
somebody like that versus one president
who's had a bigger impact and and change
like for sure bill gates
yeah i mean he's got you know what 200
billion dollars like
what it was he owns the most land in
wyoming you heard about that
owner in the entire united states
yeah him and then ted turner the guy who
got cnn yeah or did i don't know if he
owns it or not uh he's the largest uh
private owner of uh bison
in the united states too because he he
thinks that there's going to be a food
shortage
yeah for real
uh is john malone john maloney yeah
cable cowboy is what he's the largest
largest landowner yeah uh but um
bill and melinda gates owned more
farmland in the united states
than the size of 50 countries farmland
that's what it is
yeah so the the other thing that i saw
was uh when bill gates and melinda gates
got divorced melinda gates went to uh an
island and she paid 132 000 a night to
be at the island by herself so no one
could take pictures of her and stuff and
they calculated they said she could live
there every single night for the rest of
her life and she wouldn't even touch
five percent of her wealth
what bro
like
what are you doing all this money though
like you gotta remember a billion
dollars
is
so much money
right like like think about this way
if i gave you a million dollars yeah and
then i said i'm gonna give you a hundred
of those
you only have a hundred million you
don't have a billion yet so a million
dollars times a hundred
i gotta give you a thousand millions to
get a billion yeah
like you could literally you know if i
gave you a billion dollars you could
spend one million dollars a day but
every day
for literally three years with inflation
going on right now right yeah
is that billion still worth a billion
dollars no of course not you can't buy
the same stuff you used to be right
but buddy
you just seen them playing for 52
million
yeah you take a billion you put in a
bank account the interest is nice i
don't care what's the most expensive
plane in the world type in um
type in that new uh
g800 uh airbus a380 jumbo uh super jumbo
type in the boeing tell me how much is
the new boeing um
the new boeing jet i forgot the name of
it i gotta get the name but also what's
expensive
uh 7x yep typing that in
and also look at that new global uh
8 000 i think that's just airbus a380
super jumbo how much is that 446 million
yeah and the uh the new boeing that's a
commercial area
yeah yeah they're commercial plants yeah
yeah it's other news you could deck it
out oh there's a spirits stealth bombers
though
joe's over here trying to buy [ __ ]
stealth bombers bro they said it's 2
billion well yeah dude because defense
contracts
bro this ling's got like like bowings
and [ __ ] too i thought this was like the
whole thing
joe's gonna fight the aliens
how much is it no by the way i do
believe
um the aliens like
it got to be a species other than humans
all right i'm glad you brought this up
what's going on with aliens you believe
in them no i just believe it's a species
besides outside of us yeah yeah of
course
are they like hanging around earth or
are they like elsewhere i don't know i
just you know you think that there's no
way we're the only people there exactly
all right there's no there's no way
though they're claiming air force one is
worth five point three billion dollars
the plane ain't worth that it's all the
stuff inside the plane
well it cost the pentagon 5.2 billion
well because they had government
contracts those dudes put zeros on the
end of what it really costs i'm gonna
come start hanging out with you guys
more often this is fun
that's true right tequila you come
whenever you want
[Laughter]
no problem with you
no problem can you buy old air force one
can you do that
oh they think i'm talking about this uh
is there a market to get into like nfl
nba teams in the in the private jets and
when that whenever they fly or is that
all just like suited up in like
long-term deals that they already have
100 is a market um
a lot of athletes right now um are
firing their agents
because they're finding that they was
getting a kickback on not only jets but
jets cars houses so they find they're
firing their agents
and um i think that's where i can tap
into i mean i've been flying a couple
different athletes but
um i do want to tap into the nba nfl
world a little bit more um i'm friends
with a couple of them know like
my boy you know jaylen brown he's a good
friend of mine he actually takes my jets
he's from boston celtics
um a few few friends so so what some of
these guys like if the the ones that got
shady aliens still basically uh tell
them they're gonna go buy something for
them like hey i want this car i want
this house i want whatever and they'll
add some cash on top of it for
themselves yo they'll get a kickback
from either from whoever from the
company or whatever yeah yeah so they're
finding that out and they're just fine
not pumped about that that pumped out
yeah i mean these guys are busy as [ __ ]
right they can't literally do or watch
everything themselves and it's just like
you gotta find people youtube i mean i
was watching uh a kanye west interview
the other day i don't know if you guys
seen it but he said he had 80 accounts
what what's the uh what was that thing
he did uh the interview he did it on uh
drink champs yeah that that interview
was amazing i watched the full thing
yeah but i saw a bunch of the highlights
like like 20 different highlights and
news you said you had 80 accounts right
and i was just like how do you manage 80
accounts 80 like bank accounts yes
yeah i mean i'm having trouble managing
a couple out there yeah
88 80s bombs and you know they're not
all at the same bank
it's not like he just last one login
yeah
yeah he's got an excel sheet of
passwords so crypto's on sale today too
guys
there's a sale going on in a black
friday sale
you buying of course
the the uh the the thing that uh uh i
appreciate about people who got all
those banking council stuff is i would
love to know what the ratio between uh
legal entities and bank accounts are
right like does he also have 80 llcs
because then all and then you get into a
game of like man you got a lot of stuff
going on right
yeah
it'd be easy to lose a hundred grand and
if you got 80 accounts like oh [ __ ] we
forgot that's a rounding error for him
yeah well maybe
what was it uh uh he's estimated now a
6.6 billion net worth and uh drake says
show me what's in your bank account
he's if uh leasing his record of [ __ ]
value no we said [ __ ] a evaluation show
me personal funds yeah yeah yeah yeah
right
but but i do think that that's like a
great point of uh there's multiple ways
that people think about wealth right
some people think of it as like what is
my illiquid uh kind of equity-based net
worth so what's the money that's in my
bank account then there's like you know
a hybrid of the two but you know i'm
sure that drake is explaining to people
that he you know he also has some equity
in uh there's but now i'm showing just
just send me a while later show me your
wallet let me see what's in your wallet
that's great like that what's in your
wallet yeah all right where can we send
people to find you on the internet pjcav
on instagram pj kim approve on twitter
um
approve
dashjets.com is my business page for
jets
approve art i have
uh african art show coming out on art
basil weekend down in beautiful miami if
you guys here december 4th you can get
your tickets on eventbrite you can go to
approveart.com
um i'm also launching a company called
approveexperiences.com
coming out in january 2022
and um just look out for what i got
coming up next
bro hold on a second first of all
everyone go follow you but second of all
that's what your twitter account to put
into the uh uh into the um
chat
my guy's banner photo was him outside
diddy's uh chat
he left this photo he said yeah i've
seen that one before
he said yeah i've seen that one before
because he took the same picture
that's all time you're a legend for that
one thank you my brother i appreciate it
all right any last words you got for the
people
invest and best and best and um
make sure you
do some research and some knowledge
before you invest in these
uh crypto coins that's it that's great
advice great advice all right hang out
for a second we're almost done all of
you that are still here
we got uh two more things we're gonna do
one
we got a hundred dollar uh
people who spent a hundred dollars in
the store
we got more shout outs daniella from
florida appreciate you nelson from
california alexander from germany global
global global everything tyler
washington stephen from canada
i know i'm gonna say global for that you
just think it's the united states
stevens
from florida and eric from virginia and
look we just got just people all over
the world all over the world we're
trying to help people get their
christmas gifts done that's all 21 off
in the store 21 that's going till sunday
right now it's going to monday night at
midnight monday night at midnight cyber
monday cyber monday i didn't know that
was the thing that's a thing though uh
21
reminder
buy 100 in the store give you a shout
out
if you spend 500 we'll go ahead and
we'll give you a personalized video if
it's been a thousand dollars you get to
come on the show there's two more people
who spend a thousand dollars they're
coming on the show here in a second and
then lastly is whoever spends the most
money in the store this weekend you know
what you're getting you're getting a
free trip to miami to come hang out with
us for a day so pretty uh pretty
straightforward we got two people
that are coming on now
uh we're gonna pull them up in a second
one one at a time who's the first person
michael is he there michael you there
i'm here brother what's up what's going
on man bang bang
where is what a crazy day man it is
black friday everywhere i know where do
you live
i'm uh just south of atlanta uh georgia
in georgia all right what what uh what
do you do out there
um uh i'm in petroleum wholesale um
services company um kind of everything i
got into bitcoin in december of
uh 2019
uh just a little bit didn't buy much and
then when elon put on his balance sheet
um i did it with our oil company and uh
i've been you know stacking stats ever
since all right first before we talk
about bitcoin tell me about what's going
on the oil market why is oil being so
crazy
i mean uh what is it uh
omnicron variant i don't know what they
call it some new
i don't know i'm watching dylan with
prayer glow go off on twitter uh right
now he's got me laughing pretty hard
um
that's it that's all it is lockdowns uh
joe biden's fixing to do some type of
emergency uh
announcement they're gonna ban travel to
africa um
i guess this is round two man
so um gas is down right now 30 cent a
gallon so
um i i guess right now it'd be great if
we didn't do the spr release
do you think they're going to do it so
for those that don't know the united
states has a strategic reserve of of oil
and uh we've pretty much decided i think
it's already officially decided that
they're going to release a bunch because
they're trying to get the gas prices
down uh which i actually read something
from peter zahn who said that's a
horrible idea it's actually going to
make the gas prices more expensive not
less expensive every time we've done it
pomp it's had the adverse effect and he
knows that oh so every time we've ever
released oil from the strategic reserves
the price goes up
it's gone up every time why does it go
up
i think it's i mean it puts fear in the
market and the speculators come in and
um
they buy more of it and uh
half of it's going to china china has
already said they were going to buy half
of what we would sell
so
um
it's crazy brother it's this it's crazy
toms man i got a question
can you see russia pricing their oil on
bitcoin i know that's been a
conversation recently you see that going
on or now
you know i'm uh
i'm a god-fearing bible reading
truth-speaking american patriot and
i would love to see that though and as
bad as that would probably be for this
country um
uh just because bitcoin even though i
first bought it i really didn't buy into
really what it was and how much
liberty
bitcoin brings and and the freedom uh
that's with it you know so
um
yeah man i
who knows if if russia does it man it's
game on
what what do you uh hear about of people
mining bitcoin uh that are able to
produce any of this uh energy
are they um i'm working on that um i'm a
big distributor with uh exxon mobil
um we just bought our first um mining
equipment from
uh actually came from one of your
recommendations with block ware
so we're going to start mining ourselves
but i'd love to try to be able to use
this with some of the big oil companies
i mean
with all their flares
the amount of energy being wasted there
is insane um have you talked to them
like like are they open to the
conversation
um
okay that's all you had to say thank you
[Laughter]
so i mean we'll see the thing is is they
don't need me you know i've they're
probably just i'm probably planting a
seed and
i'll just get bypass but
it's only good for the network you know
yeah i agree um all right and then uh
you said you started putting bitcoin on
your own balance sheet at the at the uh
oil business
yep sure did when leon did it we did it
um
we bought a little bit more with the
last drop
um
got it and then the
oh we oh no we got like multiple people
all joined at the same time sorry um and
then in terms of uh when you guys did it
what was it about elon's announcement
that uh got you excited about that i
think it just it you know it was it was
validation that
um
the bitcoin was going to come to be a a
major role in the world
um
it wasn't just me i you know friends in
the industry did it um
boomers i know were like wait a second i
need to look at this
and uh you know
everybody
it's on everybody's radar right now you
know um i'm excited about the future of
it i know this sucks today and
it looks like the world's going back
into
um a crazy bad house but hey we got ppp
loans coming again you know so the
helicopter money is back
i listen as much as i joke around about
this stuff and i'm laughing i do think
that your perspective is uh
much much more common than people
realize especially like kind of like the
coastal elites uh in terms of they think
that none of this stuff is uh is ever
gonna happen no one's going to uh um
uh
laugh at it or mock it but you know uh
our parents live in north carolina which
i'm assuming pretty similar to where uh
where you live and there's not a single
person there that thinks the
government's coming to save them right
like no heck no man and uh
there's a lot of people getting red
peeled right now which
um is a great thing in my opinion not
you know so
i i completely agree uh
somebody just said you'll appreciate
this somebody just said these guests are
real people on the streets doing real
people things not celebrity guests so
you're you're uh you're doing real
people things out in the world which i
appreciate amen brother amen um hey i
just want to say as a pomp investment
fund uh client
uh congratulations on your uh
i think i don't think i know you made
the right decision it actually made me
think about some of the stuff i'm doing
so
i've got younger i've got two kids
and uh you know time is money man you
know
the older you get the more we realize
that i i appreciate you very much uh i
have uh two questions for you before we
let you go one where can we send people
on the internet is there somewhere you
want us to send them yeah i mean i'm not
that active i kind of have been lately
but uh
or your business you your personal stuff
or your business wherever you want
dnd energy group um we're patrolling
wholesaler in the southeast
we own some convenience stores as well
um
wfj merchant services
and uh which is probably not going to
make it in 10 years where we're
blockchain's going but
and uh on twitter m underscore dormitory
um
yeah man hit me up
all right i just dropped the uh link in
the uh in the chat for people to go
check out i appreciate you coming on
hopefully uh you've got uh lots and lots
of christmas gifts to uh to hand out to
people and i like your sweatshirt there
trillionaire energy
yeah let's get it
[Laughter]
awesome all right hey guys i love the
show i don't get to watch it much um
nine to five in it but it was a great
day for you guys to do this
wife's shopping my kids are at my mom
and dad's so i'm sitting around
watching the oil market collapse and
watching the best business show
[Laughter]
all right
i just want to warn everybody before the
next guest comes on i've seen a
screenshot where you're about to get
overwhelmed you ready let's pull them up
all right hold on one second
fuzz bear is coming on next all right
i don't know what fuzz bear wants to
talk about
are we gonna need a quick trigger
here we go
fuzz bear you there
oh just kidding just kidding just
kidding just kidding
i just i just pump faked on all of you
this is the last person
and we're bringing on today
you buy a thousand bucks in the store
though you can come on monday on monday
yeah anybody buy a thousand dollars over
the weekend you get you on monday
i'm tired all right fuzzbear you there
yes sir
we got the whole fam
[Laughter]
what's up guys baby
how are you guys
we are awesome
how are you guys where are you guys
based
we are in el paso texas amazing all
right what's everyone's name
i'm buzz bear
[Music]
megan
megan jefferson i'm tanner
i'm writer i'm cooper
you popping up there
i love it what are you guys doing for
thanksgiving
eating turkey eating ham enjoying some
time we played the turkey bowl today
had some great time great family time
enjoying lives who who won the turkey
bowl
yeah the athletes won right of course
everyone else is not athletic unless you
won the real
time quarterback yeah is there an
all-time quarterback
right here
so everyone knows that i've got uh
there's five boys in our family i got
four brothers right and so obviously you
don't have to be a mathematician to know
that's odd numbers two v two with one
yeah
with one all-time quarterback but
there's a fist fight for who gets to be
all-time quarterback every time
because the all-time quarterback always
wins you know you can't lose if you're
the all-time quarterback
well
we used to have a starting five but then
this kid came along
now i'm riding the bench
for basketball
you guys got bitcoin
heck yeah we do
big time we got a bitcoin story for you
all right let me
you want to tell it sure all right you
go for it
so growing up we would always work at
the farm with farmers and so my dad
would put us to work at the farm when we
were younger he would pay us a third of
our age
in dollars per hour so i was about 16 or
about five dollars an hour at the end of
the summer we earned around i mean in
between 200 or 300 dollars all of us
and my dad was like well you guys want
me to pay you in dollars or in bitcoin
and this is back in like 2015 2016.
and i don't know why but we also had a
bitcoin and here we are now
and you held it the whole time
heck yeah
yeah
i'm pretty good we got diamond
that's awesome what kind of farming do
you guys do
pecans chili and peaches
all right and uh i'm an idiot when it
comes to any kind of farming is that
like farming where you got to go and
pick it with your hands or you got like
machinery that does this uh chili and
peaches you picked my hand yeah that's
like hard that's what i like
yeah that that's like real hard grinded
out work
oh yeah it is how old were you guys when
when the kids when you guys started
helping out how old were you
um
the bitcoin story or what no no no
helping out on the farm like five six
years oh about
five four or five years old
listen i don't want to say this in front
of your dad but y'all ain't got enough
bitcoin for having work since you were
five years old
well it took them some convincing but
this guy earned you know like 300 bucks
and jason earned about 280
anyways down to like two
220 bucks and
they decided to go ahead and buy bitcoin
and now they have forty thousand
there's two hundred and something
dollars like twenty four thousand
dollars so here's the here's my favorite
you know he has point four he got point
four bitcoins in the farm which is three
hundred bucks back then
point four big points now
a lot of money about 30 grand
here's my here's my favorite part of
this story is that somehow the uh the
wage got set at a third you're of your
age
that's something that our dad would do i
did all right how old are you you're 10
okay i'm gonna pay three dollars all
but right do we get to three dollars but
i took your age divided by three
we rounded it up to four we were nice
i love you yeah
the the uh uh wha what questions do you
guys have for us what can we do to help
you guys
well we actually so you see this shirt
right here
yeah yeah get up it says bitcoin the
financial assist it's just a rough draft
but uh
we're thinking about starting a little
t-shirt company i don't know if you'd
like to help us out maybe sell some
shirts on your show or give us i'll make
you a deal
i'm gonna go rogue i'll make you a deal
i'll buy the first thousand dollars
worth of those t-shirts
and
i'll take the shirt design and we'll put
it in our store and i'll split the
profits with you
let's do it let's go
now here now here now here's the only
thing we better sell a lot of them damn
shirts get my thousand dollars back
oh we got some really good ideas you
guys will make some serious good sales
all right i feel like that's a fair deal
right that's fair all right
joey but here you ready for this one
that out of that thousand dollars who's
gonna say i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do a
third and they're gonna do a third too
yeah that's the real important question
are you guys part of the union no
my way
you can ask joe
listen kids listen kids let me explain
to you union sucked uh just trust me
about it all right
i got another little story for you but
i've been telling my voice to watch
these jokes i've been watching you guys
from before this show started
um
and i told my son like you gotta watch
the show it's gonna teach you a lot he's
at college and he has a roommate that's
in college that's studying finance and
his roommate who's studying finance has
questions for his test that he goes home
to take and he doesn't know the answer
and guess who knows the answers to the
questions just from watching this show
and the people you guys interviewed
this guy
what is he finance major
he's gonna be a computer engineer and
he's answering the finance questions for
the finance major and he's answering him
because of this show what's your
roommate's name
matthew matthew i ain't going to call it
your last name i want to embarrass you
but what are you doing man
stop watching the internet dude
professors don't know anything
that you gotta you just gotta explain to
him be like listen would you give your
money to your professor and when he says
no but all right they stopped listening
about anything about money
right
that's the fastest way to uh to get them
to stop listening it's like all
financial advisors right when you show
up you say to them oh you want to be my
financial advisor show me your bank
account you got more money than me no
okay you can't be my financial advisor
that's right
right it would be like somebody's
showing up right if you guys got a farm
and somebody shows up and like hey look
man i got some plants in my backyard
you're like well listen why don't you go
get a bigger farm than i thought you
could tell us what to do around here so
yeah go see your garden and i'll see if
you're a good farmer yeah exactly
exactly all right so dm me on twitter
and uh and we'll get the shirts in the
store and then uh based on the chat
right now i think people want the shirts
so uh
oh there's more for that
i appreciate you guys very much watching
today i hope you guys have a great
thanksgiving i'm so glad that uh we
could end with you guys being the uh the
last guest here but uh have a fantastic
thanksgiving and kids listen by the way
every time your dad ever offers you any
money say double it because pomp said so
and you'll be good you'll be set for
life
thanks guys all right guys see you later
see you later bye guys
that dad hates me
these kids hey the way he looked at it
he's like you all got 20 grand for the
summer
30 grand whatever it is now that was
pretty
good all right guys i'm tired we've been
sitting here for how long
four hours and four hours and 42 minutes
that's all i got john john also probably
has to take a poop or something almost
like we worked a real
before you got here i ate 50 mcnuggets
in 13 minutes
why
because that was the live stream i
figured why not that we the the chicken
nugget challenge we thought was 50
nuggets in an hour an hour but i crushed
the challenge
but did you win bitcoin
i just did it for fun do something great
congratulations
that's all you get
that's cool with me all right before we
finish up couple of things real quick
one if you go to the store bestbusiness
show.com you can buy anything in the
store when you buy it
100 you get a shout out on the
show if you buy 500 you'll get a
personalized video if you buy a thousand
dollars you get to come on the show
anyone between now and midnight on
monday if you buy between now and
monday's show we'll bring you on to the
show on monday if you buy between
monday's show and midnight on monday
we'll bring you on tuesday's show we'll
bring as many people on as we possibly
can
as long as you're going to story by a
thousand dollars 500 bucks get a
personalized video hundred dollars you
get a shout out
and if you just went in the store you
bought something you didn't buy a
hundred dollars but you just bought
something we're gonna pick i don't know
maybe one or two people we'll bring you
on the show just as a complete surprise
completely randomly picked
that's first
whoever spends the most money
this weekend between today and monday
night at midnight whoever spends the
most money in the store we will fly you
to miami you get to hang out with us for
a day we'll work around your work
schedule your life social life whatever
we'll get you here gotta hang out with
us for a regular flight
but on top of that do not forget also
that sofi
is offering if you go to sofi.com and
you get their credit card they have a
credit card that gives you back rewards
those rewards if you buy something in
the store between now and monday if you
buy something using the sofi credit card
they would give you up to 50 in rewards
so if you buy something that is worth
less than 50 in the store and they give
you the 50 reward
i'm not a genius but that means that the
item was free
what other two things do you two have to
say i feel like we've been at this for a
while
i appreciate everyone tuning in on a
friday on thanksgiving
remember uh and just have a good
thanksgiving actually nevermind
lady platts a lot your twins are 13
today tell them i say happy birthday i
appreciate it i hope everyone has a good
holiday with their families peace pj kid
have you got anything else
pj kevin proof
shout out run that bad we got to clip
that
i appreciate all the guests showing up
today i appreciate our entire team they
by the way what you guys don't know is
they came back from the holiday to help
us do this so i appreciate them jordy
mack chris lexie chip
uh i'm forgetting people uh but
louis lewis here hello
lois you don't need a shout out he's
good [ __ ] lewis uh and i'm uh t-minus
three seconds so i get the message that
says what do you mean [ __ ] lewis
love you louis uh caroline etc every
single person thank you so much for uh
for helping us do this we appreciate you
guys all watching make sure you like the
video make sure you subscribe to the
channel we'll be back on monday i do not
think we will be doing a
multi-hour live stream for uh cyber
monday but never say never
any last comments
concerns
the outro music isn't playing for a
minute now so let's be out
that's the sign dude appreciate you
joining in have a great weekend john
it's friday
um
[Music]
you